FISCAL REVIEW WILL COME TO
ORDER GOOD MORNING IN RESPONSE
TO THE COVERED NINETEEN
EMERGENCY AND PROTECT EVERYONE
WE ARE LIMITING NONESSENTIAL
GATHERINGS. AND HEARING TO
SOCIAL DISTANCING STAND OR FACE
COVERING GUIDELINES IN
COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE ORDERS
THE SENATORS MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL PRACTICES
IN ORDER TO ENSURE THAT THE
PUBLIC CONTINUES TO HAVE ACCESS
TO OUR LEGISLATIVE PROCESS.
WE'RE HOLDING OUR COMMITTEE
HEARING HERE IN THE CAPITAL
HOWEVER OUR REPRESENTATIVES
FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
AND THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE ARE PARTICIPATING
REMOTELY. AND SO MY COLLEAGUES
WHO ARE PARTICIPATING REMOTELY
PLEASE KEEP YOUR DEVICE MUTED
AND EVERY TIME YOU WISH TO BE
RECOGNIZED. PLEASE USE THE
RAISE YOUR HANDS FEATURE INTHE
PROGRAM AND THEN ONCE I
RECOGNIZE YOU A POP UP WINDOW
WILL APPEAR. HIT THAT. ON MUTE
YOURSELF- I. T. PERSONNEL WILL
PUT YOU BACK ON YOU WHEN YOU
ARE DONE. ONCE RECOGNIZED TO
SPEAK PLEASE MAKE SURE YOU CAN
BE SEEN ON THE SCREEN STATE
YOUR NAME AND THEN YOU CAN
ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE. TO ALLOW
PUBLIC ACCESS WE HAVE ADMITTED
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC TO TWO
HEARING ROOMS HERE IN IN OUR ON
OUR FLOOR ANDY UNTIL EVERYONE.
AND WE WILL BE USING A
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE FOR
THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH TO
TESTIFY TODAY REMOTELY. SO FOR
THOSE WHO WISH TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT REMOTELY THE
PARTICIPANT TOLL FREE NUMBER
AND THE ACCESS CODE IS POSTED
ON OUR COMMITTEE WEBSITE. AND
IT WILL BE ON THE SCREEN BUT I
WILL ANNOUNCE IT TO YOU NOW. IT
IS. 877-692-8957 THE ACCESS
CODE IS. ONE FOUR ZERO SEVEN
SEVEN FOUR FOUR. FOR DETAILED
INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW THAT SYSTEM
WORKS PLEASE REFER EITHER TO
THE STATE SENATE SORT THE
COMMITTEE'S WEBSITE- AND IN
ORDER FOR US TO HEAR YOU
CLEARLY AND TO AVOID ACOUSTIC
FEEDBACK. WHEN YOU ARE CALLED
ON PLEASE MUTE THE DEVICE YOU
WERE WATCHING THE HEARING ON.
IT'S IMPORTANT WE HEAR FROM YOU
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE AND
I WILL MAINTAIN DECORUM DURING
THE HEARING **** CUSTOMARY IN
ANY INDIVIDUAL WHO IS
DESTRUCTIVE MAY BE REMOVED FROM
THE REMOTE MEETING SERVICE OR
HAVE THEIR CONNECTIONS MUTED.
WHILE EVERY EFFORT HAS BEEN
MADE TO STREAMLINE HEARING
PROCESS AND CONDUCT OUR
HEARINGS AND IT'S CLOSE TO THE
SAME MANNER AS IS CUSTOMARY.
THERE MAY BE SOME LAG TIMES FOR
PARTICIPANTS OR ADJUSTING TO
THE USE OF OUR ONLINE TOOLS
PLEASE BE RESPECTFUL AND
PATIENT SO ALL THAT ALL OUR
PARTIES CAN BE HEARD. LET'S IF
WE HAVE. A QUORUM I DON'T THINK
WE HAVE A QUORUM YET THERE ARE
SOME COMMITTEES WE ARE
COMPETING WITH AND I KNOW SOME
MEMBERS. ARE IN THOSE-
ATTENDING THOSE COMMITTEES THEY
WILL. GET HERE SOON SO I THINK
WE WILL BEGIN. AS A
SUBCOMMITTEE- SO OUR BUDGET
COMMITTEE HEARING TODAY WE HAVE
A TOTAL OF EIGHT BILLS ALONG
WITH AN INFORMATIONAL ITEM. OUR
FIRST BILL AB ONE TWENTY NINE
IS THE BUDGET BILL JUNIOR. AND
IT REPRESENTS THE AGREEMENT ON
THE BUDGET BILL THAT WAS
REACHED BETWEEN THE LEGISLATURE
BOTH HOUSES AND THE GOVERNOR.
SO THE- THIS BUDGET BILL JUNIOR
ONE TWENTY NINE A MAN'S THE
BUDGET BILL THAT WE PASSED THE
LEGISLATURE PASSED ON JUNE
FOURTEENTH AND IT DEMANDS IT TO
REPRESENT THAT AGREEMENT THAT
WAS REACHED. THAT BUDGET PLANS
WHICH WE WILL BE ACTING ON
TODAY INCLUDES TWO HUNDRED AND
SIXTY TWO POINT SIX BILLION IN
TOTAL SPENDING A HUNDRED AND
NINETY SIX POINT FOUR BILLION
ITS GENERAL FUND THESE AMOUNTS
ARE ESSENTIALLY SIMILAR TO THE
LEVELS OF THE LEGISLATURE'S
AGREEMENT AND WHAT WE ACTED ON.
ON JUNE FOURTEENTH. WHAT I'M
PARTICULARLY PROUD OF IS THAT
OUR BUDGET BILL PRIORITIZES
RESPONSIBLE BUDGETING. THAT WE
HAVE TWENTY FIVE POINT TWO
BILLION IN TOTAL RESERVES WHICH
ARE THE HIGHEST RESERVES IN THE
STATE'S HISTORY AND WE FULLY
PAID OFF H. CATION DEFERRALS.
THE BILL BEFORE US ALSO
MAINTAINS MOST ALL OF THE
LEGISLATORS AND THE GOVERNOR'S
PRIORITIES REPRESENTED IN THE
LEGISLATURE SECTION AND THE
GOVERNOR'S MAY REVISE. WE ALSO
HAVE SEVEN ADDITIONAL BILLS UP
TODAY WHICH REPRESENTS OUR
FIRST TRAILER BILL PACKAGEFOR
THE TWENTY TWENTY ONE TWENTY
TWO FISCAL YEAR. WE THEN FOLLOW
THAT WITH AN INFORMATION ITEM
ON THE EVICTION MORATORIUM AND
RENT RELIEF. THE BILLS THAT WE
ARE HEARING IN COMMITTEE TODAY
WILL BE TAKEN UP ON THE FLOOR-
THIS EVENING. WE'LL ALSO HAVE A
COMMITTEE HEARING THIS
WEDNESDAY T. HERE TRAILER BILLS
THAT WOULD BE TAKEN UP ON THE
FLOOR THURSDAY. NIGHT BELIEVE
THAT WE HAVE ACHIEVED CORE NOW
SO- MR STEPPING SHOW WOULD YOU
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. THE
SENATORS SCANNER I'M HERE
SKINNER HERE. NIELSEN. NELSON
HERE COPYRIGHT. CORTESE CORTESE
HERE DOLLY DOLLY HERE TO RAZA
THE RESOLUTION HERE EGMOND. A
MAN HERE GROWTH. COM LONGER
COME OVER HERE LAYERED. BLAIR
HERE MAGUIRE SHE BELINDA'S. MAN
MAN HERE NEWMAN. UNTIL ABOUT
GLOBAL HERE PAN AIR IN HERE
STERN STERN HERE BY CASKEY. WE
HAVE A CHIEF CORN THANK YOU. SO
TO CONTINUE FARM. FOR THE
COMMITTEE HEARING TODAY WE WILL
HEAR ALL OF THE BILLS I
MENTIONED AND THEN WE'LL HAVE
ONE HOUR FOR PUBLIC COMMENT ON
ALL OF THE BILLS THAT WE'VE
HEARD AFTER THE PUBLIC COMMENT
WE WILL VOTE ON THE BILLS PRIOR
TO MOVING TO THE INFORMATIONAL
PART OF THE HEARING AND THAT'S
THE LAST ITEM ON THE HEARING-
MR VICE CHAIR YOUR COMMENTS.
THAT I'M SURE ARE WE NOW
THEY'RE DEBATING THE BILL OR
THIS JUST PREFERENCE AND CAUSES
YOUR PREFERENCE FOR MINUTES
YOU'RE PRACTICING COMMENTS.
WELL BUT THEN I'LL JUST RESERVE
WHENEVER WE GET A LOT. COMPASS
THAT I WILL HAVE TO START OFF
THOUGH SINCE WE'RE GOING TO BE
DEALING WITH THE ENTIRE BUDGET
HERE WITH THE SO CALLED TRAILER
BILLS AND I CALL THEM SO
CALLED. TRAILER BILLS. THIS IS
NOT AN OPEN PROCESS. IT HAS
BEEN FOR A NUMBER OF YEARS. WE
NOW HAVE GOTTEN RID OF THE
CONFERENCE COMMITTEE ARE
EXPECTED NOT TO EVER COME BACK.
LIKE NO BIG DEAL. THERE'S
ALWAYS BEEN CONFERENCE
COMMITTEES TO RESOLVE THE
DIFFERENCES IN THE TWO VERSIONS
OF THE BUDGET. FAMILY SENATE
EDITED THE LIBERTY FORUM AND
I'LL GIVE YOU AN EXAMPLE.
DURING THE VERY DIFFICULT
BUDGET OF A FEW YEARS AGO FORTY
FIVE BILLION IN THE RED AT
ELEVEN O'CLOCK AT NIGHT THE
CONFERENCE COMMITTEE'S MEETING.
AND DECIDE ON D. FUNDS ARE
LOCAL FAIRS. THEY'RE GONNA. AND
I RAISED AN OBJECTION THAT WE
NEEDED TO DISCUSS. WHICH WE DID.
AND I SAID CAN'T WE PUT THIS
OVER. THESE FARES ARE VERY
CRITICAL. I GAVE REASONS. WE
DID AND I SAID MR SHARIF WHO
WAS THE ADVOCATE FOR THE FAIR'S
VOCAL FIRST SAID HE AND I CAN
WORK OUT SOMETHING HERE I THINK
WITH THE MAJORITY. KEEP OUR
FUNDS- IF THERE'S A LIFE. NOW
BUT FOR THAT FOR A MINUTE
CONFERENCE COMMITTEE. AT THAT
NIGHT THE SHARES WERE GONE.
THAT IS A MARRIAGE. TO AND HERE
WE'VE GOT A BUNCH OF BILLS
FLOWING ALONG NOW PREVAILS
TRAILER BILLS AND MORE TRADE
DEALS I GUESS EIGHT TODAY THERE
WILL BE MORE WE STARTED OFF
WITH AROUND NINETY I THANK END
OF WEEK LAST WE HAD THIRTY ONE
AT PLAY. IN THIS BUDGET CAN GO
INTO NEXT YEAR. SO WHAT WE'RE
VOTING ON IS NOT REALLY THE
BUDGET. IT'S A BUDGETING
PROCESS AND I OBJECT TO THAT I
LIKE THAT THE RECORD ON THE
RECORD IT'S A DISSERVICE TO THE
PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA AND TWO WE
MEMBERS. ADVOCATING OUR
AUTHORITY AS THE EYES AND EARS
AND VOICE OF THE MILLION PEOPLE
WE EACH REPRESENT. THANK YOU
AS- VICE CHAIR NELSON. SO LET
US BEGIN WITH THE PRESENTATION
OF AB ONE TWENTY NINE THE
BUDGET BILL JUNIOR FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
DEPARTMENT FINANCE ARE YOU
READY TO PRESENT. YES I AM
MANAGER THANK YOU CAN YOU
PLEASE GIVE YOUR NAME AND THEN
PROCEED. YES ACTUALLY WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE- GOOD
MORNING MADAM CHAIR VICE CHAIR
NELSON MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE- I WILL BE PRESENTING
ON SEVERAL BILLS TODAY I'VE
ALREADY MENTIONED BEGINNING
WITH AB ONE TWENTY NINE EIGHTY
ONE TWENTY NINE IS- A BUDGET
BILL JUNIOR THAT AMENDS THE
LEGISLATURE'S BUDGET PLAN
PURSUANT TO EIGHTY ONE TWENTY
EIGHT- AND THEN THERE WILL BE
ACCOMPANYING. CAN THE BILLS. SO
WE'VE MADE A LOT OF PROGRESS IN
THIS B. B. J. TRUSTEE
MINISTRATIONS CONCERNS- WE
RAISED ABOUT THE DEPENDENCE ON
HIGHER REVENUE FORECAST. THAT
MIGHT NOT MATERIALIZE AS WELL
AS OVER COMMITTING TO ONGOING
INVESTMENTS WHICH REDUCED. THE
BILITY TO RESPOND SHOULD BE
FACING ECONOMIC DOWNTURN- OR
DROP IN THE STOCK MARKET. THIS
JUNE TWENTY EIGHTH PACKAGE-
BEFORE YOU REALIZE ON THE
ADMINISTRATION'S MORE CAUTIOUS
REVENUE PROJECTIONS AND
INCLUDES AN EIGHTY FIVE TO
FIFTEEN. ONE TIME TOO I'M GOING
RATIO IN THIS- THIS FOR
DISCRETIONARY FUNDS AND IS MORE
IN LINE WITH THE MAIN
PROVISIONS NINETY TEN RATIO. IT
ALSO SUCKS AWAY MORE RESERVES
AND CONDITIONS SOME INVESTMENTS
AND FUTURE PREPARATIONS TO
ALLOW THE LEGISLATURE AND THE
ADMINISTRATION TO CONSIDER THE-
PHYSICAL CONDITION AT THAT
TIME- THE PACKAGE ALSO INCLUDES
MANY SHARED PRIORITIES SUCH AS
UNIVERSAL. TRANSITIONAL
KINDERGARTEN EXPANDING MEDI CAL
COVERAGE TO MORE OLDER
INDIVIDUALS IMMEDIATE RELIEF IN
THE FORM OF THE GOLDEN STATE
STIMULUS TO. ADDITIONAL
INVESTMENTS IN SMALL BUSINESS-
SMALL BUSINESSES THAT HAVE BEEN
DISPROPORTIONATELY. IMPACTED BY
THE PANDEMIC. ENDING CHILD
CARES. AND PROVIDE RATES-
RECORD INVESTMENTS IN HOUSING
AND HOMELESSNESS AND MANY
OTHER- IMPORTANT AND
SIGNIFICANT PROGRAMS- IT TOOK
TOO MANY TO MENTION AT THIS
POINT- WE LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUE DISCUSSIONS WITH THE
LEGISLATURE AS WE WORK TOWARD A
FINAL BUDGET AGREEMENT THAT
CONTINUES TO UPHOLD OUR SHARED
PRIORITIES- AS WELL AS MAINTAIN
FISCAL RESILIENCE-
INSTRUCTIONAL BALANCE. WITH
THAT- I'M HAPPY TO RESPOND TO
ANY QUESTIONS AND- JOINED BY
MANY OF MY COLLEAGUES WHO CAN
RESPOND IN MORE DETAIL TO SOME
OF THOSE QUESTIONS AS WELL
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MISLI LET'S SEE IF THERE ARE
QUESTIONS BY ANY OF MY-
POLITICS. ONE DAY MADE VIRTUAL
YES A SENATOR PAM. THANK YOU SO
VERY MUCH I AM CHAIR AND THANK
YOU- ACTUALLY FOR YOUR
PRESENTATION I DO HAVE A FEW
QUESTIONS- I APPRECIATE- SOME
ANSWERS IN REGARDS TO THE
BHAJAN FIRST OF ALL I JUST
WANNA START OFF BY SAYING THAT-
REALLY DO APPRECIATE ALL THE
WORK THAT WAS DONE AND I THINK
THAT- CERTAINLY THIS IS A
HISTORIC BUDGET ADDRESSES-
MANY. ISSUES BOTH SHORT TERM
AND LONG TERM- DOES THE STATE'S
BEEN DEALING WITH INCLUDING
ISSUES THAT GO ALL THE WAY BACK
TO THE- GREAT RECESSION OVER A
DECADE AGO SO I VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE THAT BUT ALSO MAKE
NOTE THAT WE'RE IN THE MIDST OF
A PANDEMIC AND ALTHOUGH WE'RE-
HOPEFULLY- GETTING THROUGH
PARTS OF IT AND IT'S STILL
CERTAINLY. VERY MUCH- GOING ON
RIGHT NOW SO. I DO HAVE A
COUPLE QUESTIONS REGARDING
PUBLIC HEALTH FUNDING THAT I
WOULD LIKE TO ASK THE PART OF
FINANCE. SO FIRST OF ALL- I
KNOWN THE REGIONAL LEGISLATIVE
PROPOSAL- THERE WAS FUNDING FOR
PUBLIC HEALTH INFRASTRUCTURE I
DO HAVE AN UNDERSTANDING THAT
TRUMP ADMINISTRATION'S POINT OF
VIEW. THAT PERHAPS FOR THIS
UPCOMING FISCAL YEAR TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO- THAT- MUCH OF THAT
COULD BE FUNDED THROUGH FEDERAL
FUNDS. CAN YOU ADDRESS THE
COMMITMENT OF THE
ADMINISTRATION TO ACTUALLY
SPEND US FEDERAL FUNDS ON
PUBLIC HEALTH INFRASTRUCTURE
INCLUDING PUBLIC HEALTH
WORKFORCE. LABORATORY CAPACITY
AND INFORMATION TECHNOLOGY
CAPACITY- NOT JUST PHYSICALLY
FOR COVE IT BUT MORE BROADLY
AND REALIZING CO THAT IS SORT
OF THE ACTIVE THING BUT WE HAVE
A LOT OF OTHER ISSUES AS WELL
PUBLIC HEALTH- SO CAN. YOU KNOW
STAY LOCAL HEALTH DEPARTMENTS
ARE. MAKING INVESTMENTS IF YOU
TRY TO HIRE SOMEONE YOU NEED TO
BE ABLE TO COMMIT THAT TEY'RE
GOING TO HAVE A JOB FOR LONGER
THAN A YEAR ARE PART OF THE
YEAR- IF YOU'RE GOING TO MAKE
AND YOU KNOW. BILL THAT YOUR
LABORATORY CAPACITY NEED TO
KNOW YOU'RE ABLE TO HAVE ON
GOING FUNDING TO HELP CONTINUE
TO SUSTAIN THAT LABORATORY
OTHERWISE WHY MAKE THIS INITIAL
INVESTMENTS. AS WELL AS OF
COURSE YOU KNOW I YOU KNOW
INFORMATION TECHNOLOGY TAKES A
WHILE SO. IN FINANCE SPEAK TO
THE NATURE OF THE FEDERAL FUNDS
THAT WILL BE SPENT IN THIS
COMING FISCAL YEAR. GIVEN THE
FACT THAT WE SIDE NOT
ALLOCATED. SIGNIFICANT FUNDS AT
LEAST CERTAINLY NOT AT THE
SCALE. ON WHICH THE LEGISLATURE
ORIGINALLY PROPOSED. CERTAINLY
SOME PAN- AND I'LL JUST I WILL
TO FURTHER QUESTION- IN REGARDS
TO THE FEDERAL FUNDING. TO MY
COLLEAGUE BUT I WOULD. WOULD
LIKE TO POINT OUT- AND
HIGHLIGHT YOUR POINT ABOUT. THE
ADDITIONAL FUNDS THAT ARE
INCLUDED IN THIS BUDGET FOR
PUBLIC HEALTH- THAT BEGAN IN
THAT YEAR PLUS ONE SO THAT'S
TWENTY TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE
OF THREE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS- AND- THAT IS AN
ONGOING- INVESTMENT SO IN
REGARDS TO. THE AMOUNTS. OF THE%
FEDERAL FUNDS I THINK THAT
THERE WAS THE IDEA THAT THEY
WOULD THERE IS THERE'S A
SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF FEDERAL
FUNDS. TO PROVIDE ASSISTANCE
TO. LOCAL PUBLIC HEALTH-
OFFICES IN THE BUDGET YEAR AND
THAT THIS WOULD ALSO PROVIDE A
PLANNING YEAR FOR ANY
ADMINISTRATION LEGISLATURE
STAKEHOLDERS TO GET OGETHER
TO. LOOK AT WAYS TO REALLY-
REFORM THE PUBLIC HEALTH SYSTEM
AND THAT'S WHY YOU SEE THE ON
GOING FUNDING IN THE OUT YEARS-
BUT I WILL DEFER TO MY
COLLEAGUE- ADAM DARCY OR OTHERS
WERE ON THE LINE FOR MORE.
SPECIFICS ABOUT THE FEDERAL
FUNDING THANK YOU. MORE SYNERGY
SALT REFINED- YOU KNOW ONE
THING I'D LIKE TO START OFF BY
RUNNING OUT- IS THAT THE BUDGET
CONTAINS ONE POINT OH EIGHT
BILLION. FOR GENERAL CORPORATE
RESPONSE SO THE STATUS IS VERY
RESOURCE. IN THE BUDGET YEAR
RESPONSE TO A PUBLIC HEALTH
NEEDS- ALSO YOU KNOW THERE ARE
A SIGNIFICANT RULES FEDERAL
FUNDING THAT WE ARE. WORKING
THROUGH- AND WE WILL BE SENDING
PLANS FOR THE SPENDINGS THE
LEGISLATURE IN THE VERY NEAR
TERM- AND BOTH THOSE DOLLARS-
ABOUT SEVEN HUNDRED FIFTY
MILLION IS FOR IMMUNIZATIONS
AND AN OUTRAGE- THERE'S ALSO
EIGHT HUNDRED. PLUS MILLION FOR
SCHOOL TESTING- AND- AGAIN THE
SCHOOLS BACK OPEN AND THERE ARE
OTHER GRANTS THAT WILL BE
GETTING WITH- THE GLVC- I GET
THOSE OF YOUR. OKAY WELL-
INVALID MAY I THINK THAT THAT'S
THE NO ONE WOULD DOUBT THAT I
AM PERHAPS ONE THE LEADING
ADVOCATES FOR VACCINATION BUT I
WOULD POINT OUT THAT FUNDING
FOR VACCINATION IS IMPORTANT AS
IT IS AND WE CERTAINLY NEED TO
GET A VACCINATION RATES UP. IS
NOT NECESSARILY PUBLIC HEALTH
INFRASTRUCTURE FUNDING SO I AM
HOPING THAT THIS YEAR YOU
TALKED ABOUTTHE ONE BILLION.
FOR COVETED- RESPONSE AND I
ALSO POINT TO POINT OUT THAT
DOES MORE TO PUBLIC HEALTH AND
JUST COPE AND OBVIOUSLY CODES
ARE BIG ISSUE- THAT- HOPEFULLY-
I LOOK FORWARD TO SEEING-
FURTHER DESCRIPTIONS OF THE
ADMINISTRATION'S COMMITMENT TO
USING FEDERAL FUNDS THIS COMING
YEAR TO BEGIN THAT WORK ON
INFRASTRUCTURE FUNDING. THAT
WERE NOT SIMPLY- SAYING THAT
WE'RE GONNA SPEND A WHOLE YEAR
DOING PLANNING- WE CAN WE
ALREADY KNOW FROM THE PANDEMIC
SIMILAR WEAKNESSES- SO I DO
LOOK FOR THAT THE OTHER
QUESTION I DO HAVE AND I
APPRECIATE- DIRECTLY BRINGING
MENTIONING IT IS THAT- YEAH AND
CAN YOU- SO I JUST WANTED. TO
HEAR FROM YOU THAT THERE IS A
DEFINITE COMMITMENT- FOR TWENTY
TWO TWENTY THREE. FISCAL YEAR
BUDGETS SO EXPECT TO SEE THE
END OF JANUARY BUDGET NOT
SOMETHING WE HAGGLE OVER FOR AT
LEAST AT LEAST THREE HUNDRED
MILLION- THAT IS PROPOSED IN
THIS BUDGET PACKAGE WHICH
ADMITTEDLY IS FOR. SALE IN SOME
SENSES- WE'RE REALLY DOING A
BUDGET FOR THIS COMING FISCAL
YEAR YOU DO ANOTHER BUT FOR THE
NEXT ONE BUT THAT THAT IS THERE
IS A COMMITMENT FROM THE
ADMINISTRATION THAT THE THREE
AT LEAST THREE HUNDRED MILLION
FOR PUBLIC HEALTH
INFRASTRUCTURE WILL BE AND- THE
BUDGET PROPOSAL FROM THE
ADMINISTRATION FROM THE OUTSET
THAT WE'RE NOT GOING TO BE
HAGGLING OVER THAT. FOR THE
NEXT FISCAL YEAR SO. THAT'S A
COMMITMENT RIGHT NOW TO DO THAT.
YES WE HAVE THE- BELT THE THREE
MILLION INTO THE SYSTEM AND
AGAIN- WE THINK IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT TO HAVE THOSE
CONVERSATIONS AROUND- WHAT-PUBLIC HEALTH OUGHT TO LOOK
LIKE- SHOULD LOOK LIKE BEST
PRACTICES AT THE LOCAL LEVEL
AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO HAVING
THOSE DISCUSSIONS- THE
LEGISLATURE AND STAKEHOLDERS.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR THAT
COMMITMENT- I LOOK FOR TO THOSE
CONVERSATIONS THANK YOU. THANK
YOU LET'S SEE IF THERE'S ANY
OTHER QUESTIONS. BUT AS SENATOR
NIELSEN GO AHEAD. LET ME FOLLOW
MY DISTINGUISHED COLLEAGUES.
QUESTION THERE. WERE GOING TO
LOOK FORWARD TO CONTACT WHAT
THE HECK DOES THAT MEAN WHAT IS
THE FORUM FINANCE FOR THIS
CONVERSATION HOW WILL THE
ACTUAL LANGUAGE BE FORMULATED
AND PRESENTED TO THIS HONORABLE
BODY FOR OUR REVIEW. AND HOW
COULD WE THE MINORITY PARTY
CAN YOU ANSWER THAT QUESTION.
YES I GOT IT I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT TO HAVE- ALL THE
STAKEHOLDERS AT THE TABLE AND-
DAVE THE LANGUAGE AT THIS
POINT- IS SOMETHING THAT IS
UNDER DISCUSSION- SHOULD BE
UNDER SECTION IN THE NEAR
FUTURE- THOSE ARE WILL BE
PUBLIC FORUMS AND- STAKEHOLDERS
AND OTHERS- WE'LL BE ABLE TO.
PROVIDE THEIR INPUT. THAT IS A
NON ANSWER. WHAT SPECIFIC
BOROUGH WHAT ROOM MEETING WITH
HOME WHO WILL BE INVITED TO THE
PARTY. I DON'T SEE THAT THE
REPUBLICANS HAVE BEEN INVITED
TO ANY OF THESE CONVERSATIONS
AM I CORRECT THANKS THE LAST.
I'M OF THE DISCUSSIONS ON THE
PUBLIC HEALTH HAVE NOT- TAKEN
PLACE YET AND- THAT'S SOMETHING
THAT WE CAN PLAN IN THE NEAR
FUTURE. LAND TWO DOESN'T CUT IT
WITH ME WE'RE VOTING NOW WE'RE
NOT PLANNING NOW THIS IS THE
BUDGET THAT WE'RE DEALING WITH.
SO YOU HAVE NOT ANSWERED THAT
QUESTION PURPOSELY I GATHER.
TWO HUNDRED MILLION IS REPORTED
TO BE CUT FROM LOCAL GOVERNMENT.
IN THIS PROPOSAL. IS THAT
CORRECT. BUT WE WOULD BE
PROVIDING THEM. THE HELP THE
COST A DAY OF INCURRED WITH THE
CV BATTLE. I'M NOT EXACTLY SURE
YOUR QUESTIONS UNDER NELSON. IS
THERE ANY FUNDING BEING REDUCED
THAT HAD BEEN APPORTIONED OR
PROMISED TO LOCAL GOVERNMENT.
BY THE STATE IN OUR BUDGET. ARE
WE GIVING THEM LESS THAN THEY
WERE INFORMED THEY WOULD GET. I
WOULD SAY THAT BROADLY- THERE
ARE FEDERAL DOLLARS ARE DOLLARS
THAT WERE PROVIDED- AND THAT WE
ARE IMPLEMENTING THROUGH THIS
BUDGET TO LOCAL GOVERNMENTS.
AND THOSE DOLLARS- HAVE NOT
CHANGED. AT EIGHT THEY DID WHAT
THOSE DOLLARS OF WHAT FEDERAL
R. DOLLARS- TO LOCAL ENTITIES
pTHE PASS THROUGH DOLLARS THE
FEDERAL DOLLARS IS THAT
CORRECT. THEY HAVE NOT CHANGED.
OKAY SO HOW WILL THIS. PENDING
DEAL AS A PRODUCT OF THE COLD
CONVERSATION. HOW WILL THAT BE
RESULT WHO'S GOING TO BE
INVITED TO THAT MEETING AND
WHERE WILL THE MEETING BE HELD.
WELL I THINK THAT IT IS
SPECIFICALLY IN REGARDS TO THE
FIRST QUESTION ABOUT PUBLIC
HEALTH EXPENDITURES- I THINK
THAT THE IDEA IS TO ULTIMATELY
HAVE A BUDGET REQUEST THAT
WOULD BE- I DID YOU KNOW.
THROUGH B. C. P. PUBLIC
HEARINGS- OTHER DISCUSSIONS-
THAT ARE OPEN TO THE PUBLIC
THAT'S THE THAT IS THE PLAN
FOR- MANY OF THE INVESTMENTS
GOING FORWARD. WELL YOU SEE WE
DON'T MUCH MAKE THINGS
AVAILABLE TO THE PUBLIC
ANYMORE. BUT WE'RE GONNA HAVE
SOME PUBLIC COMMENT APPARENTLY
LATER HERE TODAY. BUT I'M QUITE
SURE IT WILL BE ALONG THE LINES
OF THE PUBLIC COMMENT WE HAD
THE END OF LAST WEEK- I GUESS
WAS YEAH THE YEAR OF. THE FIRST
OR LAST WEEK. WELL WE HAD A
BUDGET MEETING HERE RIGHT HERE
AND THEN WE HAVE PUBLIC COMMENT.
HOW DOES THAT OCCURS. DID THE
PUBLIC GET FINANCE WELL I GUESS
SO BUT NOT REALLY. THEY GOT TO
CALL IN GET ON A LIST. THROUGH
A MODERATOR AND I GOT TO SAY
I'M SO SORRY AND I'M
REPRESENTING SUCH AND SUCH AND
I'M FOR THE BUDGET RUN GETS A
BUNCH THAT WAS THE EXTENT OF
PUBLIC INPUT. NOT ANYBODY TRY
TO ARGUE WITH ME THAT THAT'S
PUBLIC INPUT. IT'S NOT IT'S A
JOKE. IF WE'RE GOING TO
CONTINUE THIS AS WE ARE IN
OTHER COMMITTEES AS WELL AS A
BUDGET. LET'S JUST HAVE THE
MODERATOR TAKE A POLL. OF THOSE
WHO ARE CALLING A POLL. SHAKER
NAME WHO THEY REPRESENT AND
THEREFORE AGAINST. AND THEN
GIVE US A TALLY WHY WASTE OUR
TIME SITTING AROUND FOR HOURS.
WAITING FOR THIS FILE PUBLIC
COMMENT. THE LAST THING YOU
TELL ME YOU THINK THAT'S A
PARTICIPATORY PROCESS EITHER
FROM THE MEMBER STANDPOINT OR
THE CITIZENS OF CALIFORNIA'S
STANDPOINT. WELL I DEFERRED TO
THE CHAIR AND THE LEGISLATURE
FOR THAT DECISION. ALL RIGHT
WELL THAT'S A CONTINUED OF THE-
ANOTHER NON ANSWER ABOUT
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH FOR THE
MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES THERE IS
NO HEALTH DEPARTMENTS IN OUR
COUNTIES SH ARE THEY GOING TO
GET ALL THE RESOURCES THEY NEED
BY THIS BUDGET. THAT WE'RE
VOTING ON TODAY. I WILL DEFER
TO MY COLLEAGUE TO SPEAK TO THE
BEHAVIOR HEALTH INVESTMENTS.
LET'S GO ON TO ANOTHER QUESTION
IS GOING TO BE RELATED TO
ANOTHER BILL THIS IS A. B. R.
S. B. ONE FIVE TWO GOT THE
RECALL. THE LAST TIME AROUND
THE US SECTOR STATE HAD LITTLE
SLUSH FUND. OF MONEY. HE WAS
PUTTING OUT NO BID CONTRACT.
GOT ROUNDLY CRITICIZED FOR THAT.
LOOKED LIKE IT WAS A VERY
PARTISAN FAN AND I'M USING A
STRONG WORD. BUT WE'RE GOING TO
DO THE SAME THING HERE. IT
SEEMS TO BE A PART OF THE PLAN
AM I CORRECT THAT WE'RE GONNA.
DO A LITTLE RECALL VANCE HEAR
FINANCE DO YOU KNOW ANYTHING
ABOUT THAT. FUNDING OF THIS
RECALL FUND MONEY. THE DISTRICT
STATE. YES SENATOR EIGHTY ONE
FIFTY TWO- THE ELECTIONS BILL
DOES- PROVIDE THIRTY FIVE
MILLION FOR THE SECRETARY OF
STATE TO SUPPORT STATEWIDE AND
COUNTY COSTS RELATED TO
MINISTRY THAT RECALL ELECTION-
THERE WAS ALREADY A TWO HUNDRED
FIFTY MILLION PROVIDED- FOR
LOCALS TO ADMINISTER THAT
RECALL. ELECTION AS WELL.
SENATOR NELSON WE HAVE THAT
ITEM IS A SPECIFIC ITEMS YOU
WILL WILLBE WILL BRING IT UP
ON YOUR RIGHT NOW TO BE FAIR I
BROUGHT THAT UP IN ADVANCE
WE'LL DEAL WITH IT AGAIN WHEN
WE GET THERE. THANK YOU- DISH
ALL GIVES CAUSE FOR A NO VOTE
ON THE WHOLE BUDGET- I ALSO
JUST WANT TO CLARIFY THAT IT'S-
OUR PROCESS FOR- AT LEAST BE
OUR BUDGET COMMITTEE AND THE
LEGISLATURE'S PROCESS FOR
PUBLIC INPUT IS WAS NOT
PROBABLY INAPPROPRIATE LINE OF
QUESTIONING FOR THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE CERTAINLY FOR THE
FUTURE MONEY. AS WAS INDICATED
IN THE QUESTIONING BY SNATOR
PAN TO DEPARTMENT FINANCE THE
FUNDING FOR THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS FOR BEYOND WHAT THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT IS GIVING
THE FUNDING THAT THE GENERAL
FUND WOULD BE PROVIDING WOULD
BE GIVEN IN THE YEAR AFTER SO
THERE IS. POP AS PLENTY OF TIME
FOR STAKEHOLDER INVOLVEMENT IN
THAT AND IN REGARDS TO THE
ENTIRE BUDGET WELL THERE ARE.
SOME VARIATIONS IN TERMS OF
WHAT WE ADOPTED ON JUNE
FOURTEENTH THE- MOST EVERY
ACTION WAS VETTED IN COMMITTEE
AND- EVERY COMMITTEE HAD PUBLIC
COMMENT AND EVERY HEARING THAT
WE HAVE HAS PUBLIC COMMENT PLUS
AS WE KNOW THE BILLS HAVE BEEN
IMPRINT FOR SEVENTY TWO HOURS
WHICH ALLOWS FOR PUBLIC TO
ALERT. ANY OF US REGARDING
CONCERNS THEY MAY HAVE NOW I
CAN IMAGINE YOU'RE GOING TO
RAISE YOUR MIKE AND- CRITICIZED
THAT PROCESS HOWEVER IT IS A
PROCESS THAT WE HAVE FOLLOWED
THE BEFORE EVEN REMOTE HEARINGS
WE DIDN'T NECESSARILY HAVE MORE
IN PUBLIC INVOLVEMENT IN OUR
COMMITTEE PROCESS OR OUR BUDGET
HEARINGS AND IN FACT WE'RE
PROBABLY HEARING FROM A BROADER
ARRAY BECAUSE OF THE FACT THAT
PEOPLE DON'T HAVE TO. ATTEND
PERSONALLY TRAVEL TO
SACRAMENTO- RED TAG TIME I WILL
ALLOW YOU TO MAKE ADDITIONAL
COMMENTS YOU'D LIKE AND THEN I
WOULD LIKE TO CALL ON SENATOR
GROVE AND SENATOR EARLIER.
SENATOR NELSON DID YOU WANT TO
MAKE AN ADDITIONAL COMMENT.
WELL. RIGHT NOW. OKAY SENATOR
GROWTH YOU HAVE THE FLOOR.
THANK YOU- MADAM CHAIR I DID-
THANK YOU AS DIRECTOR LEE FOR-
ALWAYS BEING WILLING TO HAVE A
CONVERSATION WITH ME I DO
REALLY VERY MUCH APPRECIATE
THAT. AND THERE ARE A LOT OF
GOOD THINGS HERE- IN THIS
BUDGET YOU KNOW THE FUNNY FOR
TRIAL COURTS IS IMPORTANT
BECAUSE OF THE PANDEMIC BACKLOG
WE HAVE TO HAVE THE FUNDING FOR
TRIALS COURTS AFTER TRIAL
COURTS AFTER SCHOOL EDUCATION
PROGRAMS EARLY INTERVENTION.
PRESCHOOL- YOU KNOW CHILDCARE
AVAILABILITY WE ALL KNOW THAT-
SPECIFICALLY DURING COVETED A
LOT OF PARENTS THAT WERE
DECLARED ESSENTIAL THAT WE'RE
ABLE TO WORK STRUGGLE TO CHILD
CARE SO. THERE ARE A LOT OF
GOOD THINGS IN HERE THERE'S
ALSO- SOME VAGUE INFORMATION-
ABOUT APPROPRIATING TO- TWO
POINT THREE BILLION
APPROXIMATELY DOLLARS. FOR
DROUGHT RELIEF CAN YOU TELL ME
IF ANY OF THAT. IS GOING TO GO
TO- SAY FOR INSTANCE THAT THE
BILL THAT'S GOING TO BE
BUILDING ON FIVE FIVE NINE FOR
THE CURRENT- THE FRANKLIN
CANAL. WHICH HAS A SUBSIDENCE
ISSUE THAT CAN'T DELIVER WATER
TO THE CENTER VALLEY OR
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA BECAUSE OF
THE SUBSIDED. THIS BILL ALSO
AND I KNOW I'M TRYING TO TIE A
BILL INTO IT- DOES A ST LOUIS
CANAL CALIFORNIA HOW GOOD I CAN
OTHER PROJECTS. IS ANY OF THIS
MONEY GOING TO GO TO SOME OF
THOSE PROJECTS OR IS THIS BEING
USED FOR SOMETHING COMPLETELY
DIFFERENT. ARE YOU. THANK YOU
THANK YOU FOR THE QUESTION
CENTER GROVE- I AM GOING TO
DEFER TO MY COLLEAGUE- TO
RESPOND TO THAT QUESTION ON TO
SPECIFIC PROJECTS. THANK YOU
MA'AM. THANK YOU I GOT WAS A
PART OF FINANCE- SO YEAH WITHIN
THE FUNDING THAT IS SET ASIDE
FOR GROUND WATER RESILIENCE
THERE'S ABOUT A HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS THAT IS SET ASIDE FOR
WATER CONVEYANCE AND SO THERE'S
A FEW DIFFERENT. TYPES OF
PROJECTS THAT WOULD BE ELIGIBLE
AND SO THAT THAT HUNDRED
MILLION IS CURRENTLY IN THIS
BUDGET. FOLLOW AT I MEAN JUST
AS A FOLLOW UP SIR THAT HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS COULD BE USED
FOR THE CONVEYANCE SYSTEM AND
FOR THE FREIGHT FROM CANAL OR
THAT. WHEN WILL THAT LANGUAGE
BE DEVELOPED I'M JUST. TRYING
TO FIND OUT HOW WE- CAN
PARTICIPATE IN THAT BECAUSE NOT
ONLY FOR THE CENTER VALLEY THAT
PRODUCES. FOOD FOR THE WORLD-
BUT ALSO THE CONVEYANCE SYSTEM
DOWN TO LOS ANGELES. YES FOR
FRANK HURLEY IS ONE OF THE
POTENTIAL ELIGIBLE PROJECTS SO
AS PART OF THE LANGUAGE IT DOES
IDENTIFY THAT. THERE SHOULD BE
AN ADEQUATE NON STATE COST
SHARE MATCH- BECAUSE YOU KNOW
IN THE CASE OF BRIAN TO THE
OTHERS. D. AZ OKAY THERE IS
SOME LANGUAGE AROUND A NON
STATE COST SHARES- BUT FRANK
KERN IS IT WOULD BE ONE OF THE
POTENTIAL ELIGIBLE PROJECTS
WITHIN THIS FUNDING. BUT WE
HAVE NOT SET ASIDE. WHAT'S THIS
PROJECT WILL GET WHAT SPECIFIC
SET OF DOLLARS BUT IN GENERAL
THAT IS ONE OF THE POTENTIAL
ALGAL PROJECTS. THANK YOU SIR
VERY MUCH FOR THAT- ONE MORE
QUESTION THAT I HAD- POSSIBLY
TOO IS- IS THERE ANY CONCERN BY
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AT
THE DAY AFTER THIS BUDGET NEEDS
ONE TIME EXPENDITURES THAT WE'D
BE RETURNING BACK TO THE
OPERATING DEFICITS- BY TWENTY
TWENTY TO TWENTY TWENTY THREE
IS THERE A CONCERN THERE. THAT
THAT WE WILL GO BACKWARDS. YES
THANK YOU FOR THE QUESTION I
WOULD LIKE JUST TO POINT OUT
THE LARGE RESERVES THAT WE
HAVE- MORE SWEETS ACTUALLY
ADICIONAL. DOLLARS ABOVE THE
MAY REVISION. AND AS ALWAYS WE-
ARE. LOOKING TO BUY TO
RESILIENCE AND STRUCTURAL-
BEING HAVING THIS- STRUCTURALLY
SOUND BUDGET IN THE OUT YEARS
AND THAT'S SOMETHING THAT WE-
ARE CONCERNED ABOUT WHICH IS
WHY. THE EMPHASIS ON ONE TIME
SPENDING VERSUS ONGOING
SPENDING. THANK YOU MA'AM. I'M
I DO WANT TO FOLLOW UP ON THE
COMMENT FROM MY COLLEAGUE FROM
SACRAMENTO AS WELL WHO OPENED
UP THE QUESTION AND ANSWER
PORTION- I DO HAVE A CONCERN
ABOUT THE REDUCTION IN THE
LOCAL PUBLIC HEALTH OFFICERS.
YOU KNOW WITH THE PANDEMIC THAT
IT DEFINITELY SHOWED A LOT OF
THINGS A LOT OF THINGS THAT WE
WERE DEFICIENT AND WHETHER IT
WAS SAM. PP EMERGENCY MEDICAL
SUPPLIES BUT ALSO- OUR PUBLIC
HEALTH OFFICERS WERE NOT READY
TO TAKE ON THIS PARTICULAR.
MASSIVE WORKLOAD OF THE
PANDEMIC. I KNOW WE STRUGGLED
WITH IT IN OUR COMMUNITIES- THE
THREE COUNTIES THAT I REPRESENT
AND I KNOW THAT. TALKING TO MY
COLLEAGUES IT WASN'T JUST MY
THREE COUNTIES IT WAS- ACTUALLY
STATEWIDE. WHERE. PUBLIC HEALTH
OFFICERS WERE AND- NOT READY. I
DON'T THINK ANY OF US WERE
READY BUT SPECIFICALLY OUR
PUBLIC HEALTH OFFICERS AT OUR
LOCAL. AND THERE'S A REDUCTION
IN THIS SPENDING BUT IN THE
COMMENTS THAT WE HAVE THAT WE
GOT LATE LAST NIGHT SHOWS THAT.
EVEN THOUGH THERE'S GOING TO BE
A REDUCTION NOW THAT THERE IS
GOING TO BE A FULL FUNDING
LATER CAN YOU MAKE A COMMENT ON
THAT. SURE SENATOR GRAHAM I
THINK- YOU'RE REFERRING TO THE
THREE HUNDRED MILLION IN THE
OUT YEARS- PROVIDED IN THE
BUDGET AND THAT IS- FOR PUBLIC
HEALTH INFRASTRUCTURE. THERE'S
NO- FUNDING PROVIDED. THE
FUNDING IS NOT PROVIDED IN THE
BUDGET YEAR. BECAUSE AS WE SAID
THERE. ARE SIGNIFICANT FEDERAL
FUNDS COMING IN. TO ADDRESS
SOME OF THAT NEED NOW. AND SO
THE DOLLARS ARE BUILT IN THE
BUDGET FOR ON GOING IN THE OUT
YEARS. OKAY THINKING THEN THAT
MAKES PERFECT SENSE I
APPRECIATE THAT.AND ALSO LIKE
TO THANK YOU I KNOW THIS IS
BUDGET BILL JUNIOR THAT WE'RE
DOING THAT I WAS I WOULD ALSO
LIKE TO. THANK YOU AND- THE
SENATE PRO TEM AND THE GOVERNOR
FOR. FUNDING THE BARSTOW
VETERANS HOME WHICH IS
SIGNIFICANT TO KEEP OUR-
INDIVIDUALS THAT HAVE SWORE TO
DEFEND THIS COUNTRY- AND HAVE
DEFENDED THIS COUNTRY TO HAVE
AN AVAILABILITY A PLACE TO
LIVE. THAT IS SECURE AND SAFE
SO THANK YOU FOR THAT AND ALSO
THANKYOU FOR- SOME OF THE
OTHER THINGS THAT HAVE BEEN
FUNDED- LIKE THE- SWIMMING
POOLS PUBLIC POOLS IN THE- IN
THE MINING AREAS OF THE LITHIUM
MINING PLANT. AT PLANT IN BARS-
BARSTOW OR BORON ACTUALLY BORON
I APOLOGIZE. AND THE COMPANY
TOWN. WE NEED TO LIFT HIM TO
MEET THE GOVERNOR'S RENEWABLE
ENERGY GOALS. AND THIS LITTLE
DESERT TOWN WITH ALL THESE
KIDS- HUNDRED THIRTY FIVE OR
FORTY DEGREES IT'S OUTRAGEOUS
THE INCREASES IN TEMPERATURE.
IN THE DESERT AND THEN SO
THAT'S VERY BENEFICIAL. AND I
KNOW SOME THINGS THAT AREN'T IN
THERE THAT WE HAD- THAT HAVE
BEEN TALKED ABOUT- YOU KNOW
KERN COUNTY PROVIDES 53% OF
THE- OF THE STATE'S RENEWABLE
ENERGY. WE HAVE A MAJOR US FULL
LARGE SCALE SOLAR PLANT WAITING
TO BE APPROVED BUT MY COUNTY
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS. IS AN-
HOPEFULLY GET A FULL MY LEAD
AND NOT A- IT INTO WE FIGURE
OUT HOW TO ADDRESS THIS SOME-
TAX REDUCTION CREDIT THAT COMES
TO THE SOLAR COMPANIES. AND FOR
INSTANCE I KNOW THAT WE'VE HAD
THIS CONVERSATION THAT 53% THE
STATE'S RENEWABLE ENERGY IS
PRODUCED IN MY DISTRICT AND WE
GET NOTHING FOR IT IT GOES
NORTH TO GO SOUTH I MEAN IF YOU
LOOK AT THE COMMERCIALS THAT
LOS ANGELES PUTS UP ABOUT BEING
ALL GREEN AND OPERATING ON
GREEN TECHNOLOGIES THAT ALL
COMES FROM MY DISTRICT IN THESE
MAJOR LARGE SCALE SOLAR SOLAR
PLANTS ARE NOT IN BURBANK AND
THEY'RE NOT IN BERKELEY AND
THEY'RE NOT IN SANTA MONICA.
THEY'RE IN MY DISTRICT BUT WE
GET NOTHING FOR IT AND WHEN I
SAY WE GET NOTHING FOR ITS
BECAUSE WE TAKE- AGRICULTURAL
LAND OUT OF PRODUCTION IN WHERE
WE GET TAX REVENUE AND THEN
THEY GET A TAX EXEMPTION FOR
THE SOLAR TAX- SIX EXCLUSION IS
THERE ANY PROGRESS BEING MADE
ON THAT PARTICULAR SUBJECT
MATTER I KNOW THE MAJORITY
FLOOR LEADER HAS A BILL GOING
THROUGH THE BUILDING TO BLOCK
ANY BLACK BACK FEELS ESPECIALLY
FOR. LARGE SCALE SOLAR WHICH
JUST HURTS AGAIN A COMMUNITY
THAT'S PROVIDING THE GOVERNOR
IN THIS BODY TO MEET ITS
RENEWABLE ENERGY GOALS SO JUST
CURIOUS IF THERE HAD BEEN ANY
FURTHER CONVERSATIONS ON THAT
PARTICULAR SUBJECT MATTER. HI
YES I THINK THE- THE TARGET-
INVESTMENTS THAT ARE INCLUDED
IN THIS BUDGET ARE REALLY TO
HELP. DRIVE THE ECONOMY IN THE
CENTRAL VALLEY IN THAT REGION
IN PARTICULAR IN OTHER REGIONS
AROUND THE STATE THAT ARE
TRANSITIONING FROM- WHAT TYPE
OF WORK FORCE INTO ANOTHER. I
KNOW WE HAVE TO TALK. OF WHICH
THERE ARE SIX HUNDRED MILLION
INCLUDED IN THIS PACKAGE AND- I
THINK THAT THERE ARE DIFFERENT
DISCUSSIONS IN REGARDS TO HOW
THOSE DOLLARS- OUGHT TO BE USED
BUT THAT THE GOAL IS TO REALLY-
INVIGORATE ENCOURAGING SUPPORT
PLANNING. IN COMMUNITIES THAT
ARE EXPERIENCING TRANSITIONS
SUCH AS- AND THAT IS SIX
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS THAT'S
INCLUDED IN THIS BUDGET. OKAY
AND I KNOW WE TALKED ABOUT THAT
AS WELL YOU KNOW ON THE GROUND
I WOULD SAY ON THE GROUND
BECAUSE I KNOW THAT THERE'S
GREAT INTENT IN THIS BUILDING
TO TRY TO HELP COMMUNITIES. BUT
WHAT DOESN'T WORK ON THE
GROUND- SPECIFICALLY IN CURRENT
AND THERE'S AN ORGANIZATION
INVOLVED IN ACHIEVING THEM
DOING I GUESS BEING AWARDED A
LOT OF THAT MONEY. WHO PROBABLY
WILL SPEND MILLIONS OF DOLLARS
AT THE BERKSHIRE HIGHER
INSTITUTE IN NEW YORK AND SPEND
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS ON
CONSULTANTS ON TELLING KERRY
COUNTY HAD A TRANSPOSITION AND
PROVIDE MORE RENEWABLE ENERGY.
WELL WE DO THAT NOW WITHOUT
THOSE WITHOUT ALL THAT MONEY
BEING SPENT ON CONSULTANTS-
BECAUSE LIKE I SAID WE PROVIDE
THE STATE THERE'S FIFTY EIGHT
COUNTIES IN THE STATE THERE'S
ONE COUNTY THAT GIVES YOU 53%
OF THE STATE'S RENEWABLE ENERGY
JUST ONE. AND THAT'S CURRENT-COUNTY. AND SO I AND- I
UNDERSTAND THAT I JUST WISH
THERE WAS SOME WAY THAT THE
COUNTY COULD HAVE ACCESS TO
THAT MONEY TO HIRE LAW
ENFORCEMENT PAY FOR LIBRARIES.
SCHOOLS THINGS THAT ARE NEEDED
FOR THE COMMUNITY- THAT WOULD
HAVE BEEN THERE HAD THE SOLAR
COMPANIES PAID THE TAX THAT-
THAT EVERY OTHER BUSINESS PAYS.
TO HAVE LAND AND PROPERTY IN
THE STATE- BUT THANK YOU MA'AM
VERY MUCH FOR ALLOWING ME TO
ASK THOSE QUESTIONS AND I DO
APPRECIATE ALL THE GOOD THINGS
THAT ARE IN THIS BUDGET THERE
ARE A FEW BAD THINGS BUT- I
APPRECIATE THE GOOD THINGS.
THANK YOU SENATOR GROVE CENTER
LAYERED. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MADAM CHAIR. I THINK IT WAS
TALKED ABOUT WHETHER THERE WAS
GOING TO BE A CONVERSATION HERE
AND I JUST WANTED TO POINT OUT
THAT THERE'S BEEN A
CONVERSATION GOING ON SINCE
JANUARY THE EDUCATION BUDGET
SUBCOMMITTEE THAT I CHAIR HAD
THIRTEEN HEARINGS WE AD
HUNDREDS OF PEOPLE COMMENT- OR
ARE WE IN THE END VOTED ON
ALMOST FOUR HUNDRED INDIVIDUAL
ITEMS BASED ON THOSE HEARING
SOME COMMENTS THAT ARE PART OF
THIS BUDGET TODAY. AND WHEN YOU
LOOK AT WHAT THE SUBJECT MATTER
WAS WE HAD PEOPLE TESTIFY TO US
THAT THEY WANTED MORE CHILD
CARE SLOTS AND BETTER WAGES AND
THAT WILL BE IN THE BUDGET WE
HAD PEOPLE TESTIFY FROM SCHOOL
DISTRICTS THAT THEY WANTED THE
DEFERRALS PAID COMPLETELY OFF
AND THAT WAS NOT IN THE BUDGET
THAT IS IN THIS BUDGET. AS A
RESULT OF THOSE CONVERSATIONS
WE HAD PEOPLE SAY THAT OUR
STUDENT AID SYSTEM. WAS AN
ADEQUATE. AND THERE ARE REAL.
CHANGES IN THIS BUDGET. THAT
HAD AT LEAST A HUNDRED THOUSAND
STUDENTS TO STUDENT AID AND
MAKE COLLEGE DEBT FREE MUCH
MORE OF A REALIZABLE GOAL.
THERE WERE PEOPLE THAT SAID
THAT. THE EXTENSION AND
COOPERATIVE AGRICULTURE ACROSS
THE STATE HAS BEEN SQUEEZED AND
HAS BEEN DYING IN THE LAST
TWENTY YEARS THIS BUDGET GIVES
THE BIGGEST CASH INFUSION
ACROSS THE AGRICULTURAL AREAS
OF CALIFORNIA FOR THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA TO
BRING BACK FORM AND VISORS
BRING BACK EXTENSION. WE HEARD
THAT. THERE WERE PARENTS IN
CALIFORNIA THAT WE'RE CONCERNED
ABOUT THEIR KIDS GETTING INTO
THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
AND THERE IS A PROPOSAL HERE.
THAT CAPS THE OUT OF STATE
STUDENTS AT THE THREE MOST
POPULAR. OUR CAMPUSES IN ADS
AND ROMAN SO IT HELPS THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA MEET
THAT GOAL WE HEARD ABOUT THE
EARLY CHILDHOOD DEVELOPMENT AND
HOW IT IS HELPED. BY PRE K.
PROGRAMS AND A MIX OF CHILD
CARE AND TRANSITIONAL
KINDERGARTEN AND THERE IS A
ONCE IN A LIFETIME REFORM HERE
THAT RESPONSE TO ALL THOSE
COMMENTS. SO WHEN WE HAD
HUNDREDS OF COMMENTS IT WAS A
CONVERSATION THAT'S BEEN GOING
ON OVER MONTHS AND THIRTEEN
HEARINGS AND THIS BUDGET IS THE
RESULT OF THAT LENGTHY PUBLIC
PARTICIPATORY CONVERSATION. AND
IF YOU LOOK GLOBALLY BECAUSE
THERE WERE SOME CURRENT
CONCERNS RAISED ABOUT- THE
FISCAL HEALTH. OF WE MIGHT HAVE
BETWEEN THE FEDERAL MONEY AND
THE ONE TIME REVENUE. A HUNDRED
BILLION DOLLARS WITH TWENTY
FIVE BILLION WILL BE THE AMOUNT
OF RESERVE STATUS IN THIS
BUDGET THERE WAS CONCERN ABOUT
FUTURE YEARS THIS IS BALANCED
IN THE NEXT FOUR. YEARS BASED
ON CURRENT REVENUES AND CURRENT.
ESTIMATES THIS BUDGET GIVES
PROVIDED WE APPROVE THE
STIMULUS THE GOLDEN STATE
STIMULUS OVER ELEVEN BILLION
DOLLARS TO BUSINESSES AND
INDIVIDUALS THAT HAVE BEEN
STRUGGLING ECONOMICALLY AS A
RESULT OF THE PANDEMIC- IT PAYS
OFF THE DEFERRALS AS I SAID SO
IT PAYS OFF THE DEBT WHEN WE
HAVE THIS ONE TIME. AND THEN.
IT GOES TEN FOR IT BUDGETS FOR
IMPACT ON SOME OF THE MAJOR
ISSUES FACING CALIFORNIA
WHETHER IT'S HEALTH CARE ACCESS
IT ADDS PEOPLE TO HEALTH CARE
WHETHER IT'S CHILD CARE AS A
SUPPORT. FOR ECONOMIC.
DEVELOPMENT THERE ARE
ADDITIONAL CHILD CARE SLOTS FOR
THOSE THAT WANT TO WORK HARD
AND LIFT THEMSELVES UP IT
ALLOWS FOR A DEBT FREE COLLEGE
EXPERIENCE. END WITH A SPECIFIC
ISSUES WE HAVE WITH THE
WILDFIRE AND THE DROUGHT IT
ADDRESSES THOSE SO THIS BUDGET
IT IT'S NOT AS IF IT WAS DONE
IN THE DARK. IT WAS DONE IN
FIVE SUB COMMITTEES WITH
THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE COMMENTING
WITH PROBABLY SIXTY OR SEVENTY
HEARINGS AND PUBLIC
PARTICIPATION AT EVERY LEVEL OF
THE WAY AND WHAT WE HAVE IN
FRONT OF US IS THE RESULT OF
THAT PROCESS SO. THERE'S A
REASON EVERYBODY'S BEEN
THANKING THE STAFF AND THE
MEMBERS THAT HAVE WORKED ON
THIS SINCE THE BUDGET CAME OUT
IN EARLY JANUARY. AND IT'S IN
BALANCE IT'S PRUDENT IT PAYS
OFF THE DEBT IT HAS SIGNIFICANT
RESERVES AND AN ADDRESS TO SOME
OF THE MOST INTRACTABLE
PROBLEMS THAT CALIFORNIA HAS.
AND SO I DON'T WANT THAT TO BE
LOST BECAUSE WERE IN ONE
HEARING AND NOBODY UNDERSTANDS
EVERYTHING OVER FIVE MONTHS
THAT WENT INTO IT BEFORE WE
HAVE THIS HERE I WILL BE
PLEASED TO VOTE. FOR THIS
BUDGET WHEN WE HAVE THE CHANCE.
THANK YOU SENATOR AND I'M SURE
THE OTHER SUBCOMMITTEE CHAIRS
COULD SIMILARLY DESCRIBED THE
NUMBER OF HEARINGS THEY HELD
THE PUBLIC INPUT THAT WAS
PRESENTED AND THE ADJUSTMENTS
TO THE BUDGET THAT WERE MADE AS
RESULT- NOW AS I MENTIONED WE
WILL BE VOTING AT THE END.
AFTER WE HAVE PUBLIC COMMENTS
WE'RE GOING TO CONTINUE THROUGH
THE PROCESS OF HEARING. ON THE
BILLS SO WE'VE HEARD NOW ON
EIGHTY ONE TWENTY NINE THE
BUDGET ACT I'M GONNA NOW MOVED
TO EIGHTY ONE THIRTY NINE.
WHICH IS THE GOLDEN STATE
STIMULUS. AND I WOULD LIKE TO-
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE TO
PRESENT PLEASE. ONE EIGHTY ONE
THIRTY NINE SORRY EXACTLY WITH
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE THIS
IS EIGHTY ONE THIRTY NINE THE
GOLDEN STATE STIMULUS. TO PART
TWO THE GOLDEN STATE STIMULUS
TO EXPANDS ON THE MEDIA
RELEASE- STIMULUS PAYMENTS THAT
WERE PROVIDED IN THE ORIGINAL
GOLDEN STATE STIMULUS- THIS IS
AN ESTIMATED EIGHT POINT ONE
BILLION DOLLARS TO. ELEVEN
POINT ONE MILLION HOUSEHOLDS-
AND OVER TWENTY ONE MILLION
INDIVIDUALS- THE GS THE G.
ACCESS AS WE COLLEGE TO PROVIDE
UP TO ELEVEN HUNDRED DOLLARS
PER HOUSEHOLD- WITH SIX HUNDRED
GOING TO TWENTY TWENTY TAX
FILERS WITH INCOME OF SEVENTY
FIVE THOUSAND OR LESS. WHO DID
NOT ALREADY RECEIVED- A GOLDEN
STATE STIMULUS- PAYMENT. AND
FIVE HUNDRED TO TWENTY TWENTY
TAX FILERS WITH INCOME OF
SEVENTY FIVE THOUSAND OR LESS
WITH THE DEPENDENTS- AND FIVE
HUNDRED FOR UNDOCUMENTED
FAMILIES WITH INCOME OF SEVENTY
FIVE THOUSAND OR LESS- AND AT
LEAST ONE DEPENDENCE. I JUST
LIKE TO STATE THAT THROUGH BOTH
THE GOLDEN STATE STIMULUS PLAN
AND THE GOLDEN STATE STIMULUS
TO- ALONG WITH THE GOLDEN STATE
GRANTS- COMBINED WE ESTIMATE A
TOTAL OF ABOUT FIFTEEN POINT
TWO MILLION HOUSEHOLDS WILL
GROUP WILL RECEIVE. STATE
STIMULUS ASSISTANCE AND-
IMPORTANT TO POINT OUT THAT
THESE- THE TARGET AUDIENCES
REALLY THOSE WHO HAD BEEN A
MOST IMPACTED BY THE PANDEMIC.
THANK YOU- HAPPY NEW TO RESPOND
TO QUESTIONS. THANK YOU-
HONESTLY LET ME SEE IF THERE'S
ANY QUESTIONS ON THE GOLDEN
STATE STIMULUS BILL- AND THIS
IS THE GOLDEN STATE STIMULUS TO
IT ADDS ON TO THE EARLY ACTIONS
THAT WE ALREADY TOOK WHEN THE
GOVERNOR INITIATED THE FIRST
PAYMENTS TO OUR LOW INCOME
HOUSEHOLDS AND NOW THIS COVERS.
THOSE FAMILIES AS MISS LEE
POINTED OUT WHO ARE- HAVE
INCOMES OF SEVENTY FIVE AND
BELOW SEVENTY FIVE K. AND BELOW
WHO HAVE ALSO BEEN STRUGGLING
DURING THIS PANDEMIC AND- THAT
IS. WHAT EIGHTY ONE THIRTY NINE
AS SHE DESCRIBED DOES- LET ME
SEE I DON'T SEE ANY MIKE'S UP.
SO I AM GOING TO MOVE TO THE
PRESENTATION ON EIGHTY ONE
FORTY TWO WHICH IS THE
MEMORANDUM OF UNDERSTANDING FOR
A NUMBER OF OUR STATE
BARGAINING UNITS STATE EMPLOYEE
BARGAINING UNITS GO HEAD
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. ACTUALLY
AGAIN WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE I'M AT ONE FORTY TWO
IS- R. M. O. U. ONE OF THE M.
O. U. TRAILER BILLS WILL BE
HEARINGTODAY- AND THE STATE'S
FORGETTING UNITS AGREED IT TO
CERTAIN EMPLOYEE COMPENSATION
RATE REDUCTIONS AND CHANGES. IN
ORDER TO HELP THE STATE ADDRESS
A PROJECTED SIGNIFICANT-
DEFICIT AT THE TWENTY TWENTY
BUDGET ACT AND AS STATED IN THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET AND THEN
AGAIN AT THE MAY REVISION THE
REVENUES AND THE STATE'S FISCAL
CONDITION HAVE DRAMATICALLY
CHANGED SINCE THEN. AND SO THE
ADMINISTRATION IS ENTERED INTO
NEGOTIATIONS WITH OUR
BARGAINING UNITS TO RESTORE
THESE PAY FOR ITEMS AND
SPECIFICALLY THIS BILL RATIFIES
THE AGREEMENTS WITH THOSE
BARGAINING UNITS. AND THE
PERSONAL LEAVE PROGRAM TWENTY
TWENTY IT RSTORES THE PAY
REDUCTIONS IN OTHER PAY ITEMS
THAT WERE SUSPENDED. YEAH
RESUMES EMPLOYEE CONTRIBUTIONS
ARE PRE FUNDING OF OTHER POST
EMPLOYMENT BENEFITS ALSO KNOWN
AS A TAB- AND PROVIDES GENERAL
SALARY INCREASES- THESE
AGREEMENTS RESULT IN A TOTAL OF
ONE POINT TWENTY TO NINE.
BILLION IN BUDGET YOUR COSTS-
THE VAST MAJORITY OF THOSE
COSTS ARE THE RESULTS OF
PROVIDING EACH BARGAINING UNIT
WITH TWO GENERAL SALARY
INCREASES- AND THESE AGAIN
WHERE THESE WERE- ENVISIONED.
PRIOR TO THE PANDEMIC BUT WERE
REDUCED- AND- FROZEN- DURING
THE PANDEMIC AGAIN BECAUSE
BARGAINING UNITS IT KNOWLEDGE
AND WERE- PROVIDING ASSISTANCE
TO THE- TO THE BUDGET- OR
SHOULD THE STATE DURING-
MASSIVE BUDGET DEFICITS. ARE A
POTENTIAL DEFICITS THE
PROVISIONS OF THIS BILL DO NOT
TAKE EFFECT UNTIL. AND UNLESS
FUNDS ARE APPROPRIATED BY THE
LEGISLATURE. I'M HAPPY TO
RESPOND. ANY QUESTIONS ON THIS
BILL. ALRIGHT LET ME SEE IF
THERE'S ANY QUESTIONS ON THE
MEMORANDUM OF UNDERSTANDING
WHICH REPRESENTS THE AGREEMENTS
ON THE VARIOUS STATE BARGAINING
UNITS THAT WERE JUST DESCRIBED.
ANY QUESTIONS. ALL RIGHT SEEING
NINE FIVE YES SENATOR KABIR.
ACTUALLY MADAM CHAIR I DON'T I
DON'T HAVE ANY QUESTIONS I JUST
WANT TO MAKE A STATEMENT I
THINK IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT
THAT- THAT. AND THIS THIS
AGREEMENT THIS MOU DOES THAT IS
TO- TO TAKE OUR EMPLOYEES BACK
TO. WHERE THEY WERE PRIOR TO
THAT PANDEMIC- UNBEKNOWNST TO
MOST CALIFORNIANS I THINK- THEY
HAVE NO IDEA THAT ARM OUR STATE
EMPLOYEES TOOK. A REDUCTION IN
SALARY THIS PAST YEAR AND
DESPITE THE FACT THAT. THAT
MANY OF THEM WERE RESPONSIBLE
FOR HELPING US TO GET THIS
PANDEMIC UNDER CONTROL AND
TOOK. ON IT WHEN YOU KNOW MADE
YEOMAN'S EFFORTS TO DO THAT-
EVERY SINGLE DEPARTMENT WAS
STRESSED BECAUSE PEOPLE WERE
SENT HOME AND HAD TO FIGURE OUT
HOW TO GET THEIR JOB DONE.
WHILE THEY WERE WORKING FOR
HOME THEY ALSO- RECEIVED LESS
IN SALARY SO I WANNA RECOGNIZE
THAT ACKNOWLEDGE IT AND THANK
THE GOVERNOR FOR- HIS
LEADERSHIP IN MAKING SURE THAT
WE MAKE THEM WHOLE AND THAT WE
DO EVERYTHING WE NEED TO DO TO.
GET THEM BACK TO WHERE THEY
WERE PREPAID PANDEMIC. THANK
YOU SENATOR CAFIERO FOR THOSE
COMMENTS I THINK THOSE ARE
VERY. YEAH IT WAS A VERY
IMPORTANT POINT TO MAKE OUR
STATE EMPLOYEES CONTINUE TO
WORK. AND UNDER AND LIKE YOU
POINTED OUT AS MANY PEOPLE
UNDER GREAT DURESS. AND WHETHER
THEY WERE EMPLOYEES FOR EXAMPLE
LIKE COVERED CALIFORNIA WHICH
PROCESS THAT MANY MORE- HEALTH
BENEFIT PLANS FOR FOLKS TO MAKE
SURE THAT CALIFORNIANS HAD
HEALTH CARE. OR WHETHER IT WAS
ANY OTHER OF OUR DEPARTMENTS IN
SOCIAL SERVICES HUMAN SERVICES.
THEY CONTINUE TO WORK THEY WORK
REMOTELY THEY HAD A REDUCTION
IN PAY AND THIS THESE
AGREEMENTS THAT WE HAVE BEFORE
US BRING THEM BACK. RESTORES
THAT REDUCTION AND IN MANY
CASES PROVIDES SOME ADDITIONAL
BENEFITS WHICH WOULD WOULD BE
LEGITIMATE BUT VERY REASONABLE
SO THAT WE CONTINUE OUR
RESPONSIBLE BUDGETING
PRACTICES. AND HAVE A BALANCED
BUDGET IN THE OUT YEARS.
SENATOR PAN. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR I TOO WANT TO- ALSO.
STRONGLY SUPPORT EIGHTY ONE
FORTY TWO AND ALSO EXPRESSED
SAME SENTIMENTS AS MY GOOD
FRIEND- CENTER COUNTY L. I
POINT OUT THAT- WHEN WE WERE
THINKING THAT WE WERE GOING TO
HAVE A- LARGE DEFICITS IN THE
STATE EVEN THOUGH THEY HAVE
EXISTING AGREEMENTS. WITH THE
STATE SO WE REALLY HAD NO LEGAL
HE FOUND THE GREEN INSTEAD THEY
STEPPED UP TO THE PLATE. TO GO
SHE DID CUTS FOR THEMSELVES
EVEN AS WE WERE ASKING THE
CENTURY MANY OF THE DO OVER
TIME AS WE THINK ABOUT WE'RE
SHIFTING PEOPLE AROUND FOR
CONTACT TRACING AND OTHER TYPES
OF TASKS ADDRESS ASKING PEOPLE
TO STEP OUT OF THEIR- USUAL
WORK STONE SAID TO HELP OUT IN
THIS CRISIS. YET SEEN TIME
AGREED TO THE CUT SO I THINK SO
CERTAINLY MORE INAPPROPRIATE.
THAT GIVEN DAY- FISCAL PICTURE
THAT WE SEE NOW WITH OUR STATE
BUDGET THAT WE SHOULD KEEP OUR
PROMISES TO THEM THAT WE
EARLIER MADE. AND RESTORED
THEIR COMPENSATION TO WHAT
ESSENTIALLY- WE HAD AGREED TO-
PRIOR TO A- POSSIBLE AGAIN
POSSIBLE- BUDGET REDUCTION AND-
THEY STEPPED UP TO TRY TO HELP
US ADDRESS THAT AND SO THANK
YOU- SUPPORT. THANK YOU DR
PEPPER. ALL RIGHT SEEING NO
ADDITIONAL COMMENTS WE WILL GO.
TO THE PRESENTATION ON OUR NEXT
ITEM WHICH IS- ONE SECOND. IS.
EIGHTY ONE FORTY SIX WHICH IS
THE FACILITIES FINANCING FOR
SOME OF OUR PUBLIC SAFETY
FACILITIES DEPARTMENT FINDS. S.
ERICA LAY WITH THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE EIGHTY ONE FORTY
SIX- THIS BILL LANGUAGE REDUCES
LEASE REVENUE BOND OF FORTY
CURRENTLY AUTHORIZED BY THE-
FOR THE CONSTRUCTION OF THE
REMAINING HEALTH CARE FACILITY
IMPROVEMENT PROGRAM PROJECTS
ALSO KNOWN AS HE ACCEPTS- THE
FOUR OTHER CORRECTIONS
DEPARTMENT OF CORRECTIONS AND
REHABILITATION- BY FORTY TWO
POINT EIGHT MILLION. TOTAL
FUNDING NECESSARY TO COMPLETE
THE REMAINING PROJECTS IS BEING
PROVIDED THROUGH THE GENERAL
FUND CORPORATION THE BILL ALSO
REDUCES THE LEASE REVENUE BOND
OF FORTY CURRENTLY AUTHORIZED
FOR FOUR SEPARATE COUNTY JAIL
FINANCING PROGRAMS FOR THE
LOCAL JAIL AN ADULT LOCAL
CRIMINAL JUSTICE FACILITY
FINANCING PROGRAMS- FOR CDC ARE
AND THE BOARD OF STATE. AND
COMMUNITY CORRECTIONS. AND
THAT'S BY TWO TWENTY- THE
INTENTION IS TO INSTEAD
ALLOCATE RESOURCES TO EXPAND
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH TREATMENT
SERVICES FOR INDIVIDUALS WITH
SERIOUS MENTAL HEALTH MENTAL
ILLNESS. WHO ARE DEEMED
INCOMPETENT TO STAND TRIAL ON A
FELONY CHARGE. I'M HAPPY TO
ANSWER QUESTIONS ON THIS BILL
AS WELL. THANK YOU ANY
QUESTIONS ON YES SENATOR DOLLY.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS I
DID. WHAT WE'RE GONNA BE
SHUTTING DOWN OR WE HAVE- TAKE
SOME ACTION TO SHUT DOWN MANY
OF OUR CORRECTIONAL FACILITIES-
SO IN THIS PROCESS ARE YOU
TAKING INTO ACCOUNT. THE
FACILITIES THAT ARE THE FUTURE
GOING TO SHUT DOWN WE'RE GOING
TO BE RELEASING. A LOT MORE
INMATES I KNOW THIS IS IN
CONJUNCTION ALSO WITH COUNTY
JAILS WHICH ARE PROVIDING THOSE
SERVICES WELL SO. ARE YOU
LOOKING AT IN THE IN THE POLICY
PART OF IT- WHERE WERE YOU
LOOKING AT SHUTTING DOWN MORE
OR CLOSING PRISONS- AND THAT IN
COORDINATION WITH THE COUNTY
JAILS THAT PROVIDE FOR THOSE-
STATE PRISONS- YEAH THANK YOU
FOR THE QUESTION CENTER DOLLY-
I WOULD JUST WANT TO POINT OUT-
BEFORE HANDING IT THIS. THE
DETAILS OF THIS TO MY COLLEAGUE
THAT- IT'S THE STATE'S LEGAL
OBLIGATION- PURSUANT TO THE
PLOT OF SETTLEMENT- TO REALLY
FOCUS ON IMPROVING PRISON
HEALTH CARE FOR- DISABILITY IS
TO PROPERLY ADDRESS ISSUES- AND
LEVEL OF CARE THERE- BUT IN IN
REGARDS TO- PLANNING FOR PRISON
CLOSURES- AND THE DECISIONS ON
THIS I LIKE TO. DEFER TO MY
COLLEAGUE- HURRYING. HURST
MORNING CREAM ON RUNNERS
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AND AS IS
THE PRACTICE WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF CORRECTIONS AND
REHABILITATION WE ARE DOING OUR
BEST TO MINIMIZE- CONSTRUCTION
PROJECTS AT ANY FACILITY THAT
COULD BE CLOSED IN THE FUTURE.
THE PROJECTS THAT WE'RE LOOKING
AT SPECIFICALLY DATE BACK TO
TWO THOUSAND TWELVE. AND SO
THERE TOWARDS THE TAIL END OF
BEING FINISHED AND WHAT YOU SEE
BEFORE YOU IS ACTUALLY A
REDUCTION IN US ALREADY THROUGH
LEASE REVENUE. SERVICE AS IT
WAS BEING SHIFTED TO GENERAL
FUND. IN REGARDS TO THE COUNTY
JAIL RELINQUISHMENT IT'S
ACTUALLY A REDUCTION IN FUNDING
THEY'LL GO TO COUNTY JAILS- AS
THEY'VE BEEN RELINQUISHED OUR
THEY WERE UNAWARE DEFINED SO IT
WOULD NOT CONSTRUCT COUNTY
JAILS AT THE LOCAL. LEVEL DOES
THAT ANSWER YOUR QUESTION
SENATOR. WELL I JUST NOTE THAT
IN THE CASE OF CCC IN LASSEN
COUNTY THEY DID A BUNCH OF
IMPROVEMENTS ON THAT FACILITY.
AND THEN. IT WAS SLATED TO SHUT
DOWN NOW I BELIEVE IN MY
COMMUNITY BELIEVES THAT. THE
ACTION THAT WAS TAKEN IT WAS
OBVIOUSLY WASN'T FOR THE BEST
INTEREST OF US BUT THERE WAS
OTHER FACILITIES THAT WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE THESE INMATES TO
THE DIDN'T HAVE THE SAME
UPGRADES AND MONEY SPENT ON
THEM SO. BUT THERE'S A LOT OF
MONEY BEING SPENT. AND AS THE
POLICY THAT REALLY MATTERS IS
HOW ARE WE- GOING TO DELEGATE
OR USE THE RESOURCES AND A VERY
COST EFFECTIVE WAY SO WHAT I'M
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT. IS ARE WE
PLANNING WE KNOW THAT. THERE'S
GOING TO BE MORE INMATES
RELEASED OVER TIME.
APPROXIMATELY SEVENTY SIX
THOUSAND INMATES. WHAT WE WANT
TO BE ABLE TO HAVE THOSE
FACILITIES. WORK AND MANAGE
THESE INMATES SO THAT WE CAN
ACTUALLY REHABILITATE SOME. AND
THAT'S THE GOAL SO FOR ME IT'S
ABOUT THE POLICY OF HOW WE'RE
GOING TO DO THE MONEY IN THE
END IT HASN'T REALLY BEEN LAID
OUT. AT LEAST IN MY MIND. WE'RE
GOING TO GO FORWARD AND MAKE
SURE THAT WE- DO THAT GIVE THE
SERVICES THAT WE NEED TO GET.
AND THEN ALSO MAKE SURE THAT
WE'RE NOT WASTING MONEY BY
FIXING SOME. FACILITY THAT
WE'RE GONNA EVENTUALLY CLOSED
DOWN. I THINK WILL ACCEPT THAT
AS A APARTMENT- I THINK IT
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCES PROVIDED
THAT INFORMATION THE SPECIFICS.
ON SENATOR DRAWS A- I JUST WANT
TO RESPOND TO MY OTHER
COLLEAGUES- COMMENT ABOUT. A
KNOWING IN ADVANCE WHERE WE
THINK WE MIGHT BE CLOSING SO
THAT WE DON'T SPEND
UNNECESSARILY AND THAT WAS A
SUBJECT OF A LOT OF
CONVERSATION MANY MANY HOURS IN
OUR SUBCOMMITTEE ON THIS AND-
TOTALLY AGREE WITH YOU THAT WAS
THE POINT WE WERE TRYING TO
MAKE TO THE ADMINISTRATION
THAT. WE NEED TO KNOW MORE OR
LESS SOME SHORT LIST SO THAT WE
DON'T INVEST TENT LITERALLY
HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS OF DOLLARS
SO. I AGREE WITH YOU I JUST
WANNA LET YOU KNOW THAT THIS
WAS A WE GOT A COMMITMENT TO A
MUCH MORE SPECIFIC COMMITMENT
FROM THEN AND MINISTRATION THAT
WE WERE GOING TO. HAVE THIS
KIND OF INFORMATION MORE
READILY AVAILABLE TO US SO THAT
WE COULD MAKE SOLID DECISIONS
ON ON WHERE TO SPEND ON CAPITAL
IMPROVEMENTS ALL THESE- THINGS
THAT COST AN ENORMOUS AMOUNT OF
MONEY. THANK YOU AS- FOR THAT
COMMENT AND SENATOR DRESSER IS
CHAIR OF THE SUBCOMMITTEE THAT
HEARD THIS- LET ME SEE IF
THERE'S ANY OTHER. QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS. OKAY SEEING NO
ADDITIONAL WE WILL NOW MOVE ON
TO THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE'S
PRESENTATION ON A. B. ONE FORTY
SEVEN. WHICH IS THE BUDGET ACT
OF TWENTY TWENTY AUGMENTATION
GO AHEAD DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
DIRECTLY WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE- EIGHTY ONE FORTY SEVEN
PROVIDE AUGMENTATIONS UP
SEVENTEEN POINT TWO MILLION
GENERAL FUND TO ADDRESS
UNANTICIPATED COSTS. IN THE
CURRENT YEAR TWENTY TWENTY
TWENTY ONE- FOR THE DEPARTMENT
OF CORRECTIONS IN REAL
REHABILITATION AND SWELL AS THE
HOMICIDE TRIAL COSTS-
SPECIFICALLY THE BILL INCLUDES
AN AUGMENTATION. OF SEVENTEEN
POINT TWO MILLION FOR CDC ARE
TO FIND UNANTICIPATED COSTS
INCURRED TO IMPLEMENT REMEDIAL
MEASURES TO KEEP COMPLIANCE
WITH- ARMSTRONG COURT ORDERS
ISSUED IN SEPTEMBER TWENTY
TWENTY AND MARCH TWENTY TWENTY
ONE. THIS INCLUDES INSTALLING
FIX VIDEO SURVEILLANCE CAMERAS
DEPLOYING BODY WORN CAMERAS
MODIFYING ITS STAFF COMPLETE
PROCESS SEES AND INCREASING
SUPERVISORY STOPPING AND BASED
ON OUR REVIEW CDCR IS NOT ABLE
TO ABSORB THE COST OF THIS
MAGNITUDE AT THIS TIME. AND
ADDITIONALLY THE BILL INCLUDES
TEN THOUSAND EIGHT HUNDRED
DOLLARS FOR GENERAL FUND TO
REIMBURSE MARIPOSA. COUNTY FOR
THE UNANTICIPATED COSTS
INCURRED IN NINETEEN TWENTY AND
TWENTY TWENTY ONE RELATED TO
HOMICIDE TRIAL COSTS. FOR THE
CASE OF PEOPLE VERSUS. IN OUR-
I'M HAPPY TO RISK TO. THANK YOU
MISLI LET ME SEE IF THERE'S ANY
QUESTIONS ON THIS. THERE ARE
EIGHTEEN NINETY PRETTY
STRAIGHTFORWARD- WE WILL GO TO
THE NEXT ITEM WHICH IS. EIGHTY
ONE FIFTY TWO- WHICH IS THE
ELECTIONS APPROPRIATION
ELECTIONS BILL- DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE GO AHEAD. YES EIGHTY
ONE FIFTY TWO- AS STATED
EARLIER THE ELECTION ITSELF AND
IT'S GOT THIRTY FIVE HOW THE
TWENTY TWENTY ONE GOOD MATERIAL
RECALL ELECTION WILL BE
CONDUCTED- AN APPROPRIATE THREE
FIVE MILLION TO THE GENERAL
PLAN TO THE SECRETARY OF STATE
TO SUPPORT STATEWIDE AND LOCAL
COSTS RELATED TO ADMINISTER
ADMINISTERING THE ELECTION-
SPECIFICALLY THIS BILL MAKES
CHANGES AND CLARIFICATIONS TO
ANY ELECTION CONDUCTED PRIOR TO
JANUARY ONE TWENTY TWENTY TWO-
INCLUDING- REQUIRING COUNTIES
TO CONDUCT VOTER EDUCATION AND
OUTREACH CAMPAIGN- REQUIRING
THE SECRETARY OF STATE TO
CONDUCT THE VOTER. SORRY JUST
ALYSHA PROCESS FOR GRANTING
COUNTIES PARTIAL WAIVERS- FROM
REQUIREMENTS RELATED TO THE MAX
NUMBER OF VOTERS IN PRECINCTS-
AMONG AMONG OTHER THINGS- AND
AGAIN THIS IT'S THAT THE
ALLOCATION IS THIRTY FIVE
MILLION FOR THE SECRETARY OF
STATE- FOR THE PURPOSE OF THE
SUPPORTING STATEWIDE AND COUNTY
COSTS RELATED TO THE SELECTION
I'M HAPPY TO RESPOND TO
QUESTIONS AND- JOINED. BY
COLLEAGUES WHO CAN ANSWER IN
MORE DETAIL. THERE ARE A
LIMITED THERE'S ANY. FOR TO
ONE- SENATOR DOLLY. THE MANAGER
BUT I'D LIKE TO KNOW- ARE THESE
FUNDS GOING TO GO TO THE
COUNTIES. OR IS IT GONNA GO TO
THE SECRETARY OF STATE. THE
THIRTY FIVE MILLION IS FOR
ADMINISTRATION IT GOES TO THE
SECRETARY OF STATE TO SUPPORT
COUNTIES THERE WAS A AN
AUGMENTATION PROVIDED. IT THE
TWO HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION THAT
WAS IDENTIFIED- THROUGH
ANALYSIS OR- INFORMATION
PROVIDED BY COUNTY ELECTION
OFFICIALS ANDTHAT IS GOING TO
THE COUNTY. OFFICIALS TOOK TWO
HUNDRED MILLION GOES TO THE
COUNTIES AND THIRTY FIVE
MILLION GOES TO THE SECRETARY
OF STATE. THAT'S CORRECT AND
THEN. ACTUALLY TWO HUNDRED AND
FIFTEEN MINUTES. FIFTEEN
MILLION TO THE LOCALS AND
THIRTY FIVE MILLION TO THE
SECRETARY OF STATE. AND AS YOU
KNOW THAT DURING THE BUDGET
PROCESS THIRTY ACTION ITEMS WE
TOOK IN THE LAST ELECTION THERE
WERE THIRTY FIVE AND THE
SECRETARY. NO THE AUDITOR
TREASURER WOULD NOT PAY THE
BILL SO WE HAD TO RE RATIFY IN
THE BUDGET LAST TIME TO PAY THE
THIRTY FIVE MILLION. SO HOW IS
THIS CONTRACT GOING TO BE THAT
IS AT THE- WHAT WHAT IS THE
POLICY TO THE- SECRETARY OF
STATE AND HOW TO IMPLEMENT THIS
THIRTY FIVE MILLION. LET ME
TURN THAT QUESTION OVER A MORE
DETAILED RESPONSE TO MY
COLLEAGUE WHO'S ON THE LINE.
GOOD MORNING TIM WEBER
DEPARTMENT FINANCE HE'S SEEN
HERE ME YES. THE BILL I
APPROPRIATE THIRTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS DIRECTLY TO THE
SECRETARY OF STATE I DON'T
THINK IT'S WORTH MENTIONING
THAT THE BILL ALSO STATES THAT-
INTENDED THE LEGISLATURE CAN
CONSIDER JUSTIN'S EMAIL BASED
ON THE FINAL COST THE
GUBERNATORIAL ELECTIONS AFTER
THEY ACTUALLY COMPLETED. IN
ADDITION IT CENTERS THEY HAVE
BROKEN OUT THERE IT'S PRETTY
CONSTANTLY PROVIDES THE
LEGISLATURE AND SPECIFICS OF
THEIR ESTIMATED FUNDING. SO
THAT'S- IT IF I COULD JUST
MAYBE PARAPHRASE WHAT I THINK I
HEARD. THE TWO HUNDRED AND
FIFTEEN MILLION IS GOING TO
BASICALLY OFFSET THE COST FOR
THE COUNTIES TO FOR THE SPECIAL
ELECTION THE THIRTY FIVE
MILLION IS GOING TO. THE
SECRETARY STATE TO. DO VOTER
OUTREACH OR TOO EDGY I I'M A
LITTLE BIT CONFUSED ON THAT
PART I KNOW THAT WE DON'T WANT
THE COUNTIES HAVE TO PAY FOR
THE SPECIAL ELECTION WITH THAT
THEY COME OUT OF THEIR GENERAL
FUND SO THAT'S RIGHT I'M
ASSUMING THE TWO HUNDRED FIFTY
MILLION GOES. BUT THE THIRTY
FIVE MILLION I'M STILL A BIT
CONFUSED ON WHAT THE PURPOSE OF
THAT IS FOR YES THE MAJORITY OF
IT ABOUT SEVENTEEN POINT FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS ESTIMATE
CURRENTLY IS FOR A
COMMUNICATIONS AND OUTREACH-
AND THEN THE NEXT LARGEST COST
WOULD BE FOR THE BORDER MISSION
THAT PRINTING WHICH IS ABOUT
NINE MILLION DOLLARS AND OTHER
VARIOUS CAUSES OVER TIME THE
SECRETARY OF STATE AND IT COSTS.
OKAY AND WILL THAT WELL THOSE.
WELL THOSE BE LET OUT TWO OF
THE COMPETITIVE BID AND THEN
THE LOWEST BIDDER WILL BE ABLE
TO. I DO THE WORK OR IS THAT
WE'RE GONNA BE DONE IN HOUSE
WITH THE SECRETARY OF STATE.
WELL THE FUNNY REPLY TO THE
SECRETARY OF STATE'S GOING TO
GET BACK TO YOU ON SOME OF THE
SPECIFICS OF- REGULATORY
COMMISSION DATA WHO DO CONTRACT
WITH THAT. NOT APPRECIATE THAT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SENATOR
ALI SENATOR GROVE. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR I HAVE A COUPLE OF
FOLLOW UP QUESTIONS ON MY
CALLING FROM BEEPERS AT
QUESTIONS REGARDING THIS-
REGARDING AB SP ONE FIFTY TWO.
AM ARE THERE GOING TO BE
ASSURANCES TO THE PUBLIC OR
WHAT KIND OF INSURANCE IS ARE
WE GOING TO BE ABLE TO GIVE THE
PUBLIC AND THAT NO CONTRACT SO
THE DIFFERENCE WITH POLITICAL
CAMPAIGN TIES LIKE WE
EXPERIENCED- IN THE PREVIOUS
FEW MONTHS. WHERE I GUESS TEAM
BIDEN'S- ORGANIZATION GOT A
SUBSTANTIAL AMOUNT OF MONEY FOR
VOTER OUTREACH AND OTHER
LAWSUITS FILED BUT I GUESS MY
QUESTION IS IT IS GOING TO BE A
FAIR AND OPEN ENDED IF IT DOES
GO OUT TO CONTRACT AND WHAT
KIND OF ASSURANCES CAN WE GIVE
THE PUBLIC THAT IT'S NOT GOING
TO BE A POLITICAL CAMPAIGN. AND
THAT HAS POLITICAL CAMPAIGN
TICE. YEAH THANK YOU FOR THE
QUESTION- I DON'T KNOW MR
WEBBER DO YOU HAVE A RESPONSE
TO THAT. FOR THE S. C. ON THEIR
EXACT CONTRACT PROCESS AND
THOSE CONCERNS. I'M SORRY SIR I
DIDN'T HEAR YOU- DIFFERED IN
THE- THE SECRETARY SCALES EXACT
CONCERNS. FORTY EIGHT HOURS TO
CONTRACTS AND SENATOR GROW WE
CAN GET BACK TO YOU WITH MORE
DETAILS ON THE PROCESS OF THE
PROCUREMENT. OKAY I APPRECIATE
THAT AND DIRECTOR LEE I JUST
LIKE I SAID I KNOW THERE WAS A
LOT OF CONTROVERSY SURROUNDING
SOME- STATE RESOURCES- IN
PREVIOUS CONTRACTS- AND I JUST
WAS CURIOUS AND- REALLY WANTED
TO MAKE URE THAT- THIS IS A
FAIR AND OPEN BID. AND THAT IT
DOESN'T GO TO POLITICAL
OPERATIVES THAT WOULD BE FROM
ONE SIDE OR THE OTHER AND THAT
AND THE PUBLIC CAN HAVE TRUST
IN WHERE THEIR RESOURCES ARE
BEING SPENT THANK YOU MA'AM.
LET ME SEE IF THERE'S ANY OTHER.
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS- SEEING
NONE WE WILL MOVE TO THE NEXT.
BILL BEFORE US WHICH IS EIGHTY
ONE FIFTY EIGHT THE TOXICS
CONTACT SIX. GO AHEAD IN
FINANCE THANK YOU ACTUALLY WITH
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
EIGHTY ONE FIFTY EIGHT THE
DEPARTMENT OF TOXIC SUBSTANCES
CONTROL. ANSWERS A GOVERNANCE
ANDFISCAL REFORM TO IMPROVE
GOVERNANCE AND TRANSPARENCY AND
PROVIDE LONG TERM FISCAL
SUSTAINABILITY FOR DTS CD OR
THE DEPARTMENT OF TOXIC
SUBSTANCES CONTROL I'M
SPECIFICALLY THIS BILL
ESTABLISHES THE BOARD OF
ENVIRONMENTAL SAFETY TO PROVIDE
GREATER PUBLIC TRANSPARENCY AND
ACCOUNTABILITY- IT RESTRUCTURES
INCREASES HAZARDOUS WASTE FEES.
MAKES VARIOUS PROGRAMMATIC
CHANGES AND APPROPRIATE- FIVE
HUNDRED MILLION FOR STATEWIDE
CONTAMINATED SITE CLEAN UP- AND
THREE THREE HUNDRED TWENTY TWO
MILLION THE CLEANUP RESIDENTIAL
PROPERTY SURROUNDING THE FORMER
EXCITED FACILITY- IN VERNON
OVER THE NEXT THREE YEARS I'M
HAPPY TO RESPOND TO QUESTIONS.
CLICK. IF THERE'S ANY
QUESTIONS- BEFORE I CALLING YOU
SENATOR GROVE I WANTED TO
INDICATE THAT I'M VERY HAPPY TO
pCITY CLEAN UP IN THE AFTERNOON
AREA IT IS BANNED- SOMETHING
THAT IS. THIS COULD BE
SOMETHING VERY DIFFICULT FOR
THE COMMUNITY TO HAVE HAD.
THOSE THAT TOXIC AND HAZARDOUS
MATERIALS THERE AT THE AT THE
FORMER EXCITE FACILITY- SO I'M
REALLY REALLY PLEASED TO SEE
THAT WE ARE ACTING ON THAT. AND
THAT WE ARE ALSO- INSURING THAT
IS JUST AS WE GO FORWARD THAT.
HAZARDOUS SITES LIKE THAT
HAZARDOUS AND TOXIC SITES THAT
WE WOULD BE ABLE TO DO THE
APPROPRIATE CLEANUP. BECAUSE IT
IS NOT FAIR TO ANY COMMUNITY
SETTING BE EXPOSED THAT WAY. SO
SENATOR GROVE DID YOU. STILL GO
AHEAD AND THEN I'LL CALL ON
SENATOR Y. CASKEY. THANK YOU
AGAIN THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR- SO
I DO APPRECIATE THE FACT THAT
THESE SITES ARE BEING CLEANED
UP ESPECIALLY IN THE CITY OF
VERNON IN THAT AREA- I DO HAVE
A CONCERN ABOUT- AGAIN- I GUESS
IN THE BACK AT SO. WE ALL COME
FROM DIFFERENT PERSPECTIVES
LIFE EXPERIENCES AND I BELIEVE
THAT EVERY DOLLAR SPENT IN THIS
CAPITAL ORIGINATES FROM
BUSINESS. NOW I HAVE HAD
ARGUMENTS OR CONVERSATIONS WITH
SOME OF MY COLLEAGUES THAT- SAY
THEY PAY TAXES TOO AND I AGREE
WE ALL PAY TAXES BUT ALL OF
THAT ORIGINAL DOLLARS ORIGINATE
FROM BUSINESS. AND BUSINESSES
PAY PROPERTY TAXES AND THEY BUY
BUSINESSES THEY PAY PROPERTY
TAXESTHEY SIMPLY TAXES THEY
HIRE PEOPLE WHO PAY TAXES ON
THEIR WAGES. AND THEY PAY FEES
AND FINES AND FEES THAT ARE
LIKE THIS PARTICULAR FEE THAT'S
GOING TO INCREASE THREE HUNDRED
AND TWENTY PERCENT- FOR
BUSINESSES TO PICK UP THE TAB
ON THAT. BUT EVERY DOLLAR THAT
IS SPENT IN THIS BUILDING COMES
FROM THE BUSINESS COMMUNITY
ORIGINALLY. NOW I REALIZE THAT.
EMPLOYEES PAY TAXES BUT THEY
GET THEIR ORIGINAL CHECK FROM
THE BUSINESS OWNER- WE PAY
TAXES BUT WE GET OUR ORIGINAL.
MANY THAT COMES FROM THE
GENERAL FUND THAT PAYS US AS
LEGISLATORS- COMES FROM THE
BUSINESS COMMUNITY SO I HAVE A
HUGE CONCERN THAT THIS INCREASE
TARGETS THE BUSINESS COMMUNITY
WHETHER LARGE OR SMALL- BY
THREE HUNDRED AND TWENTY
PERCENT. IS THERE A REASON WHY
WE'RE TARGETING THE BUSINESS
COMMUNITY FOR THE THIS
PARTICULAR INCREASING D. TSC.
THANK YOU FOR THE QUESTION- I
JUST WANT TO POINT OUT THAT
THE- THE BILL ELIMINATES THE
ENVIRONMENTAL FEE FOR
APPROXIMATELY FOURTEEN THOUSAND
BUSINESSES WITH FEWER THAN ONE
HUNDRED EMPLOYEES. SO SMALLER
BUSINESSES WILL ACTUALLY SEE A
REDUCTION IN THEIR
ENVIRONMENTAL FEE- AND IT DOES
RESTRUCTURE THE HAZARDOUS WASTE
CONTROL ACCOUNT VS- IT TO
CHARGE ON A PART TIME BASIS TO
REALLY REFLECT. THE POLLUTER
PAYS- STRUCTURE- WHICH WE THINK
IS FAIR AND APPROPRIATE AND SO
JUST TO HIGHLIGHT- WELL THERE
IS AN INCREASE THAT WILL
GENERATE ADDITIONAL REVENUES-
THE IDEA IS TO MAKE THIS A
FAIRER. WAY DEALING WITH THOSE
FEES. THANK YOU DIRECTOR LEE-
YOU MADE A COMMENT POLLUTER PAY
STRUCTURE WHAT IS THAT- I
DEFERRED THAT QUESTION FOR A
MORE DETAILED RESPONSE TO MY
COLLEAGUE BUT ESSENTIALLY IT
IS- THE MORE. THE MORE YOU PAY-
AND- I'M NOT SURE WHO'S ON THE
LINE BUT I WILL DEFER THAT TO
MY COLLEAGUE. HEY ANDREW MARCH
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
SO GENERALLY THE POLLUTER PAYS
PRINCIPLE- REFLECTS EXACTLY AS-
DIRECTLY STATED THAT THE MORE
THAT YOU POLLUTE THE YOU KNOW
THERE'S A THERE'S A FAIR COST-
ALLOCATIONS FOR THOSE- FOR THAT
POLLUTION. AS UNDER THE CURRENT
HAZARDOUS WASTE- CONTROL
ACCOUNT STRUCTURE- ANY ANY
HAZARDOUS WASTE GENERATED ABOUT
I BELIEVE TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED
TIMES ADDED THAT BUSINESSES NOT
PAY ANY ADDITIONAL REGULATORY
FEES- SO. AT THE END OF THE
DAY- THE SMALLER GENERATORS I
CAN SUBSTITUTE OR ARE
SUBSIDIZING LARGER GENERATORS
SO UNDER THIS PROPOSAL- BEING A
PER TON BASIS REGARDLESS OF HOW
MUCH. YOU MAKE OTHERS NO CAP-
THAT YOU YOU'D BE PAYING THE
SAME AMOUNT ON A PART TIME
BASIS. AND THANK YOU SO MAYBE
I'M MISUNDERSTANDING I THOUGHT
THIS WAS THE ENVIRONMENTAL. FEE
THAT YOU PAID EVERY YEAR BASED
ON THE NUMBER OF EMPLOYEES THAT
YOU HAVE. SO AND THERE'S A
SCALE AT THE END OF THE YEAR A
BUSINESS GETS A- REPORT IF YOU
HAVE. ZERO TEN FIFTEEN FIFTY
ONE TO NINETY NINE NINETY NINE
TO FOUR NINETY NINE AND THEN
ABOVE FIVE HUNDRED. SO THE WAY
THAT THIS TAX IS CALCULATED
FROM MY UNDERSTANDING IS THAT
AND- THE MORE EMPLOYEES THAT
YOU GIVE A JOB TO AN
OPPORTUNITY TO PROVIDE FOR
THEIR FAMILIES THE HIGHER YOUR
PENALTY OR TAXES. IS THAT NOT
THE TAX WE'RE TALKING ABOUT.
THAT'S GREAT SO THAT'S ONE OF
THE TAXES ARE ONE OF THE FEES
ACTIONS- CONTAINED IN THIS
TRAILER BILLS THE ENVIRONMENTAL
C. N. AS YOU STATED IT'S BASED
ON THE NUMBER OF EMPLOYEES. SO
CURRENTLY THAT FEE IS- ON ALL
BUSINESSES WITH FIFTY OR MORE
EMPLOYEES OR A CERTAIN NUMBER
OF BUSINESSES AND CERTAIN
INDUSTRIES WITH FIFTY OR MORE
EMPLOYEES- THIS PROPOSAL
ELIMINATES THAT FEE FOR A BIT-
BUSINESSES WITH- MORE FIFTY TO
NINETY NINE EMPLOYEES- WHICH IS
AROUND FOURTEEN THOUSAND
BUSINESSES THAT WILL NO LONGER
BE PAYING THAT FEE- IT
MAINTAINS THE FEE FOR
BUSINESSES BETWEEN. FIVE
HUNDRED AND NINE HUNDRED NINETY
NINE EMPLOYEES AND THEN RAISES
THE C. ON BUSINESSES ABOUT ONE
THOUSAND EMPLOYEES. M. IS IT
ONLY RAISED ON THE BUSINESSES
OF ONE THOUSAND EMPLOYEES HAS
UP TO THREE HUNDRED AND 20%
INCREASE OR- THAT'S CORRECT. SO
AGAIN I GUESS AND AGAIN I GUESS
IT'S JUST LIFE EXPERIENCES I
BELIEVE THAT- YOU KNOW THOSE
EMPLOYERS THAT PROVIDE THOSE
PEOPLE JOBS AND AN OPPORTUNITY
TO PROVIDE FOR THEIR FAMILIES-
WHY WE TARGET THEM I DON'T
KNOW- I DO KNOW THAT YOU KNOW
THERE'S A- IT'S POLITICALLY
CORRECT I GUESS TO SAY LARGE
BUSINESS VERSUS SMALL BUSINESS.
BUT THERE ARE A LOT OF LARGE
BUSINESSES LEAVING CALIFORNIA
AND- AT THREE HUNDRED AND 20%
INCREASE JUST BASED ON THE
NUMBER OF EMPLOYEES THAT YOU
HIRE IF YOU'RE GIVING. YOU
KNOW. IF YOU HAVE NINETY NINE
EMPLOYEES AND YOU CAN'T GIVE
ONE MORE PERSON TO JOB- YOU'D
BE SUBJECT TO THAT INCREASE OF
THREE INTERN 20% ON THAT
ENVIRONMENTAL TAXI. JUST
BECAUSE YOU GAVE SOMEBODY AN
OPPORTUNITY HAVE A JOB. EVEN
THOUGH THEY'RE NOT IN THE-
DISPOSAL TRANSFER PROCESS SCENE
OF ANY TOXIC SUBSTANCES IT'S
JUST THE FACT THAT. THEY DRIVE
TO WORK OR- THE AND- IT'S JUST
BECAUSE YOU HIRED SOMEBODY- I
JUST THINK THAT I APPRECIATE
THE FACT THAT YOU GUYS DID LOOK
AT THAT WE'LL START THERE. I DO
APPRECIATE THE FACT THAT YOU
GUYS DID LOOK AT THE SMALLER
BUSINESSES. THAT HAVE FEWER
THAN NINETY NINE EMPLOYEES AND
IT DOES SAY FOURTEEN THOUSAND-
BUSINESSES THIS TAX AND THAT
SEASON ROUGHLY BETWEEN
400-021-2000 DOLLARS A YEAR.
BUT AND I GUESS MY CONCERN ON
THIS PARTICULAR ISSUE IS THAT
YOU'RE EXPANDING THE FEE ON
BUSINESS. JUST SOLELY ON THE
FACT THAT THEY PROVIDE
EMPLOYEES A JOB. I THINK THAT
THE ENTIRE STRUCTURE OF THE WAY
GOVERNMENT OPERATES. ISN'T VERY
DIFFICULT A VERY DETRIMENTAL TO
BUSINESS THE HIGHER THE WAGES
THE HIGHER THE WORKERS COMP.
AND THE HIGHER THE WAGES THE
HIGHER THE LIABILITY INSURANCE
BECAUSE EVERYTHING IS TIED TO
WAGES- EXCEPT FOR MEDICAL
INSURANCE IS NOT TIED TO WAGES
IT'S TIED TO THE NUMBER OF
EMPLOYEES. THAT AND I THINK
THERE HAS TO BE A BETTER SFI
STRUCTURE I THINK THIS IS A
STEP FORWARD AT LEAST
ELIMINATING THE FOURTEEN
THOUSAND. BUSINESSES THAT WOULD
HAVE TO NOT ELIMINATE THE TAX
NOT THE BUSINESS THE TAXES TO.
FOURTEEN THOUSAND BUSINESSES
BUT I THINK WE NEED TO LOOK AT
A STRUCTURE MOVING FORWARD-
JUST ON. I JUST I GUESS MY
POINT IS. RAMBLING ON AND I DO
APOLOGIZE FOR THAT WHY DO WE
PUNISH EMPLOYERS FOR HIRING
PEOPLE. THAT'S AWESOME I GUESS
MY CONCERN BUT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR ADDRESSING THAT IT IS
IT TRUE THAT THIS TAX WILL GO
UP- THREE HUNDRED AND 20% OKAY
SO. SORRY YOU HAD ALREADY
ADDRESSED THAT YOU WOULD ASK
THE QUESTION WAS ALREADY
ADDRESSED. THE THREE INTERN 20%
I HEARD BUT TO GO HEAD
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. OR YES
AND SO OVERALL THE REVENUES FOR
THE ACCOUNTS ARE NOT ARE ONLY
GOING UP BY AROUND- THEY'RE
DOUBLING SO A 100% AND SO I
THINK SPECIFICALLY IF YOU LOOK
ON A SECTOR BY SECTOR EMPLOYEE.
EMPLOYED HERE I THINK THAT'S
WHERE THAT 310020% NUMBERS
COMING FROM- I WOULD JUST POINT
OUT TWO THINGS ONE IS THAT- IT
INCLUDING THIS BUDGET YEAR- THE
GENERAL FUND HAS PROVIDED
AROUND- ONE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS TO BACK FILL THESE TWO
FUNDS THE HAZARDOUS WASTE
CONTROL ACCOUNT AND THE TOXIC
SUBSTANCES CONTROL ACCOUNT. AND
ADDITIONALLY ONE OF THEIR
APARTMENTS FOR THE BOARD OF
ENVIRONMENTAL SAFETY IN THIS
BILL IS TO LOOK AT THIS THE
STRUCTURE IN THE FUTURE TO SEE
IF THE RESTRUCTURING OF BUT
THESE WOULD E APPROPRIATE.
THANK YOU SIR THANK YOU N. M.
THANK YOU FOR POINTING OUT THAT
THE GENERAL FUND GAVE A HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS AGAIN THAT
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS CAME
FROM PRIVATE BUSINESS. AND FOR
US TO DISTRIBUTE. SO THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR YOUR COMMENTS. I
HAVE SENATOR WHITE HOUSE AGAIN
THEN SENATOR RECOMMENDED YOU
HAVEN'T NOTICED THEN SENATOR
DRAW SO. MADAM CHAIR I'M HERE
TO REPORT THAT I ACTUALLY AGREE
WITH FINANCES NUMBERS I KNOW
THAT MAY COME AS A SURPRISE FOR
THEM- N. AND I APPLIED-
SECRETARY BLUMENFELD AND-
GOVERNOR NEWSOM AND EVERYBODY
AT THAT AND- AT THE-
DEPARTMENT. TO HAVE WORKED ON
ON THIS IT IT. IT SHOULD BE
CLEAR THAT WE'VE HAD OVER TEN
YEARS OF REVIEW AND OVERSIGHT
ON TE DEPARTMENT OF TOXIC
SUBSTANCES. IN THE CHALLENGE IS
THAT IT HAS IT REALLY DOES A
REALLY DIFFICULT JOB. NO CLEANS
UP IT HANDLES. WITH FACILITIES
IN MONITORS FACILITIES THAT
ARE. GENERATING WASTE. DEALS
WITH THE TRANSPORTATION OF THE
RIDE WASTE AND DEALS WITH THE-
DISPOSAL. MY COLLEAGUE- FROM
BAKERSFIELD WAS CORRECT WITH
REGARD TO FACILITIES THAT HAVE
OVER A THOUSAND PEOPLE YES
THEIR FEES ARE GONNA GO UP
3100% OF THE CALCULATION. BUT
LET'S BE REALLY CLEAR THERE'S
THAT'S JUST THE ENVIRONMENTAL
FEE THE ENVIRONMENTAL FEE WE
DIDN'T CHARGE. EMPLOYEES THAT
YOU HAVE FIFTY YEARS OR LESS
BUT WE'VE THE MOVE THE
DEPARTMENT IS COME UP WITH A
PLAN THAT SAYS WE'LL WAIT THESE
FIFTY TO SEVENTY FIVE OR
SEVENTY FIVE TO NINETY NINE.
YOU'RE NOT GOING TO PAY A FEE
ANY ANYWAY AND ANYBODY WHO
EMPLOYS BETWEEN ONE HUNDRED AND
FOUR HUNDRED NINETY NINE
EMPLOYEES IS PAYING THE EXACT
SAME ENVIRONMENTAL FEE THAT
THEY'RE PAYING TODAY THAT
REMAINS THE SAME IT'S ONLY WHEN
YOU GET TO THE BIG BOYS AND
GIRLS. OVER FIVE HUNDRED THAT
THEY'RE GONNA START PAYING BUT
ALSO X. ALSO INCLUDE IN THIS IS
THE- THIS FLAT. FEE FOR THE
GENERATOR SETS NOW GOING TO BE
AT FORTY NINE DOLLARS AND
TWENTY FIVE CENTS WHICH SEEMS
MORE FAIR AND THE FACILITY FEES
IS ALSO WERE POPPING THAT FOR
ALL THESE FACILITIES THEY'RE
GENERATING AT. A MINUTE THAT'S
THE QUESTION IS WHY BECAUSE
WE'VE BEEN RUNNING A DEFICIT
BOTH OF THESE FUNDS FOR THE
LAST THREE YEARS WE KNEW WHAT
MY COLLEAGUE SITTING IN FRONT
OF ME WAS SECRETARY OF
RESOURCES THAT WE WERE GOING TO
BE RUNNING A DEFICIT THIS IS
BEEN GOING ON FOR. SEVEN EIGHT
YEARS AND WHAT THIS DOES IS
TRUE TRUE UPS. THE COSTED IT
HAS IN CALIFORNIA TO PRODUCE
HAZARDOUS MATERIALS WHICH WE
NEED WE NEED THE PRODUCTS THAT
THEY MAKE BUT THERE'S A BY
PRODUCT AND ALSO THE TRANSPORT
AND THE CLEAN THEM ONE OF THE
OTHER ELEMENTS IT'S- HERE. THIS
IS BORED AFTER SEER HERE A YEAR
OF HEARINGS AND REPORTS. NOW ON
APPEALS BOARD THAT'S GOING TO
LOOK AT THE DECISIONS THAT ARE
DONE ADDING ANOTHER LAYER OF
TRANSPARENCY THE GOOD A GO
AROUND TO BAKERSFIELD TO LOS
ANGELES TO SANTA CRUZ. TO
SILLINESS TO THOUSAND OAKS. TO
SACRAMENTO TO HAVE THESE PUBLIC
HEARING C. NG GAUGE PUBLIC ON.
THE TREE. THE GENERATION AND
HOW DO WE PREPARE PRACTICE
DISPOSE OF IT SO THIS IS BEEN.
A DECADE OF WORK BUT IS THE
GUY- THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE IN
THIS LEGISLATURE I THINK. THEY
SHOULD BE APPLAUDED FOR. THEIR
COURAGE IT'S- IT'S TAKEN TO
BRING THIS BABY ONE FIFTY.
EIGHT BEFORE US AND I LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUING TO WORK
OVER THEM WITH THEIR- THE PORT
OF SAFETY ENVIRONMENTAL SAFETY.
SENATOR DRAWS A- YES- I TO RISE
TO- SUPPORT AB ONE FIFTY EIGHT
AND- THIS WAS. THIS WAS A-
PRIORITY FOR THE LA COUNTY
LEGISLATORS- FOR THE EXCITE THE
MONEY GOING TO EXCITE- WE ARE
IN UP THE TAB FOR WHAT EXCITED
OVER DECADES. AND OBVIOUSLY. WE
DIDN'T DO ENOUGH TO STOP
EXCITED FROM CAUSING THE DAMAGE
THAT IT DID- SO WHEN WE TALK
ABOUT YOU KNOW THESE COMPANIES-
AND THE FEES ARE PAYING THEY
DON'T EVEN COME CLOSE TO WHAT
THE- WHAT WE AS TAXPAYERS ARE
PAYING. TO CLEAN UP THE MESS
AND THE CONTAMINATION THAT'S
BEEN CREATED. SOMEWHERE BETWEEN
THREE FOUR HUNDRED MILLION I
DON'T REMEMBER THE EXACT AMOUNT.
IS WHAT WE HAVE TO PAY TO CLEAN
UP THE SITE ITSELF AND THEN
JUST TDAY JUSTIN THIS BILL
IT'S- OVER. THREE HUNDRED
MILLION FOR THE RESIDENTIAL
WE'VE ALREADY PAID SEVERAL
HUNDRED MILLION TO START THE
RESIDENTIAL CLEANUP THIS IS TO
CONTINUE THE RESIDENTIAL
CLEANUP SO I JUST WE NEED TO.
KEEP IN PERSPECTIVE THE DAMAGE
THAT IS CAUSED AND EVERY MONTH
EVERY YEAR THAT GOES BY THAT WE
DON'T HAVE THE FULL AMOUNT
THAT'S NEEDED TO REALLY. INCOME
PRIMARILY LATINO IMMIGRANT
COMMUNITY THAT SUFFERS FOR
EVERY SINGLE DAY THAT GOES BY
WITH THE CONTAMINATION THAT HAS
BEEN LEFT SO I APPRECIATE THAT
THIS WILL ALLOW US TO CONTINUE-
THE CLEANUP. IT SHOULD NOT HAVE
BEEN THERE IN THE FIRST PLACE
THANK YOU. SENATOR EDMUND.
THANK YOU. I ALSO. NEED A
SURPRISE AND I'M SURE RISING OR
NOT. TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
THIS I JUST YOU KNOW SOMEBODY
WHO SERVED ON THE CITY COUNCIL
AND- CONNECT SOMEONE DISTRESSED
CITY TO KNOW THE COST OF TRYING
TO DO DEVELOPMENT AND YOU'VE
GOT THESE BROWNFIELD AND TRYING
TO CLEAN THINGS UP. MASSIVE
SECTIONS IN MY AREA AROUND
AROUND OUR PORT AREA THAT WE
HAVE BEEN ABLE TO DEVELOP JUST
BECAUSE THERE WASN'T MONEY TO
BE ABLE TO CLEAN THEM UP. AND
ALSO JUST I I'D LIKE TO DO THIS.
REMARK ON MY THE GOVERNORS AND
A GREAT JOB EVERYBODY DOES A
GOOD JOB MY FRIEND CHRISTINA
GARCIA HAS BEEN TALKING ABOUT
EXCITED SINCE WE ENTERED THE-
LEGISLATURE TOGETHER IN TWO
THOUSAND AND TWELVE- SO THIS IS
I MEAN. AND THEN I. LOOK FOR MY
COLLEAGUE FROM BAKERSFIELD
TALKS ABOUT ALL ALL OUR MONEY
COMES FROM FROM EMPLOYERS. BUT
WE ALSO KNOW IN DISTRICTS LIKE
HER AND I WE HAVE HIGHER RATES
OF CHILDHOOD ASTHMA HIGHER
RATES OF CANCER HIGHER RATES OF
ALL THE KINDS OF THINGS THAT GO
INTO. THE SOME OF THE
CONSEQUENCES OF SOME OF THE
THINGS THAT WE PRODUCE AND
AGAIN DO WE NEED THEM YES BUT
DO WE ALSO HAVE TO MAKE SURE
THAT THE PEOPLE WHO LIVE IN
THOSE COMMUNITIES WHO BREATHE
THAT AIR WHO DRINK THAT WATER.
AND WHO HAVE TO PLAY AROUND
THERE. ALSO ARE PROTECTED.
THANK YOU- SENATOR DOLE YOUR
HOUSTON YES SENATOR DOLLY GO
AHEAD THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS I WANT TO RISE ON THIS
ISSUE BECAUSE I WORK AT THE
GOOD ASSEMBLY. CRISTINA GARCIA
ON DECK SIDE ISSUE AND- I
SERVED ON EQ- TOXICS IN THE IN
BOTH HOUSES AND- MAKE NO
MISTAKE ABOUT IT. WHAT HAPPENED
WITH THAT SIDE WAS OVER A LONG
PERIOD OF TIME THE LOCALS DID
NOT DO THE RIGHT THING. LET'S
FACE IT THE AIR POLLUTION
CONTROL. DISTRICT DID NOT DO
THEIR DUE DILIGENCE. AND THE
TAXPAYERS HAVE PAID WE DID WE
DID FOLLOW THE MONE IN THE
BUDGET. BUT THERE WAS A TWO
DOLLAR FEE FOR EVERY BATTERY
THAT SOLD IN CALIFORNIA THE
GOAL IS TO HELP PAID UP FRONT.
AND WHAT WE NEED TO FOCUS ON
HERE IS THE FACT THAT WHAT IS
THE FUTURE BRING. WHAT WE KNOW
HAPPENED IN THE PAST WAS WRONG.
WE SAW COMMUNITIES WHERE
THEY'RE MAINLY DISADVANTAGED.
LOW INCOME PEOPLE AND THAT'S
WHERE THE MANUFACTURING WAS IN
VERNON THOSE TYPE OF PLACES.
WRONG WE DIDN'T DO A GOOD JOB
OF MAKING SURE THAT THE COMPANY
WHO NOW HAS GONE AND LEFT AND
WHO'S PICKING UP THE BILL.
EVERY SINGLE PERSON THAT BUYS A
BATTERY IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA IS PAYING THE BILL.
NOW WE WANT TO STOP THAT FROM
HAPPENING IN THE FUTURE. THAT'S
THE GOAL HERE IS TO NOT TO DO
THE RIGHT THING CALIFORNIA.
LEADS THE WORLD WHEN IT COMES
TO ENVIRONMENTAL SAFETY. WE DO
WE DO A GOOD JOB HERE BUT WE
ALSO HAVE TO STRIKE A BALANCE
THE BALANCE HAS TO BE CAN WE
KEEP THOSE JOBS HERE IN
CALIFORNIA PRODUCE THE PRODUCTS
THAT WE NEED. AT THE SAME TIME
NOT PUSHING THOSE COMPANIES AND-
TOXICS AND THINGS OUT OF OUR
STATE WORSE NOT DONE IN THE
SAME MANNER. SO THE GOAL HERE
IS TO STRIKE A BALANCE. OUR
COST OF MATERIALS WILL GO UP.
BECAUSE WE'RE GOING TO HAVE TO
PAY. AND THESE COMPANIES ARE
GOING TO WHEN THEY DO GET THE
THOUSAND THE COMPANIES THAT
HAVE A THOUSAND EMPLOYEES OR
MORE ARE GOING TO PAY MORE AND
THAT MEANS THE PRODUCTS THEY
PRODUCE. ARE GONNA GO UP. IT'S
VERY DIFFICULT TO AFFORD TO
LIVE IN CALIFORNIA. AND THOSE
ARE THE BALANCES THAT THIS.
BUDGET COMMITTEE NEEDS TO
STRIKE IT'S GOOD WE HAVE THESE
CONVERSATIONS WE CANNOT CHANGE
THE PAST. BUT WE CAN SURELY
CHANGE THE FUTURE. AND THAT'S
THE GOAL OF THIS BUDGET
COMMITTEE IS TO TRY TO MAKE.
GOOD POLICY DECISIONS AND
STRIKE THAT BALANCE. AND THE
ONE THING THAT FRUSTRATES ME IN
CALIFORNIA IS THAT. WE GO TOO
FAR SOMETIMES IN PUSHING TO TRY
TO MAKE EVERYTHING PERFECT AS
WE PUSH WE PUSH THOSE COMPANIES
OUT OF CALIFORNIA WHICH DRIVES
DOWN THE AMOUNT OF PEOPLE
WORKING SO FOR ME THIS ISSUE IS
A REALLY TOUGH ONE. BECAUSE I
SUPPORT THE FACT THAT WE NEED
TO DO THE RIGHT THING AND MAKES
OUR COMMUNITIES ARE SAFE BUT
THE SAME TIME I DON'T WANT TO
PENALIZE THE COMPANIES THAT ARE
HERE IN CALIFORNIA PUSH THEM
OUT. SO I HAVEN'T DECIDED ON
THIS BILL YET THIS IS ONE NIGHT
WE HAVE A NON ON ON OUR CAUCUS
AND I'M DEPEND ON INSIDE I'M
DEBATING WHETHER OR NOT. TO
VOTE FOR OR OR TO LAY OFF OR TO
VOTE AGAINST IT. BECAUSE WE
NEEDTO STRIKE A BALANCE THE
POLICY HOW IT GETS IMPLEMENTED.
ARE KEY. TO DOING THE RIGHT
THING IN CALIFORNIA I JUST WANT
TO RISE AND SAY THAT. I WORKED
VERY CLOSELY ON THIS ISSUE IT'S
NOT JUST EXCITED THOUGH. THAT'S
THE ONE THING THAT GLITTERS OUT
TO US IS EXCITED BUT IT'S- IT'S
AGRICULTURE IT'S- IT'S
PETROLEUM IT'S ALL THE THINGS
WE USE EVERY DAY. IN CALIFORNIA
WE NEED TO STRIKE A BALANCE
WILL COME FROM FOR WHAT I'M
REALLY TRYING TO SAY IS THAT I
WANT PEOPLE TO STILL STAY IN
CALIFORNIA DO THEIR BUSINESS
HERE. AT THE SAME TIME I WANT
TO PROTECT THE ENVIRONMENT. SO
I JUST URGE MEMBERS THAT. WHEN
I KNOW THIS IS GOING TO PASS.
BUT I URGE YOU TO FOLLOW THE
POLICY WHEN IT GETS ACTUALLY
IMPLEMENTED AND MAKE SURE THAT.
WE'RE DOING THE RIGHT THING IF
WE NEED TO COME BACK AND TWEAK
IT WITH LEGISLATION. TO GET
WHERE WE WANT TO GO WE NEED TO
DO THAT. BECAUSE THE DEVIL IS
IN THE DETAILS. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR FOR INDULGING ME ON THISISSUE IT'S A REAL TOUGH ONE.
AND IT'S VERY IMPORTANT.
BECAUSE WE'RE EITHER GONNA.
KEEP BUSINESSES IN CALIFORNIA
AND DO IT RIGHT WE'RE GONNA
SHUT HIM OUT OF CALIFORNIA AND
THEY'RE GONNA. BUY THOSE
PRODUCTS FROM EITHER CHINA OR
SOME OTHER STATE. THAT WE ALL
USE AND WE LIVED IN CALIFORNIA
WE DO THAT. THANK YOU SENATOR
DOLLY SENATOR WORKOUTS SKI YEAH.
MISS MADAM CHAIR IN AN EFFORT
TO- HELP MY COLLEAGUES
UNDERSTAND THE IMPORTANCE OF
THIS THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT ON
THESE FEDERAL A DIVERSIFIED
SUPERFUND SITES REQUIRES A
CALIFORNIA PAY 10% OF THE COST
TO CLEAN UP AND THEN TO PAY ALL
THE COSTS TO MAINTAIN AND KEEP
IT THE STAFF REPORT. NOTES THAT
WE'RE A HUNDRED NINETY FOUR
MILLION BEHIND AT. NUMEROUS
SITES THAT HAVE ALREADY BEEN
IDENTIFIED THE STAFF REPORT
FURTHER TALKS ABOUT. THE
UNIDENTIFIED FEDERAL SITES THAT
MAY BE UP TO A HUNDRED AND
FIFTY TWO HUNDRED THOUSAND
SITES SO ALL WE'RE DOING IS BY
A BARBER DOING MANY THINGS BUT
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT WE HAVE
TO REMEMBER IF WE LOOK TO THE
FUTURE IS THAT WE'RE GETTING.
OF FEES THAT WE'RE GONNA BE
COLLECTING FROM THE PEOPLE WHO
WERE GENERATING THESE TOXIC-
MATERIALS AND TRANSPORTING THEM
BUT THEN WE'RE PAYING OUR
SHARE. TO CLEAN UP ALL THE PAST
ACTIVITIES THAT HAVE GONE ON
AND GET THAT 9210% MATCHING
FUND BECAUSE I CAN GUARANTEE
YOU THERE ARE OTHER STATES. AND
LEGISLATORS ARE MEETING THAT
ARE SAYING THIS IS A GOOD DEAL
WE PAY TEN PERCENT. THEY PAY
90% WE GET HIM CLEANED UP AND
THIS IS A WAY. NOT TO TAKE
ANYTHING FROM THE EXCITED
BECAUSE THE EXITE INCIDENT.
SUCKS UP ALL THE OXYGEN BUT
THERE ARE THOUSANDS HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF THE SITE'S IN
EVERYONE OF OUR DISTRICT THAT
NEEDS THE ATTENTION AND THIS IS
A PATHWAY TO GET THERE SO. I
HOPE MY COLLEAGUES CONSIDERED
THAT IN THE FUTURE SOME OF THE
SITES IN THEIR DISTRICTS HAVE
NOT BEEN IDENTIFIED AND THEY
ARE ACTING THEY ARE. FORMER
INDUSTRIAL DAY YOU KNOW THEY
DON'T HAVE A RESPONSIBLE PARTY
THAT'S THE PROBLEM WE DON'T
KNOW WHO'S GONNA PAY FOR THIS
SO. UNFORTUNATELY WE IN
GOVERNMENT HAVE TO DO UP AT
LEAST THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT'S
PICKING UP 90% OF THE TAP.
THANK YOU SENATOR WORKOUTS SKI.
ALL RIGHT. SEEING AS NO OTHER
COMMENTS. AS CENTER GROVE DID
YOU HAVE THANK YOU THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR I WOULD LIKE TO
JUST RESPOND JUST BRIEFLY TO
MY- COLLEAGUE FROM FREMONT. WE
AGREE AND I AGREE WITH MY
COLLEAGUE FROM BEAVER THAT
THERE IS A BALANCE THAT HAS TO
TAKE PLACE IN THIS LEGISLATURE
IN THIS BUDGET PROCESS AND I
AGREED. THAT THE THINGS THAT
HAPPENED IN CALIFORNIA IN THE
PAST NEED TO BE CLEANED UP
THAT'S NOT THE ISSUE. I THINK
pTHAT THOSE- SPECIFICALLY IN
THOSE AREAS THAT ARE
IDENTIFIED. AND THAT HURTS THE
POOREST OF OUR COMMUNITIES- I
AGREE WITH THAT- MY CONCERN IS
LIKE I SAID THE SAME THING FROM
MY COLLEAGUE FROM BEAVER. IS
THAT. ALL OF OUR REVENUE IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA EVERY
DOLLAR THAT'S BEEN IN THIS
BUILDING IS- PAID FOR BY
BUSINESS AND TO CONTINUE TO.
FEED BUSINESS. TO THE POINT
WHETHER THEY'RE- A THOUSAND
EMPLOYEES FIVE HUNDRED PLEASE
IT DOESN'T MATTER TO CONTINUE
TO FEED BUSINESS THERE'S GOTTA
BE SOME WAY. THAT WE CAN M.
LIKE MY COLLEAGUE FROM BEAVER
SAID STRIKE A BALANCE I DO
AGREE FROM MIKE WITH MY
COLLEAGUE FROM AND FREMONT. DID
IT THERE ARE FEDERAL FUNDS THAT
ARE AVAILABLE TO FOR THESE
CLEANUP I DID THESE SITES THAT
ARE NEED TO BE CLEANED UP AND
IDENTIFIED. AND WE DO WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT THERE'S A CLEAN
ENVIRONMENT. BUT IT'S ABOUT
MAKING IT WORK ON THE GROUND IF
YOU TAKE THE OIL INDUSTRY FOR
INSTANCE. CALIFORNIA'S
CONSUMPTION OF OIL HAS NOT GONE
DOWN OVER THE LAST TWENTY YEARS
IT'S ACTUALLY INCREASED IN SOME
CASES IN SOME YEARS IT STAYED
THE SAME. BUT INSTEAD OF
PRODUCING IT HERE UNDER THE
SAFE FREEZE YOU KNOW MOST
RESPONSIBLE ENVIRONMENTAL
POLICIES. IN THE WORLD WE
TRANSPORT FROM VENEZUELA WHERE
THEY'RE ACTUALLY POLLUTING
RIVERS AND- YOU KNOW COLUMBIA
AND- YOU KNOW. SAUDI ARABIA.
THE YOU KNOW ALL THESE PLACES
WERE IN WE BRING IT OVER
PRECIOUS. ECOSYSTEM IN BUNKER
FUEL- PROVIDED SHIPS. THAT SIT
IN OUR PORTS TO BE OFF LOADED-
SO. THERE'S GOTTA BE A WAY
WHERE WE DON'T HE NEED TO FULLY
PAY. BUSINESSES SO THAT WE
CONTINUE TO PROVE A- HERE. AND
THEN WE ALSO ARE VERY
ENVIRONMENTAL FRIENDLY AND WE
GO BACK AND CLEAN UP. WHAT HAS
HAPPENED IN THE PAST WE WEREN'T
OPERATING UNDER THE STRICTEST
REGULATORY ENVIRONMENTAL
QUALITY. AND PROCESSES.
AVAILABLE SO THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR. AGAIN FOR ALLOWING ME TO
MAKE THOSE FINAL COMMENTS.
THANK YOU ALL RIGHT I THINK WE
HAVE A OBVIOUSLY EXPRESSED
OPINIONS ON THIS ONE- SO WE
WILL GO TO BE THE NEXT
PRESENTATION- WHICH IS THE LAST
BUDGET BILLS AND THAT IS AB ONE
FIFTY NINE WHICH REPRESENTS THE
MO YOU FOR THE COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING UNIT SIX OUR-
CORRECTIONAL PEACE OFFICERS
ASSOCIATION DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
OF THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE-
AT EIGHTY ONE FIFTY NINE IS THE
MO YOU BUILT FOR BARGAINING
UNIT SIX- THE CALIFORNIA
CORRECTIONAL PEACE OFFICERS
ASSOCIATION ALSO KNOWN AS THE
C. P. O. A. AND LIKE THE OTHER
ON MARKETING UNITS THEY TOO-
EXPERIENCE REDUCTIONS IN PAY
AND- SALARY AND OTHER PAY
ITEMS. ON THIS SIDE LETTER AND-
THE PERSONALLY PROGRAM IT
RESTORES THE PAY REDUCTIONS AND
OTHER PAY ITEMS THAT WERE
SUSPENDED IT RESUMES THE
EMPLOYEE CONTRIBUTIONS FOR PRE
FUNDING OPEB. PROVIDES GENERAL
SALARY INCREASES AND INCLUDES
OTHER ONE TIME ITEMS ADDRESSING
THE IMPACTS OF THE PANDEMIC
CONTEMPLATES HEALTH AND
WELLNESS- AND LASTLY EXTENDS
THE TERM OF THE AMMO USE A
MEMORANDUM OF UNDERSTANDING
FROM JULY SECOND. TWENTY TWENTY
TWO TO JULY SECOND TWENTY
TWENTY THREE- THIS RESULT. IN
BUT COSTS OF UP FORMER FIVE
MILLION GENERAL FIND- AND
INCLUDES I'M GOING BECAUSE THIS
INCLUDES ONGOING COSTS OF TWO
HUNDRED SIXTY FOUR MILLION. AND
ONE TIME COST OF TWO HUNDRED
FORTY SIX MILLION. ASIANS UP
THIS BILL SIMILAR TO THE OTHER
DO NOT TAKE EFFECT UNLESS FUNDS
ARE APPROPRIATED BY THE
LEGISLATURE. HAPPY TO RESPOND
TO QUESTIONS- AND I AM JOINED
BY COLLEAGUES FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF HUMAN RESOURCES
FOR SOME MORE DETAILED
RESPONSES. THANK YOU LET'S SEE
IF THERE'S QUESTIONS ON THIS
ONE. ALL RIGHT SEEING NONE. WE
WILL ACT SENATOR DOLLY. YEAH
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS I DON'T
HAVE A COMMENT ON THIS BUT I
JUST WANT TO MAKE A GENERAL
COMMENT I DIDN'T AT THE PHONE
EIGHTY ONE TWENTY NINE BUT I
WANTED TO FIRST OF ALL. IF I
YOU MAY INDULGE ME JUST FOR A
MINUTE. I'D LIKE TO THANK THE
STAFF OR STAFF TO. HIS WORK
DILIGENTLY- WE WERE ON A ZOOM
LAST NIGHT AND I LIKE TO THANK
YOU AND THE MEMBERS OF THE
SUBCOMMITTEES. FOR THEIR HARD
WORK. ON THIS BUDGET THIS IS
THE LARGEST BUDGET. I BELIEVE
IN THE HISTORY OF THE STATE AND
THERE'S A LOT OF RESOURCES
MOVING AROUND. AND I WANNA SAY
THERE'S A LOT OF GOOD THINGS IN
ALL THESE BUDGETS AND THERE'S A
LOT OF THINGS THAT. OBVIOUSLY I
DON'T AGREE WITH BUT THE DEVIL
IS IN THE DETAILS. AND WHEN I
SAY THAT. I WANT TO JUST
PREFACE WITH THINGS LIKE
BROADBAND. WE'RE GONNA SPEND
SEVEN BILLION DOLLARS PROPOSED
SEVEN BILLION DOLLARS. ON
BROADBAND. BUT HOW IS THAT
REALLY GET EQUALLY TO. OUR
DISTRICTS AND OUR COMMUNITIES
AND HOW IS IT REALLY GOING TO
GET IMPLEMENTED I THINK. WHAT
THE POLICY PART OF OUR
DISCUSSION IS LACKING. THERE
ARE THERE OF IT IN THIS AREA
THERE FOUR FIVE BILLS THERE'S A
COUPLE BILLS IN THE ASSEMBLY
COUPLE BILLS IN THE SENATE. BUT
AT THE END OF THE DAY. HOW MY
GONNA GO BACK AND TELL MY
CONSTITUENTS WHAT THE SEVEN
BILLION DOLLARS IS GOING TO DO.
IT IS PROPOSED AS MIDDLE MILE
MIDDLE MILE DOES NOT HOOK
PEOPLE UP AND GET YOU. THE
MIDDLE MILE. BUT WE NEED THE
LAST MILE WE NEED TO. INNER
CITY HOUSINGS AS- SENATOR FROM
GARDENIA SENATOR BRADFORD
WORKING ON THINGS LIKE I'M
WORKING ON MY COMMUNITIES. AS
SENATOR COPULAR- THERE'S A
THERE'S A TO THE DETAILS WHAT'S
LACKING SO I JUST WANT TO. PUSH
THAT. WE FOLLOW UP IN THESE
TRAILER BILLS AND WE ACTUALLY
GET SOME DETAIL ON THE POLICY.
OF HOW IT'S GOING TO BE
IMPLEMENTED. THAT'S THAT'S THE
PART I THINK IT'S BEEN IN THE
END IT'S A I KNOW THAT WE ARE
NOT GOING TO DO IT IN THIS
BUDGET BUT WE'RE GOING TO BE
MOVING ON FORWARD. THINGS LIKE
PRESENTLY. PRESENT REALIGNMENT
WE HEARD FROM THE CHAIR OF SUB
FIVE WHO EXPLAIN SOME OF THAT
NOT EVERY MEMBERS YOU NEED THAT
BUT THE DEVIL'S IN THE DETAILS.
THINGS LIKE DROUGHT AND
WILDFIRE HOW HOW WE'RE GONNA
ACTUALLY ON THE GROUND MAKE A
DIFFERENCE FOR COMMUNITIES THAT
ARE SUFFERING FROM WILDFIRE. SO
I JUST WANT TO SHARE. THAT WE
REALLY NEED TO FOCUS ON THE
POLICY. AFTER THIS POINT.
THERE'S GONNA BE THIS ARE GONNA
PASS WE ALL KNOW THAT. BUT THE
POLICY IS WHAT MATTERS AND HOW
TO IMPLEMENT AND HOW IT AFFECTS
OUR CONSTITUENTS. AND I'LL JUST
CLOSE WITH JUST SHARING ONE
LAST THING THERE'S A HUNDRED
AND- NINETY SIX BILLION DOLLARS
A JET. FUND THERE'S- BILLION
DOLLARS. A FEDERAL FIVE THAT
ARE GOING TO BE IN. IN THIS BUT-
THE DEATH. THEY WERE PILING UP.
ON OUR CHILDREN. IT'S REALLY
HIGH AND WHAT'S THEIR FUTURE
LOOK LIKE. THINK ABOUT WE JUST
HEARD THE SENATOR FROM FREMONT
SAY THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT'S
GONNA PAY 90% AND WE'RE ONLY
GONNA PAY TEN WHAT WERE THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT ALL OF US IN
THE UNITED STATES OR THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT. AND WE'RE-
THIRTY TRILLION DOLLARS IN DEBT
AT SOME POINT THAT BILL HAS TO
BE PAID. WE DON'T TALK ABOUT
THAT. SO WHAT I WOULD ENCOURAGE
GOING FORWARD AGAIN WITH THE
THANKS TO THE STAFF AND IN THE
CHAIR AND ALL THE MEMBERS IN
THIS IS THAT WE- DOG THIS AND
THAT WE- REALLY. LOOK AT THE
POLICY AND HOW IT GETS
IMPLEMENTED ON THE GROUND TO
OUR CONSTITUENTS. BECAUSE THE
FUTURE FOR AMERICA AND FOR
CALIFORNIA'S GRAHAM IF YOU LOOK
AT THE DEBT. WE WANT WE WANT TO
DO WHAT'S RIGHT FOR THE FUTURE.
AND TO DO IT RIGHT IS MAKE OUR
MONEY GO FURTHER THAN IT DOES
AND MAKE SURE POLICIES ACTUALLY
WORK. SO AGAIN I WANT TO THANK
YOU I THANK YOU FOR GIVING ME
THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK AND
SHARE SOME OF MY THOUGHTS. AND
I LOOK FORWARD TO- WORKING ON
THOSE POLICIES IN THE FUTURE
MADAM CHAIR. THANK YOU SENATOR
DOLLY- I AM- I WILL NOT
ENTERTAIN ANY OTHER GENERIC
CONTENTS BECAUSE WE ARE STILL
ON THE ITEM. OF THE S. C. C. P.
O. H. M. O. U. I AM IF THERE'S
NO OTHER COMMENT OR QUESTION ON
THAT M. O. U. I AM GOING TO GO
TO THE PUBLIC COMMENT AND THEN-
AFTER THE PUBLIC COMMENT. WE
CAN TAKE ARJUN GENERAL COMMENTS
AN VOTE SO LET US NOW AND THEN
AFTER THAT WE'LL HAVE OUR
INFORMATIONAL ITEMS SO LET US
GO TO THE PUBLIC COMMENT. WE
WILL FIRST- LET ME JUST QUICKLY
FOR THOSE WHO ARE GONNA GIVE
PUBLIC COMMENT REMOTELY. THE
PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS EIGHT
SEVEN SEVEN. SIX NINE TWO.
EIGHT NINE FIVE SEVEN. AND THE
ACCESS CODE IS. ONE FOUR ZERO
SEVEN SEVEN FOUR FOUR. NOW LET
ME FIRST TURN TO ANY WITNESSES
HERE IN THE GALLERY ARE THERE
ANY WITNESSES WHO WANT TO GIVE
PUBLIC COMMENT WHO ARE HERE IN
THE GALLERY NOW. ALL RIGHT
SEEING NINE LET ME LOOK INTO
THE- AUXILIARY ROOM. AND THERE
ARE NO PERSONS THERE. SO WE
WILL GO TO THE- MODERATOR PHONE
MODERATOR YOU PLEASE QUEUE UP
FOLKS. ON THE TELECONFERENCE
ORVIS FOR. PUBLIC COMMENT.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND AS A
REMINDER FOR THOSE PARTICIPANTS
ON THE PHONE PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO YOU MAY WITHDRAW YOUR
QUESTION AT ANY TIME BY
REPEATING THE ONE ZERO COMMAND
AND ALTHOUGH THE LINE OF A
TWENTY ONE. TO ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. I LINE TWENTY ONE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS BEVERLY YOU
ON BEHALF OF YOU W. WE
APPRECIATE YOUR HARD WORK AND
LEADERSHIP. RIGHT EXACTLY
STRONGLY OR NOT THE PREMIER
RESTORATION WITH SOME PERCENT
CUT WHICH IS LONG OVERDUE FOR
PROVIDERS AND CONSUMERS WE LOOK
FORWARD TO SEEING TRAILERS A
LANGUAGE OTHER IDEAS THAT
PROVISION WHICH WILL HELP ALLOW
FOR CONTRACT WITH THE CLIPPER
BANGKOK WITH THE IDEA THAT
PROGRAM AT THE COOK COUNTY TO
MOVE NEGOTIATIONS FORWARD. ON
BEHALF OF FIFTY P. U. E.
PARTNERSHIP BETWEEN AT THE I.
EIGHTY W. WE WOULD HIGHLIGHT
THE CHILD THROUGH TONS OF THE
GREEN WITH THE STATE WHICH
INCLUDES STRONG RATE INCREASES
FOR CHILDCARE PROVIDERS IN
ACCESS TO CARE. FOR WORKING
PARENTS THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
YOUR WORK. HELLO LINE TWENTY
FOUR TO FOUR PLEASE GO. GOOD
MORNING MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
BILL MCGOVERN WITH THE
COALITION FOR CLEAN AIR
COMMENTING ON THE ZERO EMISSION
VEHICLE PROGRAMS IN EIGHTY ONE
TWENTY NINE. WE THANK THE
LEGISLATURE FOR INCLUDING THESE
PROGRAMS IN THE BUDGET NOW AND
PRIORITIZING ZERO EMISSION
TRANSPORTATION AND THE
INFRASTRUCTURE TO SUPPORT IT
THESE INVESTMENTS WILL AID IN
THE TRANSITION TO ZERO EMISSION
TRANSPORTATION WHICH IS
ESSENTIAL TO SOLVING OUR TWIN
CRISES OF AIR POLLUTION AND
CLIMATE CHANGE. BUT WE ARE
DISAPPOINTED THAT THE
LEGILATURE IS NOT PROVIDING
ADEQUATE FUNDING TO THE
TRANSPORTATION EQUITY PROJECTS
WHICH PROVIDE CLEAN MOBILITY TO
PEOPLE IN DISADVANTAGED IN LOW
INCOME COMMUNITIES WHO ARE MOST
IN NEED OF CLEAN SAFE AND
RELIABLE TRANSPORTATION. THE
GOVERNOR HAS PROPOSED MUCH
HIGHER NUMBERS FOR THESE
PROGRAMS AND WE'RE DISAPPOINTED
NOT TO SEE. THAT IN THIS BUDGET
THANK YOU. NEXT ON THE LINE
TWENTY SIX TWO SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE MY CAROL WITH
THE WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY- WE REALLY WANT TO
EXPRESS OUR GRATITUDE TO THE
GOVERNOR THE PRO TEM UM. THE
SPEAKER AND ALL THE STAFF THAT
HAVE WORKED ON TO PUT THIS
BUDGET TOGETHER- THIS IS REALLY
AN EXTRAORDINARY BUDGET FOR LOW
INCOME CALIFORNIANS- AND JUST
VERY QUICKLY I MEAN WE REALLY
ARE GRATEFUL FOR THE CHANGES TO
THE MEDICAL MEDICARE WILL HAVE
THAT CHANCE. FOR HELP STROLL
SENIORS OVER AGE FIFTY- FOR THE
LONG OVERDUE RESTORATION ABOUT
THE FIVE GRAMS ARE WE REALLY
APPRECIATE THE WORK DONE IN
THIS AREA. AND WE ALSO REALLY
APPRECIATE THE PROPOSAL TO
REPEAL CIVIL ASSESSMENT ONE
PERSON- WHO ARE IN TRAFFIC
COURT ANOTHER CRIMINAL RELATED
MATTERS- THERE'S SUBSTANTIAL
FUNDING IN HERE TO MAKE SURE
THAT PEOPLE HAVE ACCESS TO
JUSTICE- AND PROTECTIONS FROM
ADDICTION- WE'RE VERY HAPPY FOR
OUR SCRANTON CREEK FROM THE
OTHER CHANGES MADE TO THE
COWARDS PROGRAM. AND THEN
LASTLY WE ARE VERY SUPPORTIVE
OF PROJECTS IN THE FUNDING FOR
AFFORDABLE HOUSING- THIS IS
OBVIOUSLY AN IMPORTANT FOCUS AS
WE GO ON HOWEVER I. FORGOT TO
MENTION FOOD FOR ALL ANYWAY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR ALL
YOU'VE DONE IN THIS BUDGET AND
WE LOOK FORWARD TO THE BOATS
AND. GETTING THESE OPERATIONAL
THANK YOU. THANK NET WE WILL
TALK TO THE BY NUMBER TWO EIGHT
TO. PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
NEED PEOPLE PARTICULARLY IN THE.
SERVICE LA FIRST I WILL GIVE
ECHO MY FRIEND MIKE CARROLL-
COMMENT HE DID A LOT ALL THAT
SAID WE ARE. GRATEFUL FOR THIS
THANK AND WHAT IT WILL DO FOR
THE CLIENT TO SERVE IN THE
COMMUNITY AT RISK ACROSS HEALTH.
HE TO THAT PROGRAM SHE HIGH.
JUST WANTED TO TAKE YOU THE END
AND MULTI SENIOR SERVICES
PROGRAM AND PUTTING US BACK FOR
THE FIRST TIME TO WHERE WE WERE
IN 200-082-0009 BEFORE THE
GREAT RECESSION AND YOUR
INVESTMENTS IN SENIOR
NUTRITION. AND THE ENTIRE
INVESTMENT IN THE MASTER PLAN
UP FOR AGING WE ARE INCREDIBLY
GRATEFUL LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH YOU IN THE WEEKS
AND MONTHS AHEAD. ON
LIMITATIONS THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. AND NEXT WE'LL TWO LINE
NUMBER THIRTY FIVE THREE FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS RONALD
COLEMAN HERE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA PAN ETHNIC HEALTH
NETWORK HERE TO COME IN ON A B.
ONE TWENTY NINE WELL WE ARE
VERY EXCITED THAT THEY ARE
REALLY EXTRAORDINARY INVESTMENT
CONCLUDED IN THIS BUDGET THAT
WILL EXPAND HEALTH EQUITY. WE
ARE DISAPPOINTED THAT THIS
BUDGET MISSES AN OPPORTUNITY ON
COMPREHENSIVE PUBLIC HEALTH
INVESTMENTS. WE VERY MUCH
APPRECIATED THAT THE
LEGISLATURE UNDERSTOOD THAT FOR
STRONG PUBLIC HEALTH SYSTEM IT
TAKES A VILLAGE AND THAT'S WHY
THEY NOT ONLY ALLOCATED TWO
HUNDRED MILLION FOR
INFRASTRUCTURE AND WORKFORCE
AND PUBLIC HEALTH. BUT ALSO A
HUNDRED MILLION TO COMMUNITY
BASED ORGANIZATIONS THAT FOCUS
ON HEALTH EQUITY AND RACIAL
JUSTICE INTERVENTIONS AND
PUBLIC HEALTH. WE VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE THE AT MINIMUM THREE
HUNDRED BILLION ONGOING
COMMITMENT STARTING IN TWENTY
TWO TWENTY THREE AND LOOK
FORWARD TO DISCUSSIONS THAT
ALLOW US TO WORK TOGETHER TO
INVEST IN BOTH PUBLIC HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS AND COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS WORKING TOWARD
HEALTH EQUITY AND RACIAL
JUSTICE AS PART OF A
COMPREHENSIVE PUBLIC HEALTH
SYSTEM. OUR COMMUNITIES GREAT
WORK TO THE LEGISLATURE IN THE
ADMINISTRATION ON HEALTH FOR
ALL FIFTY PLUS FOOD FOR ALL
FIELD TESTING OF TRANSLATED
MEDI CAL DOCUMENT THE
ELIMINATION OF THE ARCHITECT
AND SO MUCH MORE THAT WILL
SUPPORT REDUCING DISPARITIES
AND IMPROVING HEALTH OUTCOMES.
THANK YOU. ALL FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP AND FOR YOUR HARD
WORK. AND NEXT WE'LL GO TO LINE
NUMBER FORTY FOUR ZERO PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS MICHAEL PIMENTEL
EXEC DIRECTOR OF THE CALIFORNIA
TRANSIT ASSOCIATION
REPRESENTING EIGHTY FIVE TRENDS
IN RELATION TO THE CROSS OR ST.
LEADS TO VOICE OUR SUPPORT
TODAY FOR EIGHTY ONE TWENTY
NINE AND IN PARTICULAR ONE
UNDERSCORE OUR SUPPORT FOR THE
TWO POINT SIX BILLION DOLLARS.
FOR THE TRADE IN THEIR CITY
RAIL CAPITAL PROGRAM THE TWO
POINT THREE BILLION DOLLARS FOR
YOUR MISSION VEHICLES
INFRASTRUCTURE AND A HUNDRED
WITH A HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS
FOR ZERO EMISSION RAIL AND
TRANSIT. HI PETE AND DOCUMENTS
ARE ABSOLUTELY CRITICAL FOR
TRANSFORMING OUR TRANSPORTATION
NETWORK AND FOR RECOVERING FROM
THE PANDEMIC WITH CLEANER
MOBILITY OPTIONS FOR ALL WE
UNDERSTAND THAT WITH REGARDS
THE INVESTMENT FOR THE TRANS
INTERSTATE RAIL CAPITAL
PROGRAM. THEY'RE STILL
DISCUSSION TO BE HAD IN PARTS
CORRECTION WOULD ENCOURAGE THE
ADMINISTRATION THE LEGISLATURE
TO REACH QUICK RESOLUTION IN
THOSE DISCUSSIONS TO PERMIT
NEEDS CRITICAL INVESTMENT. TO
MOVE FORWARD AGAIN THANK YOU
FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP AND
COMPOSING THESE AND INVESTMENTS
AND WILL PLEASE- TO SUPPORT. I.
EIGHTY ONE TWENTY NINE TODAY
THANK YOU. NEXT WE'LL GO TO
LINE NUMBER THIRTEEN ONE THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU MY
NAME IS MARTY MOTO I'M A FAMILY
MEMBER OF A PERSON WITH BILL
MILLER DISABILITIES ALSO A
MEMBER OF THE DEVELOPMENTAL
SERVICES TASK FORCE MEMBER OF
THE MASTER PLAN FOR AGING. ET
JUST WANT TO THANK- AND EQUIP
THE WORDS OF- MY COLLEAGUE- MY
CURLS AND THE OTHERS ON. ON THE
ON THE- BUDGET GREENMAN AND
WHAT IT DOES FOR LOW INCOME
CALIFORNIANS AND PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES SPECIALLY IN THE
AREA. OF I. HSS- AND ALSO THE
MEDICAID EXPANSION- THE DISH NO
FUNDING TO REGIONAL CENTRES
ESPECIALLY FOR THE RATE STUDY
THOUGH OF COURSE. WE WOULD
APPRECIATE MORE NEEDED
RESOURCES. LASTLY WE JUST WANT
TO. THANK THE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE BOTH PARTIES. FOR THE
DISCUSSION ON ALL THE BUDGET
BILLS. IT WAS REALLY GOOD TO
HEAR FROM MEMBERS OF BOTH
PARTIES TALK IN A VERY CIVIL
WAY. AND I JUST THINK IT WAS
GOOD INFORMATION PROVIDED BY-BOTH. PARTIES AND LASTLY WE
WOULD URGE THE COMMITTEE AND
THE LEGISLATURE TO SUPPORT THE
NEW SOME ADMINISTRATIONS JUNE
THIRD HOME AND COMMUNITY BASED
SERVICES SPENDING PLAN. THAT
LOOKS AT THE WHOLE PERSON AND
LOOKS AT PERSON CENTERED
OUTCOMES AND WE THINK IT'S A
GOOD LINKAGE. TO THE BUDGET
PACKAGE THANK YOU AGAIN FOR
YOUR TREMENDOUS WORK AND TO THE
TREMENDOUS WORK OF THE
SUBCOMMITTEE. STAFF AND THE
ADMINISTRATION. AND NEXT TO
LITTLE NUMBER TWO. SEVEN TO
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING THIS IS DOCTOR GORSKI
YOUR CALL LOOKING FOR MAXIMUM
CHILDCARE AND THE OLD
FIREHOUSE- I LIKE THE FIRST
THANK YOU LETTER THANK YOU FOR
PAYING SO MUCH ATTENTION GIVEN
SO MUCH TO EARLY CHILDHOOD
EDUCATION I WOULD HAVE WOULD
HAVE TO SAY. THAT WE ARE SO HOW
WILL THAT NINETEEN FORTY FIVE
THE CHILDCARE AND PUT IT UNDER
THE NEXT DELIVERY SYSTEM FOR
THE PREPAID PROGRAM WITHOUT
THAT MIGHT HELP HE IS GOING TO
BE DEPLOYED WILL NOT. FIT INTO
HARBORS IT WILL BE DESTROYED SO
WE NEED TO CONSIDER THAT PART
OF THE MIX LIBRARY SYSTEM THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY. TO
SPEAK WITH YOU. THANK YOU. YES
A LITTLE LINE FORTY ONE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING MADAM
AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME
IS DENISE LIKE- AND I AM FROM
INDEPENDENCE AT HOME BEAUTY
SERVICES CAN HELP PLAN IN LOS
ANGELES COUNTY. AND I WOULD-LIKE TO THANK YOU AND ECHO THE
COMMENTS OF MY COLLEAGUE MEANS
PEOPLE PARK AND MY OTHER AGING
SERVICES CALLING ON A BUDGET
THAT WAS WELL THOUGHT OUT TO
SUPPORT OUR OLDER ADULT. AGE IN
PLACE AND OUR GREAT STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. AS WE SAW WITH THE
PANDEMIC THEY WERE PARTICULARLY
VULNERABLE AND WE WANT TO
ENSURE THAT THEY CAN REMAIN
SAFE AND ALL THE CHOICES THAT
MAKE OR NOT. I WANT TO POINT
OUT THAT A SPECIAL APPRECIATION
FOR MAKING A MESS THE
MULTIPURPOSE SENIOR SERVICES
PROGRAM WHOLE AGAIN- WE ARE
NURSING HOME ALTERNATIVE THAT
REALLY KEPT A LOT OF PEOPLE
AWAY FROM THE PANDEMIC AFFECT.
BUT IT TAKES A VILLAGE AND SO
ALL OF YOUR FUNDING TO ALL THE
SERVICE OF THE CROSS AG IS.
APPRECIATED AND APPLAUDED THANK
YOU. NEXT WE'LL GO TO LINE
THIRTY NINE THREE NINE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS THIS IS
JANELLE CARTER FROM THE ANTI
RECIDIVISM COALITION WE
APPRECIATE ALL THE WORK ON THIS
BUDGET AND PRIORITIZE ATION OF
INVESTING IN MOBILE WELL THEN
THAT YOU KNOW. WILL POPULATE.
YOUR INCREDIBLE GRATEFUL THAT
SHE ON BOARD INVESTMENTS IN THE
REHABILITATION REENTRY AND
RECIDIVISM REDUCTION STRATEGY.
SEPARATELY THE EVIDENCE BASED
REHABILITATION PROGRAMS CLOSE
CURRENTLY INCARCERATED.
ADEQUATE FUNDING FOR THE OFFICE
OF YOUTH AND COMMUNITY
RESTORATION AND THE REDUCTION
FARMS EAST ON THE LOW INCOME
CALIFORNIANS SO I JUST WANT TO
SAY THANK YOU AND APPRECIATE
ALL THE HARD WORK. BEING
INVESTING. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
NEXT WE'LL GO TO LINE THIRTY
TWO THREE TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
I'M SURE MEMBERS- THIS IS
JOSEPH WITH ACTOR WAS THAT OF A
COALITION WE APPRECIATE ALL THE
WORK ON THE BUDGET AND POWER TO
THE PROPER LOCATION OF
INVESTING IN MORAL POPULATION
AMONG OTHERS WE ARE TO BE
GRATEFUL FOR THE ONGOING
INVESTMENT AND REHABILITATION
REENTRY AND REDUCING.
RECIDIVISM REDUCTION STRATEGY
SPECIFICALLY EVIDENCE BASED
REHABILITATIVE PROGRAMS FOR
THOSE CURRENTLY INCARCERATED
ADEQUATE FUNDING FOR OFFICE THE
MUSIC COMMUNITY RESTORATION ALL
RIGHT THE R. AND A REDUCTION
OF. FINES AND FEES. ON LOW
INCOME CALIFORNIA THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. WE'LL GO TO LINE
FORTY ONE FOR ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO GOOD MORNING MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
FINE GAEL GARCIA WITH THE ANTI
RECIDIVISM COALITION AND I
APPRECIATE THE WORK ON THE
BUDGET AND THE PRIORITIZED THE
HINT OF INVESTING IN VULNERABLE
POPULATIONS. AMONG OTHERS I AM
INCREDIBLY GRATEFUL TO SEE THE
ONGOING INVESTMENT IN
REHABILITATION REENTRY
PERCENTAGES AND REDUCTION
STRATEGY SPECIFICALLY EVIDENT
FATE WE ABILITY OF. PROGRAMMING
FOR THOSE CURRENTLY IN CART%
THIRTY ADEQUATE FUNDING FOR THE
OFFICE OF YOUTH AND COMMUNITY
RESTORATION- WHAT WE ARE AND
THE REDUCTION OF FINES AND
FEES. ON LOW INCOME. CALIFORNIA
THANK YOU AND HAVE A GREAT DAY.
IT WILL MOVE TO LINE FORTY
THREE FOUR THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. ONE FORTY THREE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. IN LINE FORTY
THREE DID YOU HAVE A PUBLIC
COMMENT. WHEN WE MEET. YES
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU MY
APOLOGIES MY MUTE BUTTON
MUSHTAQ- GOOD MORNING MADAM
CHAIR AND SENATORS DELEGATES
REPRESENTING THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY OFFICE OF EDUCATION
pWOULD LIKE TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE FOR THEIR
EXTRAORDINARY WORK THIS YEAR
UNDER SO MANY CHALLENGES WE
KNOW YOU HAVE MANY PRIORITIES
WE WANT TO THANK YOU. FOR THE
THREE BILLION DOLLARS IN ONE
TIME PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
FUNDING FOR CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY SCHOOL PARTNERSHIP
PROGRAM WE KNOW THIS IS THE
PROGRAM THAT HAS BEEN
SUCCESSFUL IN LOS ANGELES
COUNTY BUT NEEDED TO BE
EXPANDED TO OTHER SCHOOLS THAT
WANTED TO PARTICIPATE IN THE
PROGRAM WE THANK YOU FOR THAT
WELCOME THANK YOU FOR PAYING
DOWN DEFERRALS- IN THE AMOUNT
OF ELEVEN BILLION DOLLARS. AND
ALSO THANK YOU FOR THE
COMPREHENSIVE EARLY LEARNING
AND CARE FUNDING THAT YOU
PROVIDED- INCLUDING THAT HE
CAN'T STAND HIM BUT ALSO
RECOGNIZING HEAD START- AND
MAKING SURE. THAT HEAD START
HAS- THE AUSTRALIAN NATIONAL TO
CONTINUE ALONG SIDE PK. WE ALL
ARE TO THANK YOU FOR THE
BROADBAND FUNDING WE KNOW THIS
YEAR- IT HAS BEEN IMPORTANT FOR
STUDENTS TO CONTINUE DISTANCE
LEARNING WE KNOW THAT YOU'RE
CONTINUING EXPANDED LEARNING
PROGRAMS AS WELL IN THE BUDGET
SO. WE APPRECIATE THOSE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR STUDENTS
GOING FORWARD SLASH THREE ARE
WOULD LIKE TO THANK YOU FOR THE
CAREER TECHNICAL EDUCATION
FUNDING IN A HUNDRED AND FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS ON GOING FUN.
IF CERTAINLY BEEN A PRIORITY
FOR THE COUNTY OFFICE. URGES
CONTINUED- HARD WORK OVER THE
NEXT COMING DAYS WHEN NO OTHER
BILLS ARE BEING AMENDED AND WE
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
YOU AGAIN ON WITH. MUCH
APPRECIATION THANK YOU FOR YOUR
WORK. AND NEXT WE'LL GO TO LINE
AT FORTY FOUR. FOUR FOUR PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING SURE AND
JANITORS THIS IS JUDY HYMAN
REPRESENTING CHARACTERS
CALIFORNIA ALLIANCE
ORGANIZATIONS AND INDIVIDUALS
PROMOTING THE SYSTEM OF SUPPORT
AND CARE FOR ALL PEOPLE IN
NEED. IN PLACE OF THE CURRENT
CARCERAL SYSTEM. WE ARE DEEPLY
DISAPPOINTED IN THE EXPANSION
OF PRE TRIAL PROBATION IN
EIGHTY ONE TWENTY NINE. YOUR
SUMMARY IT SAYS THIS WILL BE.
HEY THAT IT WILL INCREASE LONG
TERM MATCHING CLOSE RELATIONS.
JUDICIAL COUNCIL DATA SHOWS
THAT THE PROGRAM THE PILOT
PROGRAM TO HAVE A 30% NO
RESTAURANT AND 40% FAILURE TO
APPEAR IN COURT. COMPARE THAT
TO FROM ZERO TO NO MORE THAN A
FEW PERCENT INVESTING COMMUNITY
BASED PRE TRIAL SUPPORT
PROGRAMS. AS A RESULT A LOT OF
CALIFORNIANS WILL BE JAILED FOR
TECHNICAL PROBATION VIOLATIONS
OR BECAUSE THEY GOT AN ANKLE
MONITOR INSTEAD OF HELP WITH
CHILDCARE TRANSPORT OR OTHER
BARRIERS KEEPING THEM FROM
COLLEGE. MAKE NO MISTAKE.
ENGINE OF PROBATION IS AN
INVESTMENT IN MASS
INCARCERATION. OUR HOPE AND
REQUESTED THAT YOU WILL KEEP
THE DOOR OPEN TO WORKING WITH
US OVER TIME. TO MOVE AWAY FROM
THIS FAILED APPROACH TO THE
COMMUNITY BASED APPROACHES THE
EVIDENCE SHOWS TRULY PROTECT
PUBLIC SAFETY. AND RESTORE.
THANK YOU. OUR MODERATOR BEFORE
YOU CALL IN THE NEXT CAN YOU
TELL ME HOW MANY PEOPLE ARE IN
THE QUEUE. WE STILL HAVE A TAN
IN Q. ALL RIGHT THANK YOU
PLEASE PROCEED. AND WE'LL GO TO
LINE AT FORTY EIGHT FOUR EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
SHARES INTERNAL MEMBERS OF THAT
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS TURNING
COLDER WITH THE CALIFORNIA
ALTERNATIVE PAYMENT PROGRAM
ASSOCIATION. FOR PUBLIC AND
PRIVATE COMMUNITY BASED
NONPROFIT THAT SUPPORT
ESSENTIAL AND ARE LOW INCOME
FAMILIES. WITH ACCESS TO
CHILDCARE AND OTHER SUPPORT TO
LIFT THEM TO SELF SUFFICIENCY
WE ARE HUGELY APPRECIATIVE OF
THE INVESTMENT OF OVER TWO
HUNDRED THOUSAND CHILDCARE
SLOTS FOR LOW INCOME FAMILIES
TO ACCESS. AS WELL AS
INCREASING THE RATES FOR FAMILY
CHILD CARE PROVIDERS. AND OTHER
SUPPORT THIS TYPE OF. NO WE ARE
AT THE CORE OF THE RAY INCREASE
WITH THE HOW CARE FROM. WE ASK
THAT YOU MAKE CLEAR ENSURE THAT
RATE INCREASES WILL ALSO APPLY
TO ALL PROVIDERS THAT SUPPORT
THAT FLIGHT FAMILIES. INCLUDING
OUR DIRECT CHILDCARE CENTERS.
ALL SUBSIDIZED CHILDCARE
PROVIDERS ARE SUFFERING AND ALL
PROVIDER TYPES NEED TO BE
LIFTED. WE WOULD LIKE TO WORK
WITH YOU ON SECURING ONE TIME
FUNDING TO ALLOW AGENCIES TO
ENROLL THE NEW CHILD CARE
SLOTS. AS WELL AS THE CALCULATE
HOW RATE INCREASES FOR
PROVIDERS. AND DRAFTED AV ONE
Q. NINE WILL REQUIRE AGENCIES
TO INCREASE INDIVIDUAL PROVIDER
RATE ON A CASE BY CASE BASIS.
THIS IS HUGELY COSTLY TO
AGENCIES AND WILL COME AT THE
EXPENSE OF FAMILY SUPPORT
SERVICES. EIGHTY ONE Q. NINE IS
DEFINITELY GOING IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION WE ASK THAT YOU
CONTINUE TO WORK ON SHORING UP
THE EXISTING COMMUNITY BASED
PROGRAMS AND STRENGTHEN THEM.
WELCOME TO MANTA I'M CONNECTING
ESSENTIAL AND ARE FORCED TO
WORKING FAMILIES. THE CHILD
CARE YOU'RE DEFINITELY GOING.
IT WILL TO LINE FORTY NINE FOUR
NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING HER MEMBERS BRENDAN
DAWSON WITH THEIR CONTROL GOING
ON I WAS CALLING IN RESPECT TO
EIGHTY ONE TWENTY NINE SECTION
NINETY SEVEN CONCERNING THE
PREPARATIONS OF THE PARK WE
WERE JUST GOING INTO THE CAR
HAD. BEEN REPEALED FROM THE BUG
BUDGET BILL WE'D LOVE TO SEE
THAT N. AS PRESERVATIONISTS
PARK IS DIRECTLY IN LINE WITH
THE. GOVERNMENT STARTED
RECOGNITION. THANK YOU. AND WE
WILL BUILD TWO LINE AT FIFTY
FIVE ZERO PLEASE GO AHEAD. I
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS THIS IS MATTHEW EASLEY
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
CORRECTIONAL PEACE OFFICERS
ASSOCIATION. WE APPRECIATE THE
LEGISLATURE SUPPORT AND THAT OF
THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE WITH
EIGHTY ONE FIFTY NINE. THAT WE
DEFINITELY APPRECIATE THE
RESTORATION OF LAST YEAR'S PAY
CUTS AND BENEFIT REDUCTIONS IN
LIGHT OF THE UNEXPECTED
REVENUES THE STATUS RECEIVED.
INTERROGATION OF THANKFUL FOR
YOUR CONSIDERATION AND LOOK
FORWARD TO THE REPLICATION OF
THE ADDENDUM TO OUR IN MY YOUTH
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. AND THAT'S
A LITTLE TOO LINE AT FIFTY ONE
FIVE ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS
JAMIE MCINTYRE WITH HEAD START
CALIFORNIA THANK YOU TO YOU AND
THE COMMITTEE STAFF ARE WORKING
WITH OUR HEAD START PROGRAMS
AND WE ARE LOOKING FORWARD TO
THE UPCOMING TRAILER THE
LANGUAGE THAT IS IMPENDING THE
COURT HEAD START PROGRAMS.
TRANSACTION AND WE'RE EAGERLY
AWAITING THE LANGUAGE AND WILL
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH YOU TO
MAKE SURE THAT OUR PROGRAM
PROBABLY NEED TO TRANSITION.
AND CONTINUED TO CRY EVEN.
FORWARD MY COMMENTS ARE TO
CHILD CARE A DIFFICULT. FOR THE
TRANSFER OF THREE POINT EIGHT
BILLION AND FEDERAL AMERICAN
RESCUE PLANNING. ONE FOR
HEALTHCARE FROM THE DEPARTMENT
OF EDUCATION FOR THE DEPARTMENT
OF SOCIAL SERVICES. HELLO WHEN
YOU BELIEVE THAT A SIGNIFICANT
PORTION OF THAT FUNDING BE
DIRECTED TOWARD PROGRAMS ARE
BEING SUBSIDIZED AND ARE MOST
AT RISK CHILDREN. INCLUDING
HEAD START AND EARLY HEAD START
PROGRAM. WE REQUEST THAT YOU
GET SEVENTY FIVE MILLION EACH
YEAR FOR THE NEXT TWO YEARS OF
THE- A. R. P. FUNDING BE
PREDICATED HADSTARTED EARLY
HEAD START PROGRAMS FOR A TOTAL
OF. SEVEN HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION
WITH FLEXIBILITY AT THE PROGRAM
LEVEL HE THE FUNDING FOR THE
RECORDING OF THE DRAFTING
STAFFING SHORTAGES. INCREASE
OUTREACH SUPPORT MY FAMILY. AND
HELPING HER. START PROGRAMS IN
ADDITION. THANK YOU FOR YOUR-
SUPPORT ABOUT THANK. NEXT WE'LL
GO TO LINE FIFTY THREE FIVE
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING ERIN MACKEY WITH PUBLIC
ADVOCATES WE WANT TO EXPRESS
THEIR APPRECIATION TO THE
LEGISLATURE ADMINISTRATION BACK
FOR YOUR EXCELLENT WORK ON
EDUCATION BUDGET PACKAGE AND
WE'RE CONTINUING TO CENTER CITY
WE'RE THRILLED TO SEE OUR CALLS
FOR THREE BILLION DOLLARS FOR
COMMUNITY SCHOOLS INCLUDED IN
THE FINAL DEAL. WE ASK THAT
COLLABORATIVE PLANNING AND
DECISION MAKING THE PARENTS
STUDENTS TEACHERS AND STAFF BE
REQUIRED ALONG WITH PROVIDING
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE. WITH
ONLINE SUPPORT INCREASING THE
LCF CONCENTRATION GRANTED 65%
AND SUPPORT THE COMBINED TWO
POINT EIGHT BILLION DOLLAR
INVESTMENT EDUCATOR TRAINING
AND PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT TO
EXPAND AND DIVERSIFY THE
TEACHER PIPELINE. LASTLY WE ARE
PLEASED TO SEE THAT CD WILL
RECEIVE. SIX POINT SIX MILLION
TO UPGRADE. THE SPECIALLY
IMPORTANT BUSINESS AS IT. A FOR
THE STATES NEW CRADLE TO CAREER
DATA FOR THEM UNFORTUNATELY AS
A CONDITION OF RECEIVING YOU
FIND CDS PROHIBITED FROM
ACQUIRING LDH RECORDING IT
BEYOND WHAT THEY'RE ALREADY
REPARTEE. THIS IS ANTITHETICAL
TO THE IDEA THAT PRINCIPLES OF
TRANSPARENCY AND ACCOUNTABILITY
AND FEDERAL GUIDANCE ON DATA
COLLECTION FOR THE RECENT
STIMULUS PLAN. WITH BILLIONS IN
NEW FUNDING A SHAMEFUL THAT THE
STATE IS LIMITING ITS ABILITY
TO EVALUATE THE- PERFORMANCE
IMPROVEMENT. AS SUCH WE THINK
THIS CONDITION SHOULD BE
STRICKEN. THANK YOU FOR
CONSIDERING A RECOMMENDATION.
AND WE'LL GO TO LINE AT FIFTY
SIX FIVE SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE HI MY
NAME IS DAN OPEN TALKS WITH THE
CALIFORNIA FOUNDATION FOR
INDEPENDENT LIVING CENTERS. WE
ARE DELIGHTED THE HOME AND
COMMUNITY BASED SERVICES
PROPOSAL THAN THAT FIVE POINT
TWO BILLION FEDERAL FUNDS TO
EXPAND SERVICES AND SUPPORTS TO
CALIFORNIANS WITH DISABILITIES
AND AN OLDER ADULTS WHO DESERVE
TO THRIVE AND LIVE IN THEIR OWN
HOMES AS THEY AGE- WE APPLAUD
AND THANK THE STATE FOR
PRIORITIZING IN THE PAST LIVING
CENTERS. AND THE TRANSITION
WORK THAT WE'VE DONE TO KEEP
INDIVIDUAL DISABILITIES AS WELL
THE OLDER ADULTS IN THEIR HOMES
AND COMMUNITY. C. S. I. L. C.
WE ARE A MEMBERSHIP ASSOCIATION
FOR TWENTY FOR THE PELICANS
HONORS IN THE STATE. AND WE
PRIORITIZE INCLUSION ACCESS AND
EQUITY ENSURE THAT DISABLED
PEOPLE HAVE THE. CHOICE TO LIVE
INDEPENDENTLY IN THE COMMUNITY.
WHAT SPORTS THAT THEY- ARE WE
CONTINUE- PORT- ABSENCE OF THE
ADMINISTRATION TO INCREASE HOME
AND COMMUNITY SERVICES FOR
PEOPLE DISABILITY IN OLDER
ADULTS. AND WHILE THE STATE
WORKS TO BUILD BACK BETTER YES
I'LL SEE THAT SIDE YOU PART OF
THE CHANGE LOOKS FORWARD TO
WITNESSING LEADERSHIP- OF- THIS
BODY AND BRINGING THAT.
GRADIENT CALIFORNIA FOR ALL
PEOPLE THANK YOU SO MUCH. AND
WE'LL MOVE NEXT TO LINE AT
FORTY FIVE FOUR FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE THAT ESPANA AS
WITH THE ANTI RECIDIVISM
COALITION I WOULD GREATLY
APPRECIATE ALL THE WORK ON THIS
BUDGET THE PRIVATIZATION OF.
THOSE MOST VULNERABLE
POPULATIONS AMONG OTHERS WE ARE
INCREDIBLY GRATEFUL TO SEE THE
ONGOING INVESTMENTS IN
REHABILITATION REENTRY AND
REDUCING RECIDIVISM
SPECIFICALLY THOSE INVESTMENTS
TO REPORTS AS EVIDENCE BASED
REHABILITATIVE PROGRAMMING FOR
THOSE CURRENTLY INCARCERATED
AND PREPARING TO RE INTEGRATE
INTO SOCIETY. WE ALSO
APPRECIATE THE ADEQUATE FUNDING
FOR THE OFFICE OF YOUTH AND
COMMUNITY RESTORATION ALLY C.
R. AND THE REDUCTION OF FINES
AND FEES. THAT ARE LOW INCOME
CALIFORNIA THANK YOU SO MUCH.
NEXT IN LINE THIRTY ONE THREE
ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS
THIS IS CARL KASELL PROFOUND
BUT- RECIDIVISM COALITION WE
APPRECIATE ALL THE WORK ON THE
BUDGET AND THE PARTS ARE USED
IN OF MASS IN THE MORNING-
POPULATIONS AMONG OTHERS VERY
CREDIBLE BREAK FROM THE YOUNG
GOING TO MASS AND
REHABILITATION REENTRY AND
RECIDIVISM REDUCTION STRATEGY
SPECIFICALLY AN EVIDENCE BASED
REHABILITATIVE PROGRAMS FOR
BOTH CURRENT AND CARSON.
ADEQUATE FUNDING FOR OFFICE FOR
YOU THINK YOU NEED TO RESTORE
RACIAL ALL WHITE C. R. AND THE
REDUCTION HE- SAID THAT A.
LOCAL CALIFORNIA THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. AND WE'LL GO TO LINE AT
FIFTY SEVEN FIVE SEVEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. ONE FIFTY SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS THIS IS
JORDAN LINDSEY WITH THE R. CAN
UNITED CEREBRAL PALSY
CALIFORNIA COLLABORATION I JUST
WANT TO QUICKLY AND SIMPLY SAY
THANK YOU TO THE LEGISLATURE
THE ADMINISTRATION AND STAFF
PRETTY ABSOLUTELY INCREDIBLE
WORK DONE TO PRIORITIZE
CALIFORNIANS WITH INTELLECTUAL
AND DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES
THEIR FAMILIES FOR SUPPORT
STAFF THEIR PROVIDERS IN ITS
BUDGET. FUNDING THE DDS RATE
STUDY ALONG WITH THE OTHER
BUDGET ITEMS TAKEN I TRULY HAVE
THE POTENTIAL TO BE
TRANSFORMATIVE FOR OUR
COMMUNITY THIS YEAR IN YEARS
GOING FORWARD THE POLICE THANK
YOU FOR THE WORK DONE TO
PRIORITIZE CALIFORNIANS WITH
DISABILITIES TO FEAR. THANK YOU.
AND WE MOVED TO LINE AT FIFTY
EIGHT FIVE EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. I WAS SO HIGH WITH THE
CALIFORNIA SPECIAL DISTRICTS
ASSOCIATION- WE JUST WANTED TO
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
SUPPORT AND GETTING
PARTICULARLY INDEPENDENT
SPECIAL DISTRICTS. HAVE
ENCOUNTERED REVENUE IMPACT TO
THE COMPANY IN RESPONSE TO A
PARTICULAR THANK YOU FOR THE
HUNDRED MILLION IN ONE TIME
FUNDING FOR THAT PURPOSE AND
FOR YOUR SUPPORT HE DIANE FOR
NON PAYMENT OF UTILITIES TO
ASSIST REPAIR THAN THE IMPACT
THE PUBLIC AGENCIES. AS WELL
THE TWO HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION
FOR ECONOMIC ASSISTANCE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC SUPPORT AND
YOUR ROBUST INVESTMENTS IN
PRIORITY LOCAL TRANSIT
PROJECTS. WE KNOW THAT DESPITE
THE ONCE IN A LIFETIME LEVELS
OF FUNDING IN THE BUDGET YOU
HAVE AN OVERWHELMING AMOUNT OF
COMPETING PRIORITIES FOR THE
FUND. WE ARE DEEPLY
APPRECIATIVE FOR YOUR SUPPORT
MAKES ANY PHYSICAL RELIEF THAT
IS ACCEPTABLE TO SPECIAL
DISTRICTS HAVE BEEN IMPACTED
OVER THE PAST YEAR WHILE THEY
CONTINUE TO MEET THE NEEDS OF
OUR LOCAL COMMUNITIES. THAT'S
FUNNY WILL GO ALONG WAY TO HELP
MEET THE NEEDS OF THE LOCAL
PUBLIC AGENCIES OPERATE MAKING
ABOUT RUSSIA THE SECRET PLAN
FOR STRUCTURE SO THEY CAN
CONTINUE TO DELIVER RELIABLE
AFFORDABLE AND VITAL LOCAL
SERVICES. GET READY TO MEET THE
NEXT EMERGENCY THANK YOU. IN GO
TO. IF FOUR. FIVE FOUR PLEASE
GO AHEAD. MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE SENATE BUDGET
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS NICOLE
WONG CREAM TRAUMA PROGRAM AT
THE NATIONAL SOCIAL TRAFFIC
FROM CROCKETT JEAN KERR YOUR
COMMENT ON EIGHTY ONE G. NINE.
STRONGLY SUPPORT AND EXPRESS
OUR GRATITUDE FOR THINKING OF
GETTING BACK AT THREE POINT
NINE BILLION OVER THREE YEARS
PART ZERO EMISSION VEHICLES AND
ASSOCIATED INFRASTRUCTURE WHICH
WILL BE CRUCIAL TO GRAD
TRANSPORTATION POLLUTION WHICH
CHRONICLED IN OUR STATE. ARE
MORE TARGETED MEASURES ARE
NEEDED TO ENSURE LONG
COMMUNITY. COLOR OR JUST A
PORTION OF THE DIESEL POLLUTION
FROM THE MEDIUM AND HEAVY DUTY
VEHICLES ON OUR ROADS CAN
ACCESS THE PUBLIC HOW CAN I
MAKE A MOBILITY BENEFITS OF
CLEAN TRANSPORTATION. OPTIONS
LIKE. YOU CALLED. TO ADDRESS
THE IS TWENTY THIRTY. I'M
SHOWING JUNIOR. FIVE HUNDRED
FOR TRANSFER TO ACTUALLY.
CONDUCTED AT LEAST ONE FIFTY
NINE THE GREEN CARD ALL OF
THEIR PROGRAM THAT COULD BE.
USING IN THE WE CAN HELP ENSURE
VIOLENT CALIFORNIANS ACTUALLY
TO CLEANER VEHICLES. AND ALSO
I'M ACTUALLY IF WE DEDICATE AT
LEAST HALF OF THE CLEAN
TRANSPORTATION PROGRAMS FIND.
FOR PRESIDENT THE DISADVANTAGE
OF OUR COMMUNITIES. ARE
COMPLETELY FORGETTING
EVERYTHING BACKING THEIR
MACHINE VEHICLES AND LAUGHING
YOU COULD INCREASE FUNDING FOR
TRANSPORTATION. PROJECTS THE
TARGET CHARGING INFRASTRUCTURE
DOLLARS TOWARD LONG CONTINUED
AND THOSE MOST IMPACTED BY
TRANSPORTATION. SOLUTIONS THANK
YOU. AND WE WILL TO LONG AT
FIFTH NINE FIVE NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING THIS IS
THREE SEPARATE AND DISTINCT
CLIMATE POLICY DIRECTOR WITH
PACIFIC ENVIRONMENT WHERE WE
ARE ONE OF TWO CALIFORNIA NGOS
WITH A COMPLICATED STATUS AT
THE INTERNATIONAL MARITIME
ORGANIZATION WHERE WE WORK TO
CLEAN UP SHIPPING FOR THE LAST
TEN YEARS- WHAT PIZZA DO YOU
NEED A HUNDRED TEN MILLION
DOLLAR GREEN HYDROGEN FUNDING
IN THE BUDGET. XCELERATED
TRANSITION AWAY FROM FOSSIL
FUEL AND- THAT A THREE HUNDRED
FIFTY MILLION FOR CARD TRUCKS
BUSES AND OFF ROAD EQUIPMENT
WHICH INCLUDES FUNDING TO
SUPPORT- FEEL TECHNOLOGY OR
JOHN MISSION AND HYBRID IN THE
MARINE BATTLE- WE WOULD ALSO
URGE YOU TO USE THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO FIND SUPPORT
ELECTRIFICATION TO MODERNIZE
OPERATIONS. AND DRASTICALLY
REDUCE EMISSIONS FOR CRYING AND-
UNITY CHIPS ARE ONE OF THE
WORST POLLUTERS IN CALIFORNIA
ACCOUNTING FOR NEARLY 1% OF
STATE GREENHOUSE GAS POLLUTION
AND IN AREAS SURROUNDING THE
SAN PEDRO BAY PORTS. ARE
CRACKED ONSTITUTES AS ONE OF
THE TOP THREE COURSES OF CANCER
READ BECAUSE OF THE DIESEL
PARTICULATE. MATTER EXPOSURE
THANK YOU SO MUCH. AN EXCLUSIVE
LINE IS SIXTY SIX ZERO PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS INTERCHANGE FROM THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF FOOD
BANKS I JUST WANT TO EXPRESS
OUR DEEP GRATITUDE AND
EXCITEMENT- WITH THE STILL
RECORD HUNGER IN OUR
COMMUNITIES I'M FOR THE WORK
DONE BY THE ADMINISTRATION AND
LEGISLATURE I THANK SENATORS
LAYERED NEWMAN AN ADMIN FOR THE
HISTORIC PACKAGE ACCORDING TO
THE BANK TO CONTINUE TO FACE
RECORD HUNGER IN LONG LINES.
THE TRULY TRANSFORMATIONAL
PACKAGES ON SCHOOL MEALS FOR
ALL THE DEAL TO RESTORE ACCESS
TO GRANTS FULLY RESTORING THE
CUTS OVER A FEW YEARS PROGRESS
TOWARD FOOD AND HELP FOR ALL
THE ASSET TAG IN MEDICARE ALL
INVESTMENTS IN CAL WORKS FINES
AND FEES SO MANY POLICIES TO.
HELP LOW INCOME FAMILIES AND
PROPEL MARKETABLE FEATURE
LOOKING FORWARD TO SEEING THE
DETAILS ON THE POLICIES AND
OBVIOUSLY FINAL AGREEMENT.
SIGNATURE THANK YOU SO MUCH.
AND WE'LL GO TO LINE SIXTY TWO
SIX TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
BROWN CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE- MARK A PRAYER I'M
TESTIFYING ON BEHALF OF CHARGE
POINTS. WE WANT TO THANK THE
GOVERNOR- THIS COMMITTEE AND
THE SENATE AND THE ASSEMBLY FOR
ALL THEIR WORK THEY DID ON-
PUTTING TOGETHER IS THE ZERO
EMISSION- PACKAGE AND- WE- URGE
YOUR SUPPORT OF THIS MEASURE
TODAY AND AS IT MAKES ITS WAY
TO THE SENATE FLOOR. THANK YOU.
IN MENDHAM KERA NO FURTHER
PUBLIC TESTIMONIES AT THIS TIME.
THANKS VERY MUCH SO WE ARE NOW
AT THE PLACE WHERE WE CAN
BEGIN- VOTING. AND I KNOW I
HAVE A MEMBER WHO NEEDS TO
LEAVE SOON SO I'M GOING TO SAVE
MY COMMENTS FROM THE FLOOR- SO
THAT WE CAN PROCEED BUT LET ME
SEE IF THEY'RE SET UP OKAY SO
WE CAN'T ARE SO ON THE FIRST
BILL BEFORE US. IS- ONE MOMENT
POLITIES SIMEK. GOING BACK TO
MY VERY FIRST. YES SIR EIGHTY
ONE TWENTY NINE THAT'S THE
FIRST BILL BEFORE US IS THERE A
MOTION SENATOR LAYER JUST
MOVED- WE WILL NOW CALL THE
ROLL. EIGHTY ONE TWENTY NINE
THE MOTION IS TO PASS SENATOR
SKINNER HI SKINNER HI NIELSEN
NO. NOTHING NO COPYRIGHT. RIGHT
HI. CORTESE WELL WE'RE TEDDY I.
DOLLY TORONTO THE RUSSELL HI
ADNAN BIG MAN HIGH GROWTH. COM
LONGER. LAYERED HI THERE HI THE
GLIDER MELINDA'S MAN HI MAN HI
NEWMAN NEWMAN HI- TROUBLE. PENN
HI PAM I STERN. WHY CASKEY.
MCGUIRE HI. CAMARGO HI. WE
WILL- KEEP THAT BILL AND CALL
TO HAVE ALLOW AND SENATOR STERN
ADELINE AND WE THAT WAS THE
BUDGET BILL JUNIOR WILL NOW GO
TO EIGHTY ONE THIRTY NINE THE
GOLDEN STATE STIMULUS MOTION BY
SENATOR LAYERED- PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. EIGHTY ONE THIRTY
NINE THE MOTION TO PASS
SENATORS SKINNER BY SKINNER HI
NIELSEN. YES AND NO COPYRIGHT.
FEBRUARY HI. CORTESE ALL RIGHT
WHATEVER THE HI ALI OKAY DOLLY
NO THE RAZA HI BROTHER HI
EGGMAN. GROWTH. GROVE NO COM
LONGER CARMICHAEL I LAYERED.
LAYERED HI THE WIRE WIRE HI
MELINDA'S MAN MAN HI NEWMAN.
NEWMAN HI THE TROUBLE THE
TROUBLE HI IN TEN HI STERN WHY
CASKEY. RIGHT A MAN I. I WILL
HOLD THE ROLE OPEN FOR A CINDER
ACCOUNTS KEY AND SENATOR
STORMED OUT ON WE'LL MOVE TO
THE NEXT BILL WHICH IS EIGHTY
ONE FORTY TWO AND THAT IS THE-
PRIVILEGES BARGAINING UNITS FOR
OUR STATE EMPLOYEE UNITS AS
SENATOR LAYERED MOVED AHEAD
CONSULTING YOU MAY CALL THE
ROLL. EIGHTY ONE FORTY TWO THE
MOTIONS TO PASS SENATORS
SKINNER HI SKINNER HI NIELSEN.
COPYRIGHT HI COPYRIGHT I
CORTESE TODAY THE I. DALI. OKAY
DOLLY NO THE RAZA. RUSSELL HI
ADMIN SEGMENT I GROW. GROVE HI
COM LONGER. COM LARGER I
LAYERED. HI MCGUIRE ACQUIRE HI
MELINDA'S MAN MAN I KNOW MAN
NEWMAN HI THE TROUBLE I HAVE
TROUBLE HI IN PENN HI STERN
WHAT COUNTY WHAT COUNTY HI.
NIELSEN HI. ALRIGHT WE'LL HOLD
THAT ROLE OPEN I THINK WE STILL
HAVE ONE ABSENT MEMBER AND WE
WILL NOW GO TO THE NEXT BILL
WHICH IS EIGHTY ONE FORTY SIX
THAT'S THE PUBLIC SAFETY
FACILITIES. STEP INSIDE CONTROL
THE ROLE. EIGHTY ONE FORTY SIX
THE MOTION IS TO PASS SENATORS
SKINNER R. SKINNER HI NELSON.
SCOTT NELSON- YES AND NO CAIRO
COVER GIRL HI COURTESY CORTESE
HI DOLLY ALI NO TORONTO.
TORONTO HI AIKMAN HEY MAN HI
THE GROWTH ROSA NOVO COM AUGER.
COM LOGGER HI THERE. LAYERED
I'M ACQUIRE. HI MELINDA IS MAN
MAN HI NEWMAN NEWMAN HI-
TROUBLE. THE TROUBLE NO IN. TEN
HI STERN BY CAL SKI LIKE WHAT
COUNTS HI BIR WILL AGAIN HOLD
THE ROLE OPEN AND WILL NOW GO
TO FIVE FIVE WHICH IS EIGHTY
ONE FORTY SEVEN AND THAT IS THE
SUPPLEMENTAL- AUGMENTATION FED
BUDGET ACT OF TWENTY TWENTY-
JUST MOVED BY SENATOR LAYERED
MR STEPPING CHARLIE CAN CALL
THE ROLL. AB ONE FORTY SEVEN
THE MOTION IS TO PASS SENATORS
SKINNER SKINNER HI MILSON NO.
YES AND NO COPYRIGHT. COPYRIGHT
I CORTESE COULD THE I. DALI
DOLLY HI THERE ALTHOUGH BROTHER
HI ADNAN. A MAN I GROWTH GROVE
I'D COME LONGER. COME LONGER
I'D LAYERED HI THERE I'M
ACQUIRE. HI WIRE I MELINDA'S.
MAN MAN HI NEWMAN NEWMAN I'LL
TELL ABOUT. TROUBLE HI IN. HI
STERN WHITE COUNTY HI WHITE
COUNTY HI FOR. NIELSEN NODE I.
RIGHT WE'LL HOLD THAT RULE OPEN
AND WILL NOW GO TO. EIGHTY ONE
FIFTY TWO THE ELECTIONS BILL
AND MOVED BY SENATOR Y. CASKEY.
FIRST STEP MR SEVEN CHARGING
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. EIGHTY
ONE FIFTY TWO THE MOTION IS TO
PASS SENATORS SCANNER HI
SCANNER I KNOW SEN. YES AND NO
COPYRIGHT COPYRIGHT HI CORTESE.
HI DOLLY. ALI NO THE RAZA.
TORONTO HI ADNAN. GROWTH GROVE
NO COMMA- COM LARGER HI LAYERED
LAYERED HI MCGUIRE. BLEIER I'M
MELINDA'S. MAN MAN I KNOW MAN.
NEWMAN HI A TROUBLE. TROUBLED
NO PEN PEN HI STERN HI SIR I
WORK OUT OKAY. GOSTEI. WERE
THERE ANY. ABSENT MEMBERS OR
NOT. EGGMAN. NO RIGHT THAT
ROLE- WE'LL CLOSE THE ROLE ON
THAT IT IS- TWELVE FOR. NOW WE
WILL GO TO- THE ITEM. FIVE
SEVEN EIGHTY ONE FIFTY EIGHT.
ON THE HAZARDOUS WASTE- MOTION
BY SENATOR Y. CASKEY DO PASS
AND- GO AHEAD SENATOR PARDON MR
STEPHAN CHUCKLED THE ROLE.
EIGHTY ONE FIFTY EIGHT THE
MOTION TO PASS SENATORS
SKINNER. SKINNER ARE YOU'LL
SEND. US A NOTE COPYRIGHT.
COPYRIGHT HI COURTESY COURTESY
HI DOLLY- DOLLY NO THE ROSWELL.
BROTHER HI ADNAN. HI ADNAN HIGH
GROWTH. COM BLOGGER TOM LOGGER
HI LAYERED. I'M A GLIDER BLEIER
I'M LINDA IS MAN MAN HI NEWMAN.
NEWMAN HI- TROUBLE NO TROUBLE
NO PEN IN HI STERN EASTERN I Y.
CASKEY RECOUNTS SKI HI. THAT
HAS EVERYONE RECORDED CORRECT.
RIGHT THEN THE VOTE THERE IS A
TWELVE. WHAT TO DO YOU HAVE
THIRTEEN. MR STEPHENSON. IF YOU
READ HOW MANY. YES. THE
THIRTEEN YES THREE NO AND-
WE'LL CLOSE THAT BILL. EIGHTY
ONE FIFTY EIGHT NOW FIND. SCUSE
ME. WE WILL GO TO- TRY TO MATE
AB ONE FIFTY NINE. THE M. O. U.
FOR STATE BARGAINING UNIT SIX
DO WE HAVE A MOTION. THE SEVEN
MOVED BY SENATOR DOLLY. MR
STUFF AND SHOW YOU PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL EIGHTY ONE FIFTY NINE
THE MOTION IS TO PASS SENATORS
SCANNER I CAN- HI. NIELSEN
NELSON HI COPYRIGHT COPYRIGHT
HI POTENTIALLY. CORTESE HI
DOLLY ALI HAIDER RAZA. RATHER
HI ADNAN. BRO. COM LOGGER I
COME LONGER HI LAYERED. LEHRER
I'M ACQUIRE WIRE HI LINDA THIS
MAN MAN HI NEWMAN. NEWMAN HI-
TROUBLE. TO ABOUT HI YEAH HI HI
STERN. DURING HI WHAT COUNTS BE
BY CAL SKI HI. GROVE HI. RIGHT
THE BILL IS OUT THE VOTE WAS
SIXTEEN. FIVE OKAY SO. THAT
HANDLES THE VOTING PORTION WE
WILL NOW GO TO OUR INFORMATION
ITEM. AND. POLICIES WE HAVE TO
GO BACK TO THE ONES I CALL. GET
MY MEMORY BACK OKAY SO LET'S
QUICKLY RETURNED TO THE BILLS
THAT WERE ON CALL EIGHTY ONE
TWENTY NINE THAT IS THE- BUDGET
BILL JUNIOR PLEASE CALL THE
OFFICE AND MEMBERS. EVERYONE
TWENTY NINE THE MOTION IS TO
PASS SENATORS STERN HI TURN HI
WHAT COUNTY. THE CASKET HI. THE
THEN MR SEPARATES OTHER BILLS
OUT. HE THAT BILL AB ONE TWENTY
NINE IST OUT THIRTEEN ONE NOW
LET'S GO TO THE SECOND. EIGHTY
ONE THIRTY NINE PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. EIGHTY ONE
THIRTY NINE THE MOTION IS TO
PASS SENATORS STERN. SENATOR
STERN ARE YOU VOTING ON EIGHTY
ONE THIRTY NINE. HI I Y. CASKEY
BY CAL SKI HI. FLORIDA BILL IS
OUT IT'S- FOURTEEN THREE. OKAY
WILL GO. TO EIGHTY ONE FORTY
TWO WOULD YOU PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. EIGHTY ONE
FORTY TWO THE MOTION WAS TO
PASS SENATOR STERN. I EARN HI.
RIGHT THE BILLS OUT SIXTEEN
ONE- WE WILL NOW GO TO AB ONE
FORTY SIX PLEASE CALL THE OB TO
MEMBERS. AB ONE FORTY SIX THE
MOTION IS TO PASS SENATOR STERN.
HI KAREN HI. RIGHT THE BILLS
OUT. THIRTEEN FOR- WILL NOW GO
TO EIGHTY ONE FORTY SEVEN.
WOULD YOU PLEASE CALL THE
OFFICE AND MEMBERS. EIGHTY ONE
FORTY SEVEN THE MOTION TO PASS
SENATOR STERN HI KAREN HI.
RIGHT THE BILLS OUT SEVENTEEN
ONE MY CORRECT THERE. SEVENTEEN
ZERO OKAY CORRECT SOMEBODY TO
CHANGE STRAIGHT RIGHT THAT
BILLS OUT. SEVENTEEN ZERO
THIRTY ONE FORTY SEVEN WILL NOW
GO TO EIGHTY ONE FIFTY TWO THAT
WAS DONE THAT HAD EVERYONE ALL
THE OTHER BILLS SAID EVERYONE
OKAY- SENATOR RICHMOND I'M
SORRY WAS THAT ROLE CLOSED.
THEY WERE CLOSER ALIGNMENT ON
ONE FIFTY TWO- YES. THANK YOU
OKAY- MADAM CHAIR WOULD IT BE
IN ORDER FOR ME TO CHANGE MY
VOTE FOR NOT VOTING TO ACT. THE
VACATION OR WHATEVER HOLD ON.
THAT'S OKAY. THAT'S OKAY. JUST
GETTING A QUICK CLARIFICATION
ON THAT.
ALL RIGHT WE'RE JUST
GOING TO PROCEED TO THE
INFORMATIONAL BECAUSE OBVIOUSLY
EVERYONE CAN RECORD VOTES ON
THE FLOOR WHEN WE TAKE THE SAP-
LATER. TODAY SO NOW WE HAVE THE
INFORMATIONAL ITEM. AND I WILL
TURN TO SENATOR CAFIERO TO
PRESENT THIS IS ON D. E.
FICTION RELIEF AND- RENTAL
ASSISTANCE GO AHEAD SENATOR
KABIR. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR I
RISE TODAY TO SPEAK IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF STATE ACTION TO
EXTEND THE EVICTION MORATORIUM
AND UTILIZE FEDERAL FUNDS TO
PROVIDE 1100% PAY DOWN OF PAST
DUE RENT. THIS IS A VERY
IMPORTANT NEXT STEPS TO ENSURE
THAT VULNERABLE CALIFORNIA
RENTERS ARE PROTECTED FROM THE
DICTION AND THAT LANDLORDS ARE
MADE WHOLE I'D LIKE TO THINK
LEADERSHIP IN BOTH HOUSES THE
ADMINISTRATION AND ALL OF THE
STAFF THAT HAVE REALLY WORKED
VERY VERY HARD. TO SUPPORT THIS
CRITICAL ISSUE. EVERYONE IN
THIS ROOM KNOWS ALL TOO WELL
THE STRUGGLE FAMILIES IN OUR
DISTRICT FACE SHORTLY AFTER THE
ONSET OF THE PANDEMIC IN MARCH
OF LAST YEAR. WHEN THE GOVERNOR
DECLARED A STATE OF EMERGENCY
AND SHELTER IN PLACE ORDERS ONE
OF MY FIRST CONCERNS WITH HOW
PEOPLE IN MY COMMUNITY. WHO
WERE PUT OUT OF WORK WOULD PAY
THEIR RENT. PUT FOOD ON THEIR
TABLES OR KEEP THEIR POWER AND
WATER ON. DESPITE ITS MANY
FLAWS MANY WERE FORTUNATE TO
HAVE SOME OF THEIR INCOME
SUPPLEMENTED BY THE
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE BUT
UNFORTUNATELY CALIFORNIA'S LONG
STANDING HOUSING CRISIS IN
EXTREME RENT PRICES MEANT THAT
MANY WERE LEFT UNABLE TO PAY
THE RENT. IN RESPONSE THE STATE
STEPPED IN AND PASSED THE FIRST
EVICTION MORATORIUM AB THIRTY
EIGHTY EIGHT. FOLLOWED BY SB
NINETY ONE WHICH PROVIDED THE
FIRST ROUND OF FUNDING TO
RENTERS MOST IN NEED AN
EXTENDED THE MORATORIUM. NOW
WITH VACCINES PROVIDING
IMPORTANT IMMUNITY WE FINALLY
SEE THE LIGHT AT THE END OF THE
TUNNEL. MANY SIGNIFICANT COVE
AND SAFETY PRO PROTOCOLS HAVE
BEEN LIFTED MORE PEOPLE ARE
BACK TO WORK IN THE ECONOMY IS
SLOWLY RECOVERING. DESPITE THIS
GOOD NEWS WE STILL HAVE WORK TO
DO. THE NEXT LOGICAL STEP TO
KEEP TENANTS HOUSED AND HELP
LANDLORDS RECOVER FROM LOST
RENT IS TO EXTEND THE EVICTION
MORATORIUM. FOR A SHORT TIME IN
INSURE 1100% OF THE RENT CAN BE
PAID TO LANDLORDS FOR
QUALIFYING RENTERS. IN ADDITION
TO REVAMPING THE CURRENT CASH
ASSISTANCE PROGRAM OFFERED
THROUGH SB NINETY ONE WE MUST
ALSO ENSURE THE NEXT STEP
PROVIDES A LONG TERM SOLUTION.
SHOULD A LANDLORD DESIRE TO
PRESERVE THE PURSUIT UNLAWFUL
DETAINER DETAINER ACTION. AFTER
THE MORATORIUM ENDS THERE MUST
BE A PROCESS IN PLACE TO ENSURE
BOTH THE LANDLORD. AND THE
TENANT DID THEIR BEST TO
PARTICIPATE IN THE CURRENT
RENTAL ASSISTANCE PROGRAMS.
FOURTEEN MONTHS HAVE PASSED
SINCE THE GOVERNOR DECLARED A
STATE OF EMERGENCY. MANY
RESIDENTS LOST FAMILY MEMBERS
AND LOVED ONES BECAUSE OF THIS
VIRUS. MANY MORE WERE LAID OFF
PERCENT HOME INDEFINITELY
THROUGH NO FAULT OF THEIR OWN
IN PARTICULAR IN COMMUNITIES OF
COLOR WHO DISPROPORTIONATELY
WORK IN THE SERVICE INDUSTRY
THAT FELT THE IMPACT OF THE
CORONA VIRUS VIRUS THE HARDEST.
DESPITE THE NECESSARY HARDSHIP
A STATE WIDE SHUTDOWN BECAUSE
CALIFORNIA HAS COME BACK STRONG
IF NOT STRONGER THAN BEFORE-
UNEMPLOYMENT IS NOW THE LOWEST
IT'S BEEN SINCE THE PANDEMIC
YEAH IT'S GETTING CLOSER TO PRE
PANDEMIC LEVELS EVERY MONTH AND
OUR STATE REVENUES ARE HIGHER
THAN ANYONE COULD HAVE
PROJECTED. I'M CONFIDENT THAT
THE LEGISLATURE CAN PASS A
MEASURE A MEASURED APPROACH
THAT PROTECTS VULNERABLE
TENANTS HELPS LANDLORDS RECOVER
FROM TREMENDOUS LOSSES AND WILL
SERVE AS A SAFETY NET TO ENSURE
THAT TENANTS DO NOT JOIN THE
RANKS OF THE HOMELESS. I LOOK
FORWARD THIS MORNING TO HEARING
FROM AMY WILSON WHO IS THE
DEPUTY DEPUTY SECRETARY OF
LEGISLATION WITH BUSINESS
CONSUMER SERVICES AND HOUSING
AGENCY JEFFREY ROSS DEPUTY
DIRECTOR OF THE DIVISION OF
FINANCIAL ASSISTANCE. WITH THE
HOUSING AND COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT AGENCY AND LAND
BOND **** LIEBERT DEPUTY
SECRETARY OF HOUSING WITH
BUSINESS CONSUMER SERVICES AND
HOUSING AGENCY. THEIR EXPERTISE
AND INSIGHT ON THIS ISSUE IS
CRITICAL TO FURTHER DISCUSSION
ON THIS ISSUE TODAY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SENATOR
KIRBY EURO NOW. WE WILL HEAR
FROM THE STAFF WE'RE GOING TO
ADD TO THIS THE- HEAD. HE COULD.
GOOD MONING TAKE YOUR NAME AND
TITLE AND THEN FOR SEAT SURE
GOOD MORNING- MY NAME IS
JEANNIE WILSON- THAT DEPUTY
SECRETARY FOR LEGISLATION AND
THE BUSINESS CONSUMER SERVICES
AND HOUSING AGENCY- THANK YOU
SENATOR CAFIERO MORNING MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS- I'M HERE
TOGETHER WITH MY COLLEAGUE AND
LYNN MONOCOQUE LEVERAGE- TO
EXPRESS THE ADMINISTRATION'S
WHOLEHEARTED SUPPORT FOR EIGHTY
EIGHT THIRTY TWO AND TO RESPOND
TO ANY QUESTIONS THAT YOU MAY
HAVE- AS THE SENATOR EXPLAINED-
EIGHTY EIGHT THIRTY TWO MAKES A
NUMBER OF CHANGES- TO THE-
EXISTING STATE ELECTION
PROTECTIONS AS WELL AS. TO THE
RENTAL ASSISTANCE PROGRAM- I
WOULD LIKE TO FOCUS MY
COMMENTS. ON ONE PARTICULAR
ITEM. IN THE BILL- THE GOVERNOR
INCLUDED IN HIS NAME REVISION
PROJECT. THE REQUEST SHOULD BE
QUICK TO RAISE THE COMPENSATION
LEVELS. IN THE STATE RENTAL
ASSISTANCE PROGRAM TO PAY 1100%
OF AN ELIGIBLE HOUSEHOLDS.
RELATED RENTAL DEBT PERSPECTIVE
RENTS AND UTILITIES. THE
ADMINISTRATION BELIEVES THIS
INCREASE IN PAYMENT LEVELS IS
CRITICAL ANDNECESSARY TO GET
MUCH NEEDED FEDERAL RENTAL
ASSISTANCE DOLLARS OUT THE DOOR
TO STABILIZE. TENANTS AND THEIR
LANDLORDS AND TO SUPPORT AN
EQUITABLE ECONOMIC TRANSITION
TO THE PAST AND IN THE STATE
RENTAL ASSISTANCE PROGRAM IS
NOW FULLY THREE MONTHS INTO
IMPLEMENTATION. IT BEGAN
ACCEPTING APPLICATIONS ON MARCH
FIFTEENTH STARTED ISSUING
PAYMENTS IN MID APRIL. OVER THE
LAST TWO MONTHS OF MAKING
PAYMENTS WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO
STOP THE RATE INCREASE THE
AMOUNT OF ASSISTANCE ISSUED AND
THE NUMBER OF HOUSEHOLDS THERE.
CHANGING PAINT IN THE PAYMENT
LEVELS IN EIGHTY EIGHT THIRTY
TWO IS CRITICAL TO OUR ABILITY
TO CONTINUE TO SWIFTLY DELIVER
THESE FUNDS TO CALIFORNIA
TENANTS AND LANDLORDS. I HAD TO
DO EVERYTHING THEY CAN TO MAKE
IT INTO. THE REDDIT GETTING
RENTAL DEBT AND SHORT TERM. AND
PROVIDING ONGOING SUPPORT TO
LOW INCOME HOUSEHOLDS THAT
CONTINUE TO RECOVER FROM THE
IMPACTS OF THE PANDEMIC IS THE
MISSION OF THIS PROGRAM.
FOLLOWING THE DOLLARS MORE
QUICKLY ALSO ENABLES THE STATE
TO STAY ON PACE TO MEET OUR
SPENDING REQUIREMENTS UNDER THE
FEDERAL LAW. DOING SO PUTS THE
STATE IN A POSITION TO
POTENTIALLY RECEIVE MORE
DOLLARS FROM BRANCHES ACROSS
THE NATION THAT HAVE UNUSED
FUND FUNDS AND NOT AS THE G. AS
CALIFORNIA. BRIEFLY I WILL NOTE
THAT EIGHTY EIGHT THIRTY TWO
INCLUDES OTHER ELEMENTS THAT
WILL SUPPORT PROGRAM
PARTICIPATION. FIRST THE
EXTENSION OF THE CURRENT
EVICTION PROTECTIONS AFTER
SEPTEMBER THIRTIETH WILL KEEP
CALIFORNIANS HOUSE AND PROVIDE
THE STATE AND LOCAL PROGRAMS
ADDITIONAL TIME TO DEPLOY THE
RENTAL ASSISTANCE RESOURCE-
ACCORDINGLY THE EXTENDED
PROTECTION. ALSO INCLUDES A
REVISED NOTICE THAT POINTS TEN
INTO OUR CALL CENTER AND- HELP
LINE TO THE STATE WEBSITE TO
DIRECT THEM ON HOW AND WHERE TO
APPLY FOR AT LEAST- SECOND
FOLLOWING THE END OF THE
PROTECTION EIGHTY EIGHT THIRTY
TWO ESTABLISHES A TEMPORARY
COURT PROCESS STARTING OCTOBER
ONE. THIS COURT PROCESS WILL BE
IN EFFECT UNTIL MARCH TWENTY
TWENTY TWO AND IT PROVIDES A
TAPERING OFF TO ENSURE
HOUSEHOLDS IN NEED OF
ASSISTANCE REMAIN PROTECTED S.
FUNDS CONTINUE TO BE ALLOCATED
ACROSS STATE. IN CLOSING THIS
DATA RENTAL ASSISTANCE PROGRAM
IS POISED AND READY TO TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF THE OPPORTUNITY
PROVIDED BY EIGHTY EIGHT THREE
TWO WE STRONGLY SUPPORT THE
LEGISLATION AND THANK THE
AUTHORS LEGISLATURE FOR
ADVANCING IT. HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS THANK YOU. THANK
YOU WAS THERE ANOTHER.
DEPARTMENTAL REP THAT WAS GOING
TO PRESENTERS THAT. OKAY LET ME
SEE IF THERE'S- ANY OTHER END
SORRY ANY COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS
MY COLLEAGUES SENATOR WHITE
HOUSE SKI. THANK YOU MANAGER I
HAVE A QUESTION. REGARDING THE
EMERGENCY THE PROGRAMMER SOME
CHANGES HI ALL I HAVE IN FRONT
OF ME IS OF A BULLET POINT BUT
IT'S WHERE THE TENANT NO LONGER
OCCUPIES THE UNIT. BUT STILL-
RULES POSTER READ WE'RE WITH
THE WE'RE WITH THE AUTHORIZED
PAYMENTS GO WOULD IT GO TO THE
LANDLORD DIRECTLY ON THE
ARREARS OR DOES IT GO TO THE
TENANT EVEN THOUGH THE TENANTS
NOT THERE. HOW WILL THAT WORK.
I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER THAT
QUESTION SENATOR. I WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT THE EVERYONE CAN
HEAR ME BECAUSE I'M NOT
PICTURED AT RIGHT NOW- SITTING
THAT YOU CAN HEAR- SO THE- THE
BILL DOES AUTHORIZE. NON
OCCUPANCY SITUATIONS WHERE THE-
TENANT IS NO LONGER THEY HAVE
LIKE SELF VACATED- THEY HAVE
MOVED OUT BUT THE- RENTAL
ARREARS WE WANTED TO MAKE SURE
THAT. THOSE SITUATIONS WERE
STILL ELIGIBLE THE- FUNDING IF
THEY ARE WE WERE ABLE TO
CONNECT WITH THE LANDLORD OF
THE FUNDING WILL GO DIRECTLY TO
THE LANDLORD- AS IT DOES- IN
THAT SITUATION IN OCCUPANCY
SITUATIONS- IF WE ARE UNABLE TO
HAVE. LANDLORD RESPONSE I'M IN
THAT SITUATION- THE TENANT
DOES- ATTEST UNDER PENALTY OF
PERJURY THAT THE FUNDS ARE TO
BE USED FOR THE STATED PURPOSE
OF PAYING THE RENTAL ARREARS
AND- THEY RECEIVE EITHER YOU
KNOW THE CHECK OR THE TRANSFER
AND AGAIN IT'S ALL- STATED
CLEARLY ON THE PAYMENT WHAT
IT'S FOR AND THEN- THE BILL
DOES ALSO REQUIRE THAT. THAT
PAYMENT TO THE TENANT WAS THEN
CONVEYED TO THE LANDLORD
WITHIN. FIFTEEN DAYS. AND IF IT
IS NOT THE LAN IS A TO FIX- A.
PENALTY FEE ASSOCIATED WITH IT.
IF I MAY GOING ON AND WITH
REGARD TO THE TERM OF THE LEASE
IF THE TENANT. VOLUNTARILY LEFT
TWO MONTHS BEFORE THE TERM OF
THE LEASE WAS WAS- EXPIRED DOES
THAT- THIS PROGRAM ALLOW FOR
THAT. A REQUEST FOR THE PAYMENT
OF THOSE TWO MONTHS WHEN IT
WOULD BE VACANT UNDER THE-
UNDER THE CONTRACT. CAN I
TRANSFER THAT QUESTION ALREADY
YOU CAN. YEAH GOOD AFTERNOON
I'M LIVE ON COOK LEADER DEPUTY
SECRETARY OF HOUSING AT THE
TEMPERATURE OF THE HOUSING
AGENCY I THANK YOU FOR THAT
QUESTION IN THAT CASE NO
BECAUSE THE- THE WAY THAT THE
PROGRAM IS SET UP WITH UNDER
UNDER THE FEDERAL GUIDELINES
THAT IT'S LINKED TO THE AND
THAT THE TENANT AND THE TENANT
TIME IN IN INDIA THE APARTMENT
OR THAT THE UNIT. OF THE TENANT
HOUSE AT THE TIME THE TENANT
ADVOCATED THAT WOULD BE THE END
POINT THAT WE WOULD BE ABLE TO
COMPLICATE THAT LANDMARK FOR
THE TIME THAT. THE TENANT WAS
NOT MAKING A PAYMENT. SENATOR
Y. CASKEY SAID ANSWER. I JUST
WOULDN'T- NOTE THAT THE IT'S A
FEDERAL GUIDELINES WE HAVE TO
FILE FEDERAL GUIDELINES BUT BUT
THAT WOULD IF THE JUDGE WAS
SITTING IN AN UNLAWFUL DETAINER
ACTION AND WOULD SAY THAT
BECAUSE I'M CONTRACTUALLY THAT
THAT TENANT ALTHOUGH THEY
VOLUNTARILY LEFT TO TRY TO YOU
KNOW GO ON TO GREENER PASTURES
THEY WOULD BE LIABLE UNDER THE
TERMS OF THE CONTRACT FOR TWO.
FOR TWO MONTHS SO THAT WILL BE.
WE'LL OBVIOUSLY THE BACKSTOP
PROCESS WITH AGE. THAT THAT SET
UP IN THE BILL WILL PROVIDE US
WITH THAT INFORMATION TELL ME
BUT I CAN SEE A COUPLE OF
PEOPLE FALLING INTO THAT. THAT
CATEGORY BECAUSE THEY DECIDED
THEY JUST LEFT WITH WERE ON
THIS PROGRAM IT EVEN BETTER FOR
THEM JUST TO STAY PUT TILL THE
END OF THE TERM SO. THANK THANK
YOU SENATOR DRAWS OF. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR IF- BUT I CAN GET
SOME CLARITY- BECAUSE THERE'S
BEEN A MIX EITHER IN ACTUAL
FUNDING OR IN TERMS OF RIGHTS
AND PROTECTIONS- THE RELIEF
AVAILABLE FOR RENT BUT ALSO
WHAT'S AVAILABLE AND HOW. DO
YOU GET ACCESS TO UTILITY DEBT
RELIEF I'VE SEEN THE SOMETIMES
IN THE SAME SENTENCE SOMETIMES
AS A SEPARATE BUT COULD YOU-
CLARIFY THAT. I'M INTERESTED I
WOULD BE HAPPY TO TAKE THAT
QUESTION I'M STILL RENTING
UTILITIES AND CAN BE CAPTURED
IN IN TWO DIFFERENT WAYS. THE
FIRST ONE NAME- WHEN AFRICANS
AT COMPLETE THAT AND
APPLICATION THEY'RE REQUESTED
TO PUT IN ALL THEIR INFORMATION
ABOUT THEIR RENT AND UTILITY
AND- BEAT THEIR REQUEST TO PUT
IN THE INFORMATION IF THEY PAY
THEIR UTILITIES AS PART OF
THEIR BUNDLED FRENCH TOAST THEY
EXAMINE CLUES THAT INCLUDED IN
THE MONTHLY COST TO THEIR
LANDLORD. OR AND OR IF THEY PAY
THEIR UTILITIES. DIRECTLY TO
UTILITY PROVIDER. IF THE RENT
IF THE UTILITIES ARE BUNDLED IN
THE RENT. THEN THAT PAYMENT IS
PAID DIRECTLY TO THE LANDLORD
AT THE TIME THAT THE TENANT
PAYMENT IS PROCESSED. IF THE
UTILITIES ARE SEPARATED AND THE
PAYMENTS ARE GOING TO BE-
UTILITY PROVIDER. WINDOWS ARE-
CARVED OUT AND THEN WE WORK
THROUGH OUR PRIORITIZATION
SYSTEM FOR FIRST THROUGH THE
PROGRAM WE PAINT RENTAL ARREARS
AND RENTAL PERSPECTIVE AND THEN
UTILITY PAYMENTS. THAT THOSE
WOULD BE CAPTURED WHEN THE
APPLICANT POINT AN APPLICATION
AND THEN PROPPED UP AS WE. GO
THROUGH THE PRIORITIZATION
WITHIN THE PROGRAM. YEAH JUST A
FOLLOW UP TEST I JUST WANNA
MAKE SURE THAT- WERE NOT. THAT
WE CAN GET THAT THE RESIDENTS
CAN GET THAT SUPPORT. BY GOING
TO ONE PLACE AND NOT WORRYING
ABOUT. THE DIFFERENT PLACES
BECAUSE IT MIGHT BE JUST THE
UTILITY IT MIGHT BE CONNECTED.
IF THEY DON'T KNOW ALL OF THE
DETAILS OF THAT CAN THEY JUST
GO TO ONE PLACE AND THAT WOULD
BE PUT ALL THAT INFORMATION.
AND SUPPORT WOULD BE PROVIDED.
YES SENATOR THAT THAT IS THAT
IS CORRECT WHEN THEY GO INTO
THE APPLICATION PORTAL AND
THEY'LL BE WALK THROUGH ALL OF
THAT BACK. AND WITH OUR RECENT
APPLICATION UPDATE AND WE HAVE
WORKED TO STREAMLINE THAT
PROCESS AND MAKE IT A MUCH
CLEARER SO THAT THEY CAN SEE
AND ULTIMATELY A CHECKLIST ON
WITHIN THE APPLICATION OF ALL
OF THE DIFFERENT ELEMENTS THAT
THEY ARE ELIGIBLE FOR. AND THEN
WORK THROUGH THE PROCESS YOUR
PLAN FOR THE FUN. AND WE'VE
ALSO DONE QUITE A BIT OF
TRAINING WITH OUR LOCAL NETWORK
PARTNERS OUR CALL CENTER CENTER
KEEP MANAGEMENT. TO HELP
APPLICANTS- UNDERSTAND WHAT
THEY ARE ELIGIBLE FOR AND MAKE.
SURE THE BABY- REQUEST ALL OF
THEM. THANK YOU. SENATOR OCHO
BOOK. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
JUST A QUICK QUESTION AS FAR AS
THE- THE TIME IT TAKES TO
ACTUALLY DO THE DISBURSEMENT OF
THE FUNDS- FOR THE LANDLORDS OR
FOR THE FOR THE TENANTS WHAT.
ARE WE LOOKING AT THIS TIME.
STAFF DO YOU HAVE AN ANSWER I'M
SORRY. WHEN WE TAKE THAT
QUESTION OR YES. I'M SORRY I'M
SORRY COULD YOU REPEAT THE
QUESTION. ABSOLUTELY BUT MY
QUESTION HAS TO DO WITH THE
TIME PERIOD IN WHICH IS IT YOU
FOLKS ARE REIMBURSING ALRIGHT
THEY REIMBURSEMENT FUNDS ARE
BEING ALLOCATED TOWARDS OUR
COOKING GRANTED TO THE EITHER
EITHER THE TENANT OR THE
LANDLORD. THANK YOU FOR READING
AND- SO THE TIME FRAME VERY A
LITTLE BIT DEPENDING ON THE
PRIORITIZATION OF THE TENANT.
AND SO IT'S APPLICATION COMES
INTO OUR PRODUCTS AND REUSING
NEEDS EXISTING STATE LAW TO
PRIORITIZE BASED OFF OF THEIR
AREA MEDIAN INCOME FIRST AND
THEY'RE AND- THEY'RE AT IT
RIGHT. TO PUT THEIR ATTENTION
BELOW 50% AM I OR AT HIGH RISK
OF INFECTION- SECONDLY IF THERE
WITH AN AGE RESTRICTION THAT IS
HIGHER AND HIGHER
DISPROPORTIONATE IMPACT FROM
KOBE. AND THEN THIRD ANY- ANY
ELIGIBLE TENANTS THAT ANYBODY
WHO IS UNDER EIGHTY PERCENT.
MEDIAN INCOME FOR THE STATE- SO
ESSENTIALLY WHEN SOMEBODY SMITH
AN APPLICATION- ON OUR CASE
MANAGEMENT TEAM WILL THEN DRAW
DOWN FROM THAT APPLICATION
POOL- BASED OFF OF THE
PRIORITIZATION. ANSWER
SOMEBODY'S IN A PRIORITY ONE OR
PRIORITY QUEUE THEN THEY CAN BE
QUITE QUICKLY IF THEIR PRIORITY
THREE THEN THE TIME FRAME WILL
TAKE. A LITTLE BIT LONGER- WHAT.
WHAT WE HAVE BEEN WORKING OUT
FOR LAST MONTH TO IS REALLY.
THE APPLE- SO THAT IT IS.
EASIER AND FASTER AN APPLICANT
TO BE ABLE TO- COMPLETE
INFORMATION ON BUT THAT ALSO SO
THAT OUR CASE MANAGERS ABLE TO
REVIEW THE APPLICATIONS AND THE
ACTUAL PROCESS. AND ONCE WE GET
THROUGH THE CURRENT BACKLOG
ARTICLE WOULD YOU BE ABLE TO
MAKE THAT PROCESS. I'M JUST A
COUPLE OF WEEKS. FROM
SUBMISSION TO PAYMENT. SIR BOTH
GO AHEAD MADAM CHAIR. THANK
YOU. SO JUST FOR CLARIFICATION
PURPOSES SO WHAT IS THE CURRENT
TIME FRAME RIGHT NOW AS FAR AS
A REIMBURSEMENT GOES AND I KNOW
YOU ARE MOVING FORWARD YOU
WOULD LIKE TO BE WITHIN A
COUPLE OF WEEKS WHAT IS THE
CURRENT- TIME FRAME THAT WE'RE
LOOKING AT REIMBURSEMENT. THANK
YOU IT DOES VERY DEPENDING ON
ON THE APPLICATION WE HAVE
PROPER COMMENT QUICKLY A FEW
WEEKS. AND THEN OTHERS HAVE
TAKEN LONGER AND WE'RE CALLING
THE FEATURED APPLICATION. ON
BECAUSE THEY AND THEY DO HAVE
THAT THERE IN THE LONGER
PRIORITIZATION- IN THAT CASE WE
DO HAVE APPLICATIONS THAT WERE
SUBMITTED- AT THE BEGINNING OF
THAT PROCESS THAT ARE STILL
WAITING UNTIL WE GET INTO THAT.
THEIR THEIR PRIOR EDUCATION. IF
I IF I MIGHT JUST ADD. TO THAT-
ALSO SENATOR- THERE ARE THERE
ARE SOME VARYING TIME FRAMES
ALSO BASED ON. A WHAT PART OF
THE STATE BECAUSE THERE ARE
DIFFERENT. PROGRAMS WHAT LATEST
DESCRIBING STATES- STATES
PROGRAM- WHICH SERVES ALL
COMMUNITIES ALL JURISDICTIONS
THAT WERE. COUNTIES THAT WERE
UNDER TWO HUNDRED THOUSAND
POPULATION SIZE AND ANY ABOVE
TWO HUNDRED THOUSAND OPTED INTO
OUR PROGRAM. THERE ARE SOME
PROGRAMS HOWEVER THAT ELECTED
TO RUN THEIR OWN PROGRAMS
LOCALLY LARGER JURISDICTIONS
AND- THEY HAVE. YOU KNOW
THEY'RE PROCESSING
ADMINISTERING THEIR OWN
PROGRAMS LOCALLY AND- SO THE
TIME FRAMES WHEN SPEAKING TO
ARE THE ONES THAT ARE UNDER OUR
CONTROL. AT THE STATE HERE. ARE
H. C. D. NH PROGRAM. RIGHT
BEFORE WE MOVE ON TO PUBLIC
COMMENT I HAVE A QUESTION- THE
FIRST COMMENT I AM VERY PLEASED
THAT THIS IS NOT GOING TO
COVER. A 100% OF RENT FOR THOSE
PEOPLE WHO NEED THAT AND
ADDITIONALLY IT IS PERSPECTIVE
SO THAT IT'S NOT ONLY BASED ON
THE FACT THAT YOU HAD NOT PAID
YOUR RENT BECAUSE OBVIOUSLY
THERE ARE MANY PEOPLE. WHO
BECAUSE OF THE FEAR. OF LOSING
A ROOF OVER THEIR HEADS HAVE.
BEEN PAYING THEIR RENT HOWEVER
THEY MAY BE IN GREAT DEBT OR
OTHERWISE A REALLY- PUT
THEMSELVES IN A VERY DIFFICULT
POSITION. IN ORDER TO MEET
THAT. AND COULD BE IN
CIRCUMSTANCES WHERE THEY'RE
FACING OTHER. INTERESTING
CONSEQUENCES FOR NON PAYMENT OF
OTHER THINGS SO IF THEY- AND
PROSPECTIVELY CAN GET SOME RENT
RELIEF THEY MAY BE ABLE TO GET
THEMSELVES OUT OF THE
CIRCUMSTANCE FOR OTHER DEBTS-
THE QUESTION I HAVE THOUGH IS.
ON THE INCOME QUALIFICATIONS
SOME OF OUR INCOME
QUALIFICATION PROGRAMS FACTOR
UNEMPLOYMENT INCOME SOME DO
NOT. DOES THIS PROGRAM A FACTOR
ONCE UNEMPLOYMENT INCOME. THANK
YOU FOR THE QUESTION SENATOR
AND I BELIEVE IT DOES NOT. SO
YOU'RE LOOKING AT. KATE
MIDDLETON GO AHEAD KEEP GOING.
YES WE'RE WE'RE LOOKING AT-
DATED 201-920-2020 TWENTY
TWENTY TWENTY ONE TAX TAX
RETURN- AND THEN WE'LL BE
LOOKING AT WHETHER OR NOT YOU
HAVE HAD A FINANCIAL HARDSHIP
AND WOULD BE ANY INCOME THAT
YOU WOULD HAVE GENERATED FROM
AN UNEMPLOYMENT CHECK DID NT
FACTOR INTO THE- INCOME
QUALIFICATIONS. OKAY THIRTY
EIGHT- THANK YOU BECAUSE ON THE-
ON THE WEBSITE UP TO THIS POINT
THAT'S BEEN VERY UNCLEAR SO I
HOPE THAT WE CAN MAKE SOME
CLARIFICATIONS LIKE THAT I'VE
MADE EVERY WEEK MY OFFICE HAS
RECEIVED MANY. QUESTIONS FROM
CONSTITUENTS AND IT WAS-
UNCLEAR SO HOPEFULLY WE WILL BE
IMPROVING SOME OF THE
INFORMATION ON THAT WEBSITE-
LET'S MOVE TO A PUBLIC COMMENT
LET'S SEE FIRST IF THERE'S
ANYONE HERE IN THE GALLERY
WANTS TO MAKE PUBLIC COMMENT ON
THIS INFORMATIONAL ITEM WHICH
IS FICTION MORATORIUM IN RIGHT
REALLY FILL. SEEING NINE ALL
LOOKING TO OUR OTHER ROOM I
DON'T SEE ANY IN THE- AUXILIARY
ROOM. AND JUST ONE SECOND. US
SENATOR GROVE YOU HAD A
QUESTION OR COMMENT BEFORE I GO
TO PUBLIC COMMENT GO AHEAD AND
THAT IN TERRACE DO YOU WANT ME
TO WAIT TILL AFTER I DON'T KNOW
NO YOU PLEASE I JUST WANTED TO
CLARIFY- HONEST ON THE FOLLOW
UP THAT YOU JUST MADE THAT
QUESTION WAS DID I HEAR
CORRECTLY THAT IT WAS A DRESS
THAT- EDT PAYMENTS OR THE
SUPPLEMENTAL PAYMENTS WOULD NOT
BE CALCULATED INTO. THEM THE-
FORMULA FOR PROVIDING SOMEONE
WITH THIS- SUBSIDIZED RENT. IS
THAT WHAT THE RESPONSE WAS FROM
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. YES THAT
IS THAT IS CORRECT. CAN YOU
TELL ME JUST BASED ON WHAT THE
FORMULA IS REALLY QUICK WITH
THE FORMULA WILL BE- CALCULATED
ON. I'M YESTERDAY FORMULA FOR
AREA MEDIAN INCOME IS LOOKING
AT AND THE NUMBER OF I'M-
LOOKING AT YOUR YOUR YOUR
INCOME AND THEN IT'S ALSO
BEARING IN MIND THE NUMBER OF
AND HOUSEHOLD MEMBERS THAT-
FALL UNDER THAT INCOME. AND
THEN IT IS CALCULATED AS THE
RELATION TO YOU AND THE COUNTY
THAT YOU'RE LOCATED IN. AND TO
EACH JURISDICTION HAS A
DIFFERENT AREA MEDIAN INCOME-
AND THEN EACH HOUSEHOLD WILL
NEED TO CALCULATE BASED OFF OF
THEIR HOUSEHOLD MEMBERS TO SEE
WHERE THEY FALL WITHIN RELATE
TO THAT. ABOVE OR BELOW 80% OF
THE AREA MEDIAN INCOME. AND WE
UNDERSTAND THAT THAT IS COMPLEX
AND SO ONE OF THE THINGS THAT
WE HAVE DONE WITHIN THE PROGRAM
IF WE BUILT AN EIGHT. AM MY
CALCULATOR PULLED INTO THE
APPLICATION AND BALL AND INTO
OUR ELIGIBILITY QUIZ ON THE
HAPPINESS I THANK. TO BE ABLE
TO HELP- AND- BOTH HOUSEHOLDS
LANDLORD TENANT AND THAT YOU'RE
HELPING AT THE PEOPLE IN
COMPLETING YOUR APPLICATION.
AND MAKE THAT CALCULATION.
THANK YOU IS THE M. EDT. PAID
OUT CALCULATED INTERVIEW
THEY'RE A LOWER LEVEL OF WHAT
THE NATURAL INCOME WOULD BE. IN
ORDER TO ADD THAT IS CORRECT
AND IT'S ACTUALLY ONE OF THE-
ELIGIBILITY FACTORS THAT WE
LOOK AT AND WHEN WE'RE LOOKING
AT AN ELIGIBILITY FOR THE
PROGRAM. IF YOU HAVE QUALIFIED
FOR THAT COUPLE MENTAL ON
BEFORE AND THEN THAT IS ONE WAY
THAT YOU CAN DEMONSTRATE THAT
YOU HAVE HAD A FINANCIAL IMPACT
AND YOU QUALIFY FOR THE
PROGRAM. THANK YOU MA'AM THANK
YOU VERY MUCH THINKING ABOUT
INTERNET WITH THE PLEXIGLASS
IT'S HARD TO SEE AND I DO
APOLOGIZE FOR NOT LEAVING. AND
NOW WE'RE UNDER NO WORRIES IT
IS TRUE DOUBLE PLEXIGLASS MAKES
FUNNY GLARE AND I CAN ALWAYS
SEE HOWEVER. WE WILL NOW I
DON'T SEE ANY OTHER. MIKES UP
SO WE WILL GO TO. THE THE
REMOTE ACCESS PUBLIC COMMENT
AND THAT- PHONE NUMBER IS.
877-692-8957 THE ACCESS CODE IS.
ONE FOUR ZERO SEVEN SEVEN FOUR
FOUR. SO WE'LL HAVE- FIFTEEN
MINUTES FOR PUBLIC COMMENT ON
THIS INFORMATIONAL ITEM-
MODERATOR GO AHEAD T. UP. FOR
FOLKS WHO ARE CALLING IN. THANK
YOU JUST AS A REMINDER IF THEY
WOULD LIKE TO MAKE A COMMENT
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AND-
A LITTLE LINE SIXTY SIX SIX SIX
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. NO WONDER
WHAT ELSE WHEN YOU CAPTURE
CRAWFORD IN SUPPORT OF EIGHTY
EIGHT THREE TWO WITH VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE THE WORK THAT HAS
BEEN DONE- IN HELP YOU KNOW THE
MOST VULNERABLE PEOPLE.
THROUGHOUT THIS WHOLE TIME YEAH
THANK YOU. MODERATOR CONTINUE
YEAH WE HAVE ONE MORE COMING IN
JUST ONE MOMENT. IN ORDER TO
ALIGN SIXTY FIVE SIX FIVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU TONY WE
WITH THE HELP OF YOUR PARTNER'S
LOCATION- WE'RE HERE TODAY FOR
THE THIRD EXTENDING INTO SOME
MORE FOR YOU. TO LEAVE YOU MUST
AND YOU MUST AGREE THAT
INTEREST THEM MORE THAN ITS
FAIR SHARE FOR EACH MONTH MANY
HOW TO PROVIDE HER WITH LITTLE
OR NO WORK. AND IF WE'LL GET
ANOTHER THREE MONTHS BEFORE
THEY ARE REQUIRED TO PAY
ANYTHING. IT'S IMPORTANT TO
POINT OUT THOUGH THAT WOULD
YOU'D EXPECT IN THAT SECTION
HAS NOT ADDRESSED THE SITUATION
WHERE CAN WE TURN TO THE
QUESTION I DON'T KNOW WE DON'T
LEARN. THAT ABOUT WATER QUALITY
WE CAN YOU SPOT. THE
APPLICATION FOR LEAVE IN THE
MIDDLE OF THE NIGHT. SO ONLY
THING THAT WILL HELP WILL BRING.
TO YOUR- WE MIGHT NOT BE HERE
TO AT THE MY HAD COME. IT MAKES
YOU WISH TO ALL DEPENDS. FOR IN
MARCH. YESTERDAY THEY HAD
NOTHING. ALL THAT. I DO WANT
FIGURE SOME GOOD THINGS OWNERS
AND TENANTS IN THREE. WE
RECOVERED A PERCENT PREEMPTION
OF LOCAL THAT DIFFER FROM
EIGHTY EIGHT THREE TWO. TWO ONE
WE'RE GOING TO WITHIN A YOU
ABOUT. SO IN SUMMARY. A LOT
QUICKER BY ANY MEANS WHAT IS
THE ONLY OPTION HELPING QUITE
HAPPEN. THE EIGHTY WE'VE GIVEN
CRITICAL TO GET THIS BILL TO
THE GOVERNOR. AND TO SPEED UP
THE DISBURSEMENT OF RENTAL
ASSISTANCE DOLLARS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. WE HAVE OTHERS IN
THE- GO AHEAD YEAH WE HAVE- ONE
MORE MAN IF YOU'RE A LINE SIXTY
EIGHT SIX EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO THIS. IS ALEX WITH
WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS. WOULD LIKE
TO THINK LEADERSHIP ON THEIR
COMMITMENT TO PROTECT TENANTS
FROM EVICTION AND PROVIDE
NECESSARY RELIEF TO LANDLORDS
AND WHILE WE APPRECIATE YOU
1100% COMPENSATION. ABOVE THE
NATIONAL OTHER PROTECTION FOR
TENANTS. THE BILL IS- FAR FROM
PERFECT BUT IT IS NECESSARY. WE
ARE PARTICULARLY CONCERNED
ABOUT THE PREEMPTION OF LOCAL
LAWS IN THE BILL THAT WILL
LEAVE TENANT MARBLE FOR SIX
MONTHS AFTER THE LOOK THE
PROTECTIONS EXPIRE. AND HAVE
THE POTENTIAL TO CAUSE AN
EVICTION NONAME. WITH THAT SAID
WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY REMAINS NEUTRAL ON THE
BILL BUT WE ARE YOUR IDOLS IN
ORDER TO PROTECT. THOUSANDS OF
TENANTS THANK YOU. MADAM CHAIR
AND NO FURTHER COMMENTS THANK
YOU. ALL RIGHT- SINCE THIS IS
AN INFORMATIONAL ITEM WE'LL SEE
IF THERE'S ANY OTHER COMMENTER
QUESTIONED BY MEMBERS.
OTHERWISE WE WILL HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO VOTE LATER. AND
LET'S SEE. WE'VE TAKEN OUR
PUBLIC COMMENT WE HAVE NO MORE
ALL RIGHT SO I WANT TO THANK
EVERYONE FROM I DIDN'T SEE IT
BEFORE THANK THE INDIVIDUALS TO
PARTICIPATE IN PUBLIC TESTIMONY
BOTH ON THE BUDGET ITEMS DOWN
THIS IF YOU WERE UNABLE TO
TESTIFY TODAY PLEASE SUBMIT
YOUR COMMENTS OR SUGGESTIONS IN
WRITING TO THE BUDGET IN FISCAL
REVIEW COMMITTEE. YOU CAN DO
THAT THROUGH OUR WEBSITE AND I
APPRECIATE EVERYONE'S PATIENCE
INCORPORATION AND OF COURSE THE
STAFF'S INCREDIBLE WORK ON THIS
BUDGET I PUT IN HOURS BUT THEY
PUT IN AT LEAST QUADRUPLE WHAT
I DID SO THEY'VE BEEN-
PHENOMENAL AND WE WILL SEE YOU
ON THE FLOOR LATER TODAY AND
WITH THAT. THE COMMITTEE IS
ADJOURNED.